Musik
MonkaW
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Da bin ich.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Mittlerweile
bilde ich mir ein, habe ich gesehen,
kann man Paperless auch mit dem Handy
Sachen uploaden.
Das werden wir heute mal ausprobieren.
Also man kann wohl,
wenn man Paperless plus die passende
OCR-KI hat, kann man wohl einfach
ein Foto mit dem Handy machen und hochladen.
Pock.
So.
Zack. Okay, geht ja schon gleich los
hier.
Hey Max, Destiny fragt, hey Max, ich habe auf der Arbeit eine Pipeline geschrieben.
Pipeline was? GitLab? CI? GitHub Actions? Jenkins?
Wieso kann PowerShell auf meinem Ubuntu... Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment, Moment.
Wieso kann PowerShell auf einem Ubuntu kein SCP?
Alfred, danke schön für den Sub.
Warum benutzt du nicht einfach SCP?
Jetzt wird es mir zu wir.
Also erstens, erstens, erstens.
Okay, okay.
Erstens, warum PowerShell auf einem Linux?
Also ich weiß, dass es geht, aber ich weiß nicht genau warum.
SCP unter PowerShell unter Linux habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Das müsste doch aber ganz normal funktionieren, weil es ein ganz normales SCP-Kommando ist,
was mit PowerShell nichts zu tun hat.
und wieso ist köln aus einem inbock web request microsoft keine ahnung ganz
ehrlich ich finde powershell ist nur so semi nice powershell ist ganz gut und
windows zeug zu automatisieren aber so als interaktive shell finde ich
persönlich jetzt nicht so geil gut machst du jetzt ja auch nicht versucht
damit auch was zu automatisieren aber ganz im ernst wenn ich unter linux
wäre würde ich das mit einem der üblichen die noch scherz machen also in
der regel ein script was ist ja eigentlich meine tastatur los das rgb von meiner tastatur stimmt
nicht warum chat was ist da los wo sich vielleicht muss ich vielleicht dings starten die hub von logitech
hub logitech hub max weib kohle ist zu also wenn du damit meinst ich mache gar nichts mehr selbst
sondern lass einfach drei Stunden
irgendeinen Agent laufen, der mir dann irgendwas
halbgehares ausspuckt, dann mich
als Unterstützung
oder zum Ideen holen
oder so, wie könnte man machen, XY, um es dann
ordentlich zu machen, ja, dann mache ich das schon.
Hi Twitch, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog Subscriptions, Leute.
Exzellent.
Welches Model?
unterschiedlich.
Also für ganz kurz und knackige
Sachen, so wenn ich jetzt einfach
sag, okay, ähm, was weiß ich,
wie mache ich in
Go
eine Vorschleife
mit Index über ein
Array, sowas. Ich weiß, wie das
geht, ja. Dann benutze ich,
äh, ach, ich bin bei
Go, keck, Alter.
Was ich dann da in letzter
Zeit ganz gerne benutze, ist tatsächlich das
hier für so ganz kurz und knackige dinger diesen google ki modus oder chat
gpt wenn es ein bisschen was längeres ist kann ich ja auch zeigen was ich
benutze wenn sie ein bisschen was umfangreiches längeres ist der zugriff
braucht dac ai habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
ausprobieren mini ja okay ganz ehrlich
mistral small ich weiß nicht ob das taugt zumindest was ich was ich benutze
wenn man lokalen zugriff braucht auf sagen wir mal nehmen wir jetzt mal hier irgendwie das ist
der linux kölner da machen wir das vielleicht besser nicht drin was haben wir denn hier schön
ist hier der der ob mama okay hier das da nehmen wir einfach mal dass da glaubt das ist kein
programm das ist einfach nur ein docker file was irgendwas macht da benutze ich
auch ein code und zwar open code in kombination mit ich glaube ich habe
meine config kaputt gemacht kann kann das sein
ich glaube ich habe
Wo liegt denn das?
Warte mal.
Config, OpenCode.
OpenCode, JSON.
Ich habe hier irgendwas
das letzte Mal drin editiert und habe es kaputt gemacht.
Hier, da.
Wobei, ist doch... Gibt es das nicht mehr?
Ach, die haben das einfach umbenannt.
Okay, ja.
Ach, ist not available.
Ach, haben sie es mal wieder ausgeschaltet.
Interessant.
Zwischenzeitlich ging es wieder.
Ja, also was ich auch ganz gerne benutzt habe, solange es kostenlos war, war tatsächlich GLM 4.7.
Seit wann man Kommentare in JSON machen kann, seit es in JSON Standard, oder weiß nicht, ob es mal Standard ist, gibt für Kommentare in JSON.
Ja, das ist aber glaube ich kein offizieller, so rückwärtskompatibles Ding, was jetzt jeder JSON-Parser können muss.
Das ist irgendeine Extension.
Aber das geht mittlerweile.
Und ganz ehrlich, damit ist für mich persönlich fast jeder Vorteil von YAML weggefallen.
Weil YAML fuckt mich so extrem ab mit Einrückungen, das ist nicht mehr normal.
Ganz besonders schlimm, wenn YAML-Arrays gemischt sind mit normalem.
Da weißt du immer nicht, ist das jetzt ein Array-Element oder wo fängt das an.
Das ist eklig ganz ehrlich bin überhaupt kein jammel fan ich bin zwar halber jammel engineer
Weil ich mittlerweile so viel jammel am tag macht das mit zu haus kommt
Aber ich persönlich finde tatsächlich die jason mit commons kommons ist das einzige was mir in jason gefehlt hat so
du hast ein documents scanner also ich habe einen multi laser laser multifunktionsgerät
mit dem dokumenten einzug das tut es ja auch oder was meinst du
übrigens ufo wenn jemand spaß machen willst wenn du mal irgendein teams call
oder so hast ja und da ist ein englisch englisch speaker dabei fragt ihn mal
ob er sein vorname aussprechen kann ich bin extrem schwer
Moin, Boom Basti.
Ja, irgendwie tun uns mit anderen Wörtern auch noch schwer.
Splixxer, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, man muss sagen, PowerShell hat durchaus ein paar nice Ideen.
Es gibt einen zentralen Unterschied, den ich kenne.
Ja, ein zentraler Unterschied zwischen PowerShell und den Linux-Shells.
Unter Linux-Shells ist ja alles Text.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier sage, ls-la, grepp, plupp, ja, oder grepp, was ist da drin, zf, zf, oder, ja geil, was haben wir hier für einen Ordner?
Nee, docker, docker, so.
Wenn ich hier greppe, dann geht hier über diese Pipe Text.
Bei PowerShell ist das anders.
Würde mich mal interessieren, Chat, ob ihr das wisst, dass das, also ob euch der Unterschied klar ist, ja.
Also bei PowerShell kannst du ja auch ein Kommando ins andere pipen, nur mit der Unterschied ist,
wie gesagt, unter Linux ist das hier Text, was über die Pipe drüber geht, ja.
Standard out von dem Kommando, Kommando in Standard in von dem Kommando.
Bei PowerShell sind das .NET Objekte.
Deswegen kannst du beispielsweise in PowerShell so Dinger machen wie,
also dafür kenne ich PowerShell
zu schlecht aus dem Kopf, nur mal so beispielsweise, ja.
Also könntest du quasi sowas hier machen,
dir gepiped nach
ähm
irgendwie find
keine Ahnung, blub
folder.name oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Das kannst du in PowerShell machen,
das kannst du in
Bash nicht machen.
Also an sich finde ich PowerShell
vom Ansatz her eigentlich ganz
cool wie gesagt nicht als interaktive shell aber zur automatisierung finde ich
das eigentlich sehr nice auf die idee zu kommen dass irgendwie unter linux
einzusetzen das würde ich aber nicht übrigens chat erinnert ihr euch noch dran
letzten letzten stream wo wir hier mit dem mini pc rum gebastelt haben nicht
mit dem nass mit dem mini pc da habe ich auch deskflow ausprobiert deskflow hatte
doch das problem dass der mauszeiger immer in der mitte vom bildschirm
bleibt das problem von desk flow ist wenn man die portable version das wäre
uns übrigens auch noch mal ordentlich machen in einem der nächsten streams mit
dem mini pc da mache ich mir noch eine zweite ssd rein ich mache linux dual boot
auf dem mini pc einmal für mich privates linux und dann für streaming linux will
da nicht aus versehen irgendwelche sachen liegen deswegen mache ich einfach
zwei unterschiedliche ssds so dass man dazwischen umschalten kann ja wenn man
die portable version von desk flow benutzt dann hat man mit diesem
Mauszeiger in der Mitte. Wenn man die installierte Version von Deskflow verwendet, die unter der Haube irgendeinen Windows-Service benutzt, dann hat man das Problem mit dem Mauszeiger nicht.
Sofern man das Deskflow auf dem zweiten Desktop startet und nicht auf dem ersten.
Was auch immer.
Kommt bei dir ab und zu Schwäbisch durch? Ne.
Haupt nicht, ich komme aus Frankfurt.
In Hessen.
Richtig Windows-Kack-W
Übrigens, ich hab ja
Ich hab ja letztens
Oh, was denn?
Ich hab ja letztens rumgeraged
Ein bisschen über Windows
Auf Twitter, ne?
Hier
401 Likes
Da kommt der Assnack durch, genau
Frankfurt, Goethestraße, Louis Vitor Store
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
Kommt da durch.
Ja, da habe ich ja hier gepostet.
Da habe ich mich ein bisschen abgeraged über Windows 11.
Wie kacke mittlerweile Windows 11 ist.
Und da gab es wirklich, man glaubt das gar nicht,
aber da gab es wirklich erstaunlich viele Comments,
die mir sagen wollten, das ist falsch
und das geht ja alles über irgendwelche Registry-Hacks
und das ist ja überhaupt nicht der Ansatz davon,
also die übelst Microsoft verteidigt haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo man da im Gehirn sein muss,
2026, so krass Microsoft zu fanboyen.
Als gewinnt man da jetzt irgendwie den Fanboy des Jahres Award
oder der Microsoft CEO lädt dann auf seinen nächsten Geburtstag ein
und sagt dann, boah, hier, den Max auf Twitter,
dem hast du es aber gezeigt, gut, dass du uns da verteidigt hast.
Keine Ahnung, ja.
Also da gab es schon ein paar Spezialisten hier drunter.
Ihn meine ich hier übrigens nicht.
Da hat er seine Meinung kundgetan, da habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Ist ja alles in Ordnung.
Aber da gab es schon echt ein paar krasse Spezialisten.
Die man aber wahrscheinlich auf Nitta jetzt nicht gescheit findet.
Zumindest haben echt viele darauf geantwortet und auch gesagt,
sie geben mir rechts.
Aber manche haben auch richtig, richtig hart,
hart gefanboyt. Und einer,
noch viel geiler,
einer hat Microsoft übelst verteidigt.
Mal, ob ich das jetzt finde.
Also einer,
einer hat Microsoft übelst verteidigt.
Da habe ich ihm gesagt, dass das Blödsinn ist,
was er geschrieben hat. Und ob er
jetzt irgendwie hofft, dass ihn der Microsoft-CEO
auf seinen nächsten Geburtstag einlädt,
weil er hier so schön gefanboyt hat, hat er mich
instant geblockt. Ich habe ja erst
gedacht, der Typ trollt. Aber
dadurch, durch den Block, weiß ich jetzt,
der meint das ernst. Und das ist dem,
das hat er voll persönlich genommen,
anscheinend.
Nee, ich finde, ich
keine Ahnung, wo das kommentiert ist.
Das muss hier wahrscheinlich in irgendeinem
Thread drin sein, keine Ahnung.
Aber wie gesagt, ich war wirklich erstaunt,
wie viele Leute da Microsoft fanboyen
bei so einem Tweet.
Trollen ist aus, das heißt Ragebait.
Okay, das heißt Ragebait.
Das ist genauso wie eine Zeit lang
die Leute,
das war ja so ein Ding hier auf Twitch
teilweise so als als standard ausrede für alles ja irgendeiner stellt sich hin
beleidigt ein übelst regt sich übelst auf macht irgendwie ein fertig und dann
sagt er ein just role playing just role play role plays just role play also das
nächste mal wenn sich irgendwie einer beschwert und angegriffen fühlen kann
ich auch sagen was regt sich so auf ein just role play
Ja, Ragebait nennt man das jetzt.
Aber das war kein Ragebait.
Weil, dann hätte er mich nicht geblockt.
Sobald du geblockt wirst auf Twitter,
dann weißt du, okay, das haben die alles richtig ernst genommen.
Das war früher bei uns nicht anders, ja.
Da gab es auch Leute,
Alter, Max, du kackst Spast hier.
Nur Spaß, nur Spaß, nur Spaß.
So nach dem Motto, ja.
Die Leute, das gab es schon immer, die sich dann rausreden mit irgendwie sowas.
Genau, nur Experiment.
also können sie aufholen
xml größer chasen wünsche dir viel spaß mit xml ja nur ein prank prank dass das das gab es auch
Ich bin auch auf der Arbeit abhängig von Microsoft
Trotzdem finde ich es kacke
Okay, nice, Chat aufgeholt.
Alles nur Spaß, wann kommt ein neues Video?
Ich war die letzten Wochen teilweise ganz kurz davor.
Ich wollte ja einfach mal so ein Update machen,
warum ich das letzte Jahr nicht am Start war und sowas.
Aber warum ich das nicht mache, ist Folgendes,
weil ich keinen Bock habe, mir die Kommentare durchzulesen danach.
Das triggert mich dann wieder.
Das letzte...
Ja, ja, mir geht es nur ums letzte...
Ja, davor hatte ich einfach keinen Bock.
Hast du schon mal was mit Paperless gemacht?
Nein.
Noch nie.
Wir müssen übrigens, bevor wir Paperless ausprobieren können,
müssen wir das NAS...
Ja, ja, genau.
Müssen wir das NAS nochmal neu installieren.
Weil wir haben das hier das letzte Mal so versaut,
mit allem möglichen.
Das wird es, glaube ich, nochmal neu aufsetzen müssen
Installieren wir Proxmox nochmal neu
Und
Dann installieren wir
Paperless
Also mein Plan, mein Plan ist ja eigentlich folgendes
Wolltest du nicht nach Teneriffa
Um dort Rad zu fahren
Nach Teneriffa nicht
Also wenn ich mal in Urlaub fahre zum Radfahren
Dann nach Mallorca, wenn schon, weil das einfach näher ist
Aber nach Teneriffa würde ich auch mal gerne
Aber dann nehme ich mein Rad nicht mit
Ich fand die Idee ist nicht schlecht
Aber wenn schon, muss ich mir da eins ausleihen.
Genauso wie in Mallorca.
Aber nach Teneriffa würde ich tatsächlich gerne mal.
Weiß ich noch nicht.
Ich war auf, wie heißen diese Inseln?
Auf Lanzarote war ich schon mal.
Auf, wie heißen diese denn da?
Moment, Moment.
Teneriffa.
Zu was gehören die nochmal?
Sind es Kanaren?
Kanarische Insel, genau.
Da war ich schon auf ein paar.
Portaventura war ich schon.
Gran Canaria war ich schon.
Und auf Lanzarote war ich schon.
Genau.
La Palma war ich auch schon.
Bei den anderen noch nicht.
Aber das ist schön, da würde ich auch gerne mal wieder hin.
Ja, ja, das ist schon lange her.
Das ist schon lange her.
Ich war die letzten 10 Jahre oder so nicht mehr im Urlaub irgendwo.
Weil ich altes Informatiker-Kellerkind bin und keinen Bock darauf habe.
Aber, mal gucken.
Vielleicht kann ich mich ja tatsächlich dazu durchringen, demnächst mal in Urlaub zu fahren.
Was auf den Kanarischen Inseln sogar gut geht, weil ich kann, ich darf sogar bis zu sechs Wochen am Stück,
darf ich, glaube ich, Vacation machen.
Länger als sechs Wochen geht nicht.
Also sprich, ich fahre quasi in Urlaub,
arbeite dort aber remote tagsüber
und den restlichen Tag bin ich dann halt im Urlaub.
Echt sehr nice.
Länger als sechs Wochen am Stück geht nicht,
weil es dann rechtlich Steuerprobleme gibt.
Haben sie mir erzählt in der Versicherung.
Das darf man nicht.
Länger als sechs Wochen am Stück.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
mal so drei Wochen in Urlaub,
tagsüber remote arbeiten,
Ja, ist, genau, deswegen ja, ist ja Spanien, deswegen geht das auch, es geht nur innerhalb von der EU
Deswegen denke ich, man geht in kanarische Inseln, geht wahrscheinlich voll klar
Und was ist mit uns, Max, wieso, ich kann doch sogar streamen von da, ich brauche bloß ein Hotel mit ordentlichem WLAN
Wobei, ich kann nicht streamen von da, weil ich meinen PC nicht dabei habe
Und Notebook habe ich nicht, außer das von der Arbeit
Du willst Vacation von daheim machen?
Ah ja.
Ich mache in letzter Zeit wenig Homeoffice.
Aber nicht, weil ich gezwungen wurde oder so.
Sondern weil mich das ablenkt, alles in Frankfurt.
Deswegen fahre ich öfters jetzt nach Frankfurt.
War ich ganz nice.
Nee, IRL.
Genau.
IRL-Stream am Strand.
Ganz bestimmt.
Ja, weil ich so der große IRL-Streamer bin.
So, was wollte ich jetzt gerade machen, Chat?
Jetzt habe ich es voll vergessen.
Das Ganze ja ungefähr gleiche Temperatur.
Ja.
Brock.
Was futterst du so in Frankfurt?
Also, ich esse meistens bei uns in der Kantine.
Aber was ich richtig feiere in letzter Zeit, wo ich relativ oft hingehe, also fast einmal die Woche mittlerweile.
manchmal sogar zweimal die Woche, bei Londoner Woche
und am Wochenende.
Was ich richtig mag hier ist das hier, Frankfurt.
Cheating.
Ja.
Da gibt es nämlich
Korean Fried Chicken. Das, was ihr hier seht,
könnt ihr alles vergessen, ja. Das hier ist nice.
Die Dinger, das ist richtig
pock, Leute. Richtig pock.
Das ist
schön knusprig, Kruste-mäßig
Chicken mit so
bisschen scharfer
Soße drüber, Reis dabei
und ich hab
den
Lifehack entdeckt, wie man das so schön nennt
bei dem Laden. Man bestellt
sich einfach ein Mittagsmenü, hier mit
dem Chicken und einem Reis dabei
und dann bestellt man sich für 1,50
oder einem Euro, ich weiß es gar nicht, 1 Euro oder
1,50 noch ein extra Reis
dabei. Danach ist man richtig
voll und es kostet nur
1,50 mehr.
Ist das in der Nähe vom Bahnhof? Ja.
Ja.
Maps, Google, Frankfurt.
Das ist
direkt
eigentlich
fast gegenüber vom Bahnhof.
Guck hier.
Hier ist der Bahnhof.
Hier ist der Hauptbahnhof.
Da ist Tchiking.
Die Ecke ist halt eklig, ja.
Da kennst du das.
Das Pock, ja.
Die Ecke ist halt ein bisschen eklig hier.
Also wenn man das Zimmer davor
mal street viewt.
Hier hinten,
weiß nicht, ob man es sieht, müssen wir mal gucken.
Hier hinten hängen immer
fragwürdige Leute rum.
Aber anscheinend hier gerade nicht.
Hier in der Ecke
hängen immer merkwürdige Leute rum.
Hier auch.
Aber hier anscheinend auch gar nicht.
Hier doch da.
oder naja die sehen eigentlich noch halbwegs normal aus aber da hängen öfters komische leute
rum hier in der ecke her da ist auch so ein matratzenlager hier davor auf das wo die leute
dann rum gammeln den ganzen tag also ist die ecke ist nicht so geil aber der laden ist der laden
hier ist echt rogers ach ja wo wir gerade in frankfurt sind wenn ihr wenn ihr euch dann mal
ein bisschen so den den kulturschock oder den stück mit bisschen schocken
wollt in frankfurt dann geht ihr einfach die straße weiter runter hier und dann
kommt ihr irgendwann hier geht schon elbe straße war wir nehmen wir sind wir
sind einst zu weit vorne wir sind einst zu weit vorne glaube ich genau hier sind
ja gar nicht die ganzen ja doch doch doch doch genau hier ist auch irgendwo
glaube ich die drogen ausgabe stelle hier hast du schon die die üblichen
verdächtigen am start aber niederstraße ist noch besser
frankfurt niederstraße
das haben die irgendwann frühmorgens aufgenommen wollte gerade sagen wo sind
ja alle aber du hast hier schon spezialisten am start was ist das hier
links ich hatte ja vor ein paar jahren meine lebensmittel vergiftung und meine
vermutung meine vermutung war ja immer die kam von dem rahm schnitzel was ich
mir hier bei einem liefer service bestellt habe und wie heißt die straße
was du meinst da wo du nicht hingehen oder wo es ekliger wie gesagt mit der
straße elbe straße so die eckhaus straße da so die ecke tausend straße ist auch
toll
frankfurt taunus straße ist auch nicht nicht sehr nicht sehr pockwieser straße
und sowas. Die ganzen Ecken
hier.
Wobei das hier geht. Ne, ne, ne. Die ist okay.
Die ist okay.
Die ist okay. Aber da vorne.
Ja, ich hatte
noch eine Lebensmittelvergiftung.
Leipzig. Das habe ich
überhaupt nicht so erlebt. Ich war ja ein paar
Mal schon in Leipzig und Dresden am Bahnhof.
Habe ich überhaupt nicht erlebt, dass das angeblich so gefährlich
ist. Habe ich auch letztens
gelesen. Also, was ich sagen wollte.
ich hatte ja vor ein paar Jahren eine Lebensmittelvergiftung.
Hatte ich, ähm,
das ist schon eine ganze Weile her, da hatte ich
Campylobacter. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das
schreibt.
Ham-
Am-
Pylo-
Eier, da, guck mal.
Campylobacter.
So sah es dann wahrscheinlich bei mir im Darm aus, ja.
So, und
da habe ich ja damals die, da kriegt man
einen richtig ekligen, äh,
Dünnschiss im Endeffekt, ja.
Und es blutet dann auch und sowas.
Ganz, ganz tolles Zeug.
Naja, zumindest ist das auch alles wieder vorbei.
Und so überhaupt kein Ding.
Und meine Vermutung damals war,
ich hab das vom Rahmschnitzel,
was ich mir bei einem Lieferservice bestellt hab.
Und ich hab damals bei dem Lieferservice geguckt,
es gibt hier nämlich was ganz Nices.
Verbraucherfenster Hessen.
Da gibt es so eine Seite, wo man sehen kann,
ob es Lebensmittel, ähm,
oder so Warnungen für Restaurants
gibt. So was gibt's
mittlerweile, ja.
Und
als ich das dann hier im Stream gucken wollte,
hatte der Laden leider gerade keine
Warnung, keine, keine
Sachen mehr drin, bei dem ich damals
bestellt hab.
Und ich glaube,
da hat dann auch der Besitzer gewechselt und ich dachte
schon, ey, letztens hab ich mir erst
überlegt, ey, sollst du da mal wieder
bestellen? Vielleicht sind die gar nicht
so schlecht mittlerweile.
Aber jetzt habe ich letztens
hier reingeguckt.
Habe ich
letztens hier reingeguckt und habe festgestellt
Moment, wo ist
Hanau? Chat?
Frankfurt?
Langselbold?
Hanau?
Hier unten?
Großauheim?
Ja.
Also ich sage nicht, dass ich...
mal ganz hier, bevor die mich verklagen,
ja, ich sage nichts,
dass ich eine Lebensmittelvergiftung
von denen hatte. Ich sage nur,
dass ich in dieser Zeit
dort bestellt habe und ansonsten
nur Sachen von daheim gegessen habe, okay?
So, und die haben wieder jetzt eine neue
Warnung.
Also anscheinend war das, äh,
damals, als die eine Warnung
hatten, nicht nur eine einfache
Geschichte. Guck mal, die haben
die haben hier drei Seiten voll. Drei Seiten mit
Zeug. Guckt euch das mal an.
Mängel waren behoben am 5.11.
Aha, aha.
Nicht ordnungsgemäß
gereinigt.
Dunkle, schmierige Ansammlungen festgestellt.
Teigmaschine war im Gehäusebereich
über dem Knethang mit angetrocknetem
behaftet
Lagerbereich, Kühlzellen.
Da ist es eklig, ja.
Also, und ich hab überlegt, jetzt, ich bestell da jetzt demnächst mal wieder, weil, ne, haben sich anscheinend wirklich gebessert, aber anscheinend, und mittlerweile haben sie sich ja wieder gebessert, vielleicht bestell ich dann doch lieber nicht.
Also, ich mein, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf hier, ja.
Deswegen bestelle ich da höchstwahrscheinlich jetzt doch nicht.
Prog.
So.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
nur gut dann installieren wir mal box und dann also von der idee her dass er eigentlich was ich
sagen würde was ich was ich eigentlich vor habe bin ich nicht sicher ob ich das heute mache und
zwar xkali draw wenn wir jetzt mal das benutzt ja die coolen leute jetzt ist ja out wie macht
man hier was neues.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich löscht das einfach alles. Zack.
Was ich eigentlich machen will, ist
folgendes. Also hier, Proxmox.
Proxmox.
Dadrauf, und dann machen wir das mal groß hier.
Okay, hier Proxmox-Kiste.
Dadrauf will
ich eine VM
mit
ähm
Dock Ploy
Das müssen wir hier rein machen
Kann man das verschieben?
So
Dock Ploy
Und da drinnen will ich dann
Container mit
Paperless. Also so
mein Plan.
Was ich mir in der Tat
etwas
herausfordernd vorstelle ist,
ich habe ja da drinnen
eine
Radeon.
Ich habe ja eine Radeon
780M
oder irgendwie sowas. Oder 870M?
Ne, ich glaube 780M.
780M
habe ich ja da.
Das Problem ist, jetzt muss ich jetzt irgendwie gucken, wie ich die hier von dem Host quasi da rein bekomme.
Warum noch Docploy?
Weil es relativ easy Plattform ist, um Services und eigene Anwendungen laufen lassen zu können.
Das ist mir auch lieber als alles selbst zu installieren in LXC Container oder so.
Ich hab eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Also soweit der Plan.
Mal gucken wie gut das funktioniert.
Den ersten Step gibt es mit PCIe Path Through.
Müsste das funktionieren?
keine Ahnung, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ja, also
da habe ich schon gelesen, dass es echt problematisch
sein soll, die GPU durchzureichen
an eine VM.
Das
kann ich mir auch vorstellen, weil
die
GPU wird ja unter anderem benutzt
von der Konsole
für Grafikrausgabe,
das mit Konsole hat an der Kiste, ja.
Also mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Also schauen wir mal, ob da
pci express part 2 ordentlich funktioniert habe ich schon gelesen
problematisch ist ja und dann doch neu weiterreichen an paperless keine ahnung
wie gut das funktioniert das müssen wir mal schauen ich bin mir übrigens aber
nicht sicher weil heute will ich hauptsächlich mal paperless ausprobieren
ob ich das gleiche in doch pläne mache ich glaube das machen wir dann einen
der nächsten streams wie gesagt wir müssen das ganze das ja noch ordentlich
einrichten, auch mit Samba-Shares und allem.
Da können wir uns die nächsten Streams dann ein bisschen
drüber auslassen.
Das heißt, wenn ihr dabei sein wollt, Leute, ihr wisst ja,
jetzt am besten follow.
Ich mag das, wenn man
grüne Pfeile hat, die nach oben gehen, so.
Donks.
Alles klar, so ist der Plan.
Wie ich das später mal haben will.
Gut, äh, Chat.
Also, dann loggen wir uns mal kurz
auf meiner
USV ein. Ach, Schwachsinn, USV.
KVM.
MonkaS, Alter. Das passiert,
Leute. Das passiert,
wenn man schneller spricht als denkt.
Erst entfolgen, dann wieder folgen.
Das bringt unterm Strich nichts.
Aber wenn es dich glücklich macht, den Button drücken zu können,
dann let's go.
Dass das passiert,
wenn man schneller denkt, oder besser gesagt,
schneller spricht als denkt, dann sagt man, ich muss mich auf
meiner usv einloggen auf der anderen seite wiederum chat
haltet jetzt für ausgeschlossen dass man sich per ssh auf der usv einloggen kann
ich meine ich kann mich per ssh immerhin auf meinem dvbc receiver im wohnzimmer
einloggen per ssh und hätte ich neueren klo könnte ich mich auch per ssh auf
mein Klo einloggen.
Die
APC-Dinger können das. Also meine
Dinger können kein SSH. Ich hab
hier noch so eine ganz olle, billige. Also
früher hatte ich mal eine Cyberpower
USV
mit sonst was.
So eine 1HE
Cyberpower.
So ein Ding hier in der Richtung hatte ich mal.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die das war, aber die sah
sehr ähnlich aus.
Die hat mich aber schwer enttäuscht
Diese USV
Die hat mich schwer enttäuscht
Den einzigen Ausfall
Längeren Ausfall, den ich in meinem
Rack hier bisher hatte
War, als die Batterie in der USV
Kaputt gegangen ist
Also eigentlich genau das, was man nicht haben will
Nicht der Strom ist ausgefallen, sondern
Die Batterie in der USV und daraufhin
Ging nichts mehr, was an der USV
Dran hing, was eigentlich nicht sein sollte
Ja, whatever, aber es war so.
Und mittlerweile habe ich so eine ganz billige, so eine ganz billige, sowas hier irgendwie in der Richtung.
Gibt es APC Green oder irgendwie sowas?
Äh.
War das online oder Line Interactive?
Eigentlich glaube ich war es Line Interactive, was heißt es sollte nicht passieren.
Irgendwie so ein Ding in der Richtung, ich weiß nicht genau.
Ja, irgendwie so. Irgendwie so in der Richtung sieht meine USV aus, glaube ich.
Und da habe ich es auch schon ausprobiert.
Wenn du da einfach den Stecker ziehst, dann schaltet es um.
Und wenn du die Batterie im laufenden Betrieb rausziehst, was geht, passiert auch nichts.
Also, genauso wie es sein muss.
Das ist sicherlich nicht die hochwertigste USV, aber so kurze Sachen tut es.
Und es hat auch letztens tatsächlich vor so anderthalb Jahren, gab es hier mal einen Stromausfall.
das habe ich gar nicht gemerkt
dass es einen Stromausfall gab
weil mein USV hat das ordentlich gecheckt
woran ich es gemerkt habe, der Raspberry Pi
im Keller hatte sich rebooted
und
wirklich gemerkt, dass was war
ist, dass ich beim Bäcker nicht mit Karte
bezahlen konnte
da war ein Bäcker drin, wollte mit Karte bezahlen
und die mussten irgendwie ihr Terminal da 5 mal
rebooten, das hat nicht funktioniert
bis sie dann gesagt haben
ja das ist heute Morgen seit dem Stromausfall
Sonst hätte ich es gar nicht mitgekriegt
Und dann ist mir gedämmert
Ach, deswegen ging mein Raspberry Pi im Keller heute Morgen nicht mehr
Weil Stromausfall
Sonst hätte ich davon nichts gemerkt
Also die bringt schon
Ich mache mal kurz übrigens hier ein Update in der VM
Schade, nix
alles update kurz gucken was die jetbrains dinger machen ob wir die auch abdecken können
okay das dauert jetzt wieder 69 stunden zwei minuten wird das jetzt wahrscheinlich dauern
ich warte mal bis die durch sind der becker ist tatsächlich einer derjenigen die bisschen mit
der zeit gehen weil ansonsten wollen die ja immer bei uns nur barzahlung und sowas neben
bei dem also der wisst ihr es gibt zwei läden wo ich öfters hingehen wo ich
nicht mit karte bezahlen kann das erste ist der barbershop ich will
ihnen jetzt nichts unterstellen aber ich kann mir schon denken warum die keine
karten annehmen ja und das nächste ist der eisladen und da denke ich gehe ich
auch mal von aus ich weiß warum die keine zahlung annehmen
Das sind die einzigen zwei Läden, wo ich noch ab und zu Bargeld brauche.
Ansonsten ist das rein mit Karte.
Das ist sogar so, weil ich bezahle sogar so viel alles nur noch mit Karte bzw. Apple Pay,
dass ich letztes Mal sogar meine PIN vergessen hatte für den Automat von der Karte.
Ich bin da wieder drauf gekommen, ja, aber so selten benutze ich die.
Ich hole mir gefühlt einmal im Jahr Geld, das reicht dann, weil ich alles nur noch mit Apple Pay bezahle.
So.
Jetzt haben wir hier alles installiert.
Installiert, installiert.
Schön Supply Chain Angriffe wahrscheinlich.
Jetzt ist das ganze System infiziert.
Und jetzt machen wir noch Jetbrains Sachen Update.
So.
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind, wir können ja schon mal, während wir...
Ne, das können wir nicht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wir könnten schon mal ein Proxmox Install anschmeißen, während wir rebooten.
Aber das ist keine allzu gute Idee, weil dann vergesse ich...
rechtzeitig zu klicken.
Es gibt ja so ein Subreddit.
Kennt ihr das Subreddit?
Äh, bitte laminiert?
Oder so ähnlich heißt das.
Da werden immer Bilder gepostet, unter anderem
von Läden,
die Zettel raushängen, warum bei ihnen
Barzahlung nicht möglich ist.
Oder dass sie keine Barzahlung wollen.
Oder nur unter ganz bestimmten Umz...
Äh, nee, sorry, nicht Barzahlung.
Sie keine Kartenzahlung wollen.
So rum.
Sie wollen nur Barzahlung.
Und haben dann immer irgendwelche Begründungen.
Oder ganz komische Ausnahmen.
Warum das mit Karte nicht geht.
Da gibt es teilweise echt abenteuerliche Sachen bei.
Ja, ja.
Wie gesagt.
Ich gehe auch stark davon aus.
Da wird einer abgerechnet und einer nicht.
Steuertechnisch.
Wie ist das bei Apple Pay?
Wer bekommt dann da die Gebühren?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, juckt mich auch nicht
Letztendlich
Ist das ja das gleiche, wenn du mit Karte bezahlst
Das ist ja so kontaktloses Bezahlen
Keine Ahnung
Apple kriegt da bestimmt irgendwie ein bisschen was ab
Keine Ahnung, juckt mich nicht
Ich muss dafür nicht mehr bezahlen
Geht mir am Arsch vorbei
Mir geht mittlerweile eh erstaunlich vieles am Arsch
Wobei es interessiert mich teilweise auch gar nicht
Hauptsache es funktioniert
Und wenn das nicht funktioniert
Ich bin mittlerweile an dem Punkt angekommen
Dass mich Sachen die nicht funktionieren
Instant so abfacken
Dass ich sie einfach ignoriere und nicht benutze
Ja und dann lache ich mich immer kaputt
Wenn dann wieder rumgeheult wird
Von irgendwelchen Stellen
Oh die Leute kommen gar nicht mehr vorbei
Und oh der Einzelhandel stirbt
Und hier und da und ganz furchtbar schlimm
Dann mach es halt so
Oder ich bei euch gerne einkaufen gehe und nicht instant abgefuckt bin, wenn ich nur euren Laden sehe.
Da komme ich auch.
Aber ich gehe nirgendswohin, wo ich mich abgefuckt fühle.
Gut.
Letztens.
Bestes Beispiel.
Es gibt hier so einen Laden.
die machen Schnitzel
all you can eat.
So.
Denkt man sich ja erst einmal, angeblich
furchtbar nice.
Schnitzel all you can eat.
Ich habe im Vorfeld ein bisschen im Internet
schon geguckt
und da habe ich rausgefunden, na ok
ganz so furchtbar geil
ist das nicht.
Moment.
Ähm, so.
Was wollte ich denn sagen?
Schnitzel, Schnitzel, all you can eat.
Genau, da habe ich im hinteren Vorfeld rausgefunden,
allzu geil ist das wohl nicht,
weil das zum größten Teil einfach Metro-Tiefkühl-Schnitzel
oder sowas sind.
Das ist besser, was ich daheim mache.
Aber ich dachte mir, okay, wisst ihr was?
Können das ja mal ausprobieren.
Ähm, ich wusste allerdings nicht genau, wie das läuft.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie so ein Schnitzel-Oleokanin laufen kann.
Ja, es gibt vielleicht ein Buffet.
Vielleicht muss man jede Schnitzel einzeln bestellen.
Und dann ist immer eine Viertelstunde Lücke zwischen dem Schnitzel und so.
Naja, zumindest bin ich hin.
Und habe gesagt, ja, ich würde gerne Schnitzel-Oleokanin machen.
Aber vorher wollte ich mal fragen, wie das abläuft.
Also sprich, gibt es da eine Theke vorne?
Gibt es da irgendwie ein Buffet?
oder kann ich vielleicht gleich
drei Stück gleichzeitig stellen, dass wir keine 15 Minuten
Pause haben oder sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, und dann hat er zu mir
gesagt, das wird so gemacht, wie es hier
üblich ist.
Und dabei habe ich mir schon gedacht, okay, weißt du was?
Ich will's
gar nicht weiter wissen. Ihr könnt
mich mal. Ich esse hier nix.
Ganz ehrlich, da muss sich
keiner danach beschweren. Oh, die Leute
kommen nicht mehr zu uns. Wir gehen alle
pleite wenn ich so eine scheiß antwort krieg auf die frage ja der mann hat aber
nicht gelogen das stimmt aber ich habe mich übelst gebettet gefühl ja der
hätte oder vor allem so wenn ich wäre also ganz ehrlich ich gebe mittlerweile
nirgends wo mehr geld aus wo ich mich nicht wohl fühle und da habe ich mich
ins sind nicht mehr wohl gefühlt okay kein schnitzel all you can eat macht es
wie es hier üblich ist, ich gehe woanders hin.
Und so mache ich
mittlerweile bei vielem, ja.
Ich streite mich gar nicht mehr groß rum.
Ja, genauso wie mich die eine auf dem
Fahrrad da über den Haufen gefahren hat,
da habe ich auch erst gedacht,
ah, ist ja nicht viel passiert,
kannst du bestimmt selbst klären.
So, und als es dann wieder ein bisschen klarer im Kopf war,
habe ich mir gedacht,
Max, Max, Max, Max, bist du dumm?
warum willst du da selbst irgendwas klären?
Einfach direkt Anwalt übergeben,
nächsten Tag, gut,
am Wochenende, Montag,
direkt einfach Anwalt übergeben und gut ist?
Überhaupt einfach gar nicht mehr stressen,
ja, einfach sobald
irgendwas ist, wo man denkt, ey, die können einem blöd kommen,
einfach nicht machen, ja,
weil ich keinen Bock habe, Geld auszugeben,
für irgendwas, wo ich mich nicht wohlfühle, oder einfach
irgendjemanden für einen machen lassen.
Und in dem Fall war das sogar gut,
dass ich zum Anwalt bin,
weil die dann am Endeffekt rumgenervt haben mit von wegen,
ah, die Rechnung, die ich ihnen geschickt habe, das wäre ja viel billiger mittlerweile und bla bla bla bla.
Es hat ewig, ich habe ein halbes Jahr gewartet, bis ich die komplette Zahlung hatte wegen dem Fahrrad.
Einfach nicht mehr stressen lassen.
Das ist mittlerweile da so meine Devise bei vielem.
Einfach nicht mehr stressen lassen, ja.
Und wenn irgendwie einer meint, das müsste so sein, dann gehe ich halt woanders hin.
Es gibt immer noch Dinger, da geht es nicht anders, ja.
Wenn ich mich mit irgendwelchen Behörden auseinandersetzen musste, so manchmal kommt es halt nicht drumherum, ja.
Auch ist man immer abgefuckt, aber trotzdem.
Sofern es sich vermeiden lässt, mache ich das nicht.
Sobald ich irgendwo hingehe, ja, und denke, und ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich quasi betteln muss, dort mein Geld ausgeben zu können,
dann sage ich auch, wisst ihr was, lenkt mich, tschüss.
Bestes Beispiel auch.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich bestellt habe.
Ich habe online beim Saturn irgendwas bestellt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was es war.
Wie gerade?
Sagen wir einfach mal Ramp.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung mehr, was es war.
Zumindest bin ich online in den Shop vom Saturn und habe das bestellt.
weil da stand in der filiale in hanau ist das lagern und man kann es gleich abholen also online
bestellt filiale hanau ausgewählt nach hanau gefahren in den saturn gegangen und die man das
ist nicht da wie das ist nicht da steht doch bei euch auf der homepage ist es lagert hier in hanau
und ich kann es abholen naja das müssen wir dann erst mal bestellen das ist dann nächste woche da
ja okay gut was studieren macht es gut habe ich nicht gesagt habe ich mir gedacht ja ich habe mir
gedacht macht's gut ihr pisser storniert und gut ist nie wieder hingegangen
ich sehe es mittlerweile einfach nicht mehr ein ich bettel nicht um mein geld
ausgeben zu dürfen dann wird halt bei amazon bestellt dann
warte ich halt ein tag bei amazon und mittlerweile geht vieles auch same day
delivery sogar bei mir von amazon die müssen sich alle nicht beschweren ganz
ehrlich viele gerade der läden die besonders rumheulen oder kommt ja keiner
mehr lokal hin? Ja, weil sie kacke sind.
Ich geh doch nicht in den Laden,
geb da mein Geld aus, lass mich kacke behandeln.
Wenn ich irgendwo hingehe und mein Geld ausgib, dann will ich
halbwegs normal behandelt werden.
So.
Das war jetzt kein Ragebait, wie man es so schön nennt.
Sehe ich wirklich so.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich schon rebooted, Chat?
Äh.
Chat, ich bin braindead. Habe ich jetzt schon rebooted
oder nicht?
Äh, Uptime 6 Minuten. Ja, habe ich.
Okay.
Das war mehr ein Rant.
Genau, das war ein Rant.
Ja, Ragebait wäre zum Beispiel,
wenn ich sage,
ich hasse alle meine Prime-Subscriber.
Ich hasse es,
wenn ihr per Prime subscribt.
Wäre das Ragebait?
Ich mag euch übrigens auch nicht, wenn ihr nicht Prime subscribt.
Ich mag euch nie.
Das wäre Ragebait, oder?
Genau, sehe ich auch so.
Was ich ein bisschen blöd finde,
es gab früher mal Frankfurt
Zeil.
Konrad gab es da mal.
Ähm.
Moment.
das gibt's wieder?
Ne, dauerhaft geschlossen. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
da gab es mal in Konrad,
das war eigentlich ganz praktisch,
wenn man nämlich kleine Elektroteile
gebraucht hat, ja?
Vom
Widerstand
bis zu irgendeinem Relay
oder irgendwelche
Jumpergabel
oder so, so kleine Elektronikkram,
da war der Konrad echt praktisch.
Da konntest du
hingehen die hatten da so ein elektro ausgabe ding das gesagt ich brauche
jetzt zehn widerstände mit dem und dem du hast es gekriegt dass das das war
richtig nice
und die haben die haben also das ist so laden hat ja immer ein gutes gefühl wenn
ich da rein bin das sind leider auch schade schade dass
der zugemacht hat.
Moncastir.
Ja, sowas von Moncastir.
Wie hieß denn der andere Laden nochmal?
Es gab zwei größere
Elektronikdinger.
Konrad und
wie hieß der andere?
Reichelt.
Reichelt, genau.
Reichelt, nicht Rieschelt.
Reichelt.
Gibt's den noch?
Okay, die gibt's noch.
Die gibt's noch.
Bastelgarage.ch
Was ist denn Bastelgarage.ch?
Also auf jeden Fall was
Schweizerisches.
Hacker.
Ach guck mal, da gibt's sogar 3D-Drucker.
Raspberry Pi.
Das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Okay, jetzt muss ich mal gucken
Was kosten sowas in der Schweiz
Also, nehmen wir mal irgendwie ein ESP32
Board
In der Schweiz sind die Sachen schon teuer
Alter
WTF
1,20 Euro für ein Firebeak
Das ist übrigens ein ziemlich gutes Low-Power-Board
Aber die Sachen in der Schweiz kosten schon ordentlich
Kohle
hier wird der kram aber auch immer teurer
reichelt hatte doch nie läden das kann sein aber den habe ich öfters online
schon bestellt
berry base habe ich auch schon viel bestellt wo ich auch schon öfters
bestellt habe ist links hier pimo roni
Das ist irgendein Shop in UK, aber die liefern oder liefert hin relativ günstig nach Deutschland.
Ja, da konntest du zum Beispiel sowas wie Automation, irgendwie solche Dinger, ja, konntest du da bestellen relativ günstig mit Lieferung nach Deutschland.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch der Fall ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Euro.
Close.
22 Euro. Add to Cart.
Gucken, wie der Versand ist.
Ob das irgendwie da steht.
Checkouts.
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Max, hast du die neue Zollregelung der EU gelesen?
Du meinst, dass China-Chinesen-Pakete
teurer werden?
Oder was meinst du?
Zollregel. Also ich habe gelesen, dass Pakete aus...
dass das jetzt anders besteuert wird, dass es jetzt irgendeine
Pauschalbezahlung...
Pauschalzahlung oder so geben soll
pro Paket. Habe ich glaube ich gelesen
bei Sendungen aus China.
Wisst ihr was? Das können wir ganz
einfach dodgen, indem wir
einfach mehr
also größere Pakete
bei AliExpress bestellen.
Ich bestelle dann einfach nicht mehr
drei Pakete bei AliExpress,
sondern ich bestelle einfach ein großes
Paket bei AliExpress und kaufe noch mehr ein,
als ich vorher eingekauft hätte, weil ich ja ein großes
Paket brauche.
Easy.
Genau.
So, aber jetzt müssen wir mal hier langsam
anfangen.
Zack. Was habe ich hier aufgemacht?
Neue Eröffnung in Frankfurt.
Ja, von wegen.
Der Konrad hat die Filiale geschlossen.
Ist das ab Juni? Ja, ich glaube, es dauert noch ein bisschen.
So, also.
Dann wollen wir mal
Chatke, ich muss mal kurz den Strom einschalten am NAS.
Und dann installieren wir Proxmox nochmal neu.
So, KVM ist an.
Strom ist angeschlossen.
Strom ist aber noch nicht hinten in das NAS gestöpselt.
Achso, bevor wir anfangen.
Ich zeige für alle nochmal kurz das NAS.
Das ist nämlich eine echte Poggers-Hardware.
Einziges Problem, was ich bisher gefunden habe, ist,
dass der Linux Support des 10 Gigabit Netzwerk Adapters noch, nennen wir es mal, Lücken behaftet ist.
Es gibt noch Optimierungspotenzial, wie man da jetzt Marketing-Sprech sagen würde.
Deswegen installieren wir heute wahrscheinlich da ein DKMS Modul von Realtek.
Aber gucken wir mal. Was wollte ich jetzt machen?
also genau
in fünf was übrigens auch was übrigens auch witzig ist
wenn ihr beim minis forum hingeht
wenn der mini minis forum de
Wenn du beim minis forum de hingehst gehst hier produkt all products mini pc others nas
Ist dumm.
Wo ist es denn?
All Products?
Wo zum Teufel?
Aha.
Ach, guck mal.
Die haben es angepasst.
Die hatten hier eine komische KI-Übersetzung drin.
Das hat sich nicht Minisforum N vermittelt.
er genannt sondern mini sport 5 luft
Gucken ich gehe da mal hin vielleicht will ich hier browser mache
Also haben sie anscheinend gefixt das heißt nicht mehr luft
Minis forum in fünf luft
Ne, die haben es gecheckt
Okay, es wird nicht mehr mit Luft übersetzt
Bei Minis V muss man den RAM noch zusätzlich kaufen
Ja
Gut, wenn man noch 32 GB RAM hat
Weil der Kram ist unsinnig
Da steht es noch, N5 Luft
Guck mal, N5 Luft
in fünf luft
ja und die hardware ist echt da ist man bekommt ein relativ stromsparende kiste
also ich habe ein bisschen bio settings gemacht und mit drei ssds trainer braucht
das ding eitel 12 watt kann sich nicht beschweren
ihr wisst jetzt auf eine alte version gekommen gar nicht ich bin aber google
gesucht ist wahrscheinlich immer noch die neue max welchen cursor verwendest
das ist ein Bibata Cursor. Beste.
Hab ich auf dem Cache iOS Mini PC auch.
Das ist die Version ohne AI. Ne, die haben es einfach nur dumm übersetzt. Das heißt,
Es gibt nur das Ding.
Es gibt kein N5R ohne AI.
Guck.
N5R.
Warum auch immer da AI drin steht.
Kein Blassen Schimmer.
Hat mit AI überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Das ist das Pro.
Da steht AI drin.
Moment.
Das ist nochmal was Neues.
jetzt mal kurz gucken das ist doch das gleiche
das ist doch das gleiche
es ist genau die gleiche kiste oder ist es das normale n5 nee das ist auch der
mit dem 255 drin.
Ne, ne, das ist die gleiche CPU.
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Das ist...
Minis Forum Logik, kein Schimmer, ja.
Okay, das ist anscheinend
wirklich...
Das ist das normale, oder?
Das ist das normale N5.
So genau checkt man das nicht.
Schon umgesetzt.
Nee, wir haben noch gar nicht richtig angefangen.
Aber wir gucken jetzt einfach mal.
Die haben doch hier unten...
Ja.
Guck mal, das ist das doch.
Wenn wir das jetzt mal vergleichen.
Warte mal.
Gehen wir jetzt mal hier unten hin
Vergleichen das mal kurz
Specification
Ach hier, das ist der Unterschied
Okay, okay, okay
Hier sieht man sogar den Unterschied, guck mal
Das ist das normale N5 AI
Und das ist das N5R AI
Warum auch immer, manchmal AI steht, manchmal nicht
Was geht hier übrigens gerade mit der Seite da drüben?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären
Was hat die linke Seite für Probleme?
Sind es die Chinesen, die fernsteuern oder was?
Ich mach nix
Ich hab die Hände von der Maus weg
Die Seite bewegt sich von alleine
Guck hier, ich mach nix
Meine, die Chinesen sind schon drinnen
Ach, du bist das, Alfred
Ja dann, dann kann ich ja beruhigt sein
Mach euch weiter.
Was ist denn jetzt der Unterschied zwischen den Dingern?
Weil CPU-technisch sind die ja gleich.
RAM-Bestückung sind die auch gleich.
Storage mit den Platten sind die auch gleich.
Nur, dass die aus irgendwelchen Gründen mehr größere Disks können als das R.
Einmal M2.
Einmal U2 M2.
Und hier ist halt eine mit vorinstalliert.
Ja, okay, gut.
es ist die gleiche netzwerkkarte beides mal die gleiche netzwerkkarte die
gleiche led der rest ist alles gleich das ist die
gleiche kiste man es macht überhaupt keinen sinn
das ist die gleiche kiste
Keine Ahnung, was Minis Forum da treibt.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall zu teuer hier.
Ja, weil wenn man bei Amazon guckt...
Gehen wir mal Amazon.
N5R
Ja, da kostet nämlich das
Da kostet das hier, das N5R
Das gleiche wie hier das normale
N5, ich hab keine Ahnung
Was Minis Forum da treibt, aber das ist die gleiche
Kiste
Bei dem einen, bei dem einen werden die Chinesen mitgeliefert
Oder was
Das ist dann keine AI, sondern irgendwelche
Was ist denn Knusper
Ah, Supermarkt.
Die Seite sackt.
Ja, machen wir zu.
Okay.
Aber da gibt es keine neue Kiste.
Ich habe auch schon...
Wir können noch ein paar News gucken.
Das ist Ugreen
Max, hast du eigentlich seit dem letzten Stream
Noch ein Nask bestellt?
Ne, ich habe jetzt drei Nasses hier
Eins schicke ich auf jeden Fall wieder zurück
Da habe ich noch zwei Wochen Zeit für
Das andere ist die Zeit schon abgelaufen
Und das N5 behalte ich
Aber ich habe noch kein neues Nass bestellt
Kann man das so einfach zurückstellen
Klar die schreiben hier
Ukraine Rückgabe
Die schreiben
Innerhalb von 30 Tagen
Ja
Du kannst eine Rückgabe innerhalb von 30 Kalender
nachhalt des produkts beantragen basieren auf dem vom versand bestätigen zuständen zeitpunkt
und ich habe das über ukraine selbst bestellt
warum hast du dich für das n5 er entschieden okay jetzt kann ich erzählen erstens nämlich
geringer standby verbrauch also das habe ich ausprobiert ich habe dazu online nichts richtig
gefunden nämlich geringer standby verbrauch so 11 12 watt kannst du dich wirklich nicht beschweren
mit 3 ssds und wahrscheinlich mit festplatten im standby spin down ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht
bedeutend mehr also du kommst da auf jeden fall mit zehn gig netzwerkkarte attached ssds und
bestückt und kommt zu 120 watt was echt nice ist was wirklich gut ist dass die ukrain dinger brauchen
mehr. Die brauchen um die 20 Watt
plus minus.
So.
Ach, man kann wieder bestellen.
Is expected to ship from Hong Kong
to Germany in end of February.
Mitte März.
Habe ich aber Glück gehabt.
Habe ich aber echt Glück gehabt.
Ich habe eine Barebone Version
plus 64 GB.
Die habe ich.
16 GB habe ich nicht.
Also, warum habe ich mich dafür entschieden?
Das erste ist, das Pro kam mir nicht in die Tüte,
weil wohl Standby-Verbrauch ein bisschen höher ist.
Aber,
weil ich gelesen habe online,
dass das Probleme
mit dem SATA-Controller hat.
Und da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
So, was ich an dem NAS mega nice finde.
Ich kann es euch jetzt leider nicht zeigen,
weil ich die Kamera hier nicht dran habe.
beziehungsweise nicht angeschlossen habe.
Letzten Streamer habe ich euch einmal gezeigt.
Also was mich daran überzeugt und warum ich es eigentlich aktuell für das Beste nass,
so komplett fertig nass halte, was es gibt, ist,
erstens, habe ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal gesagt, relativ niedriger Standby-Verbrauch.
Und die Dinger sind zu 99% eideln die vor sich hin.
So, das nächste ist 5 Base.
Das Ukraine hat glaube ich nur 4, ich muss mal umdrehen, warte mal.
Ja, das Ukraine hat nur 4.
5 Bays, wie ist die Geräuschkulisse
unter Last?
Es ist hörbar, also unter Last
ist deutlich hörbar
Lüfter rauschen, aber wie gesagt
unter Last interessiert ja auch nicht
also unter Volllast oder 70-80%
bis 100% Ausgelastung
juckt ja auch nicht weiter, wann ist es das schon?
Im Idle
oder sagen wir mal fast Idle
ist das
nahezu unhörbar, wenn man
im BIOS ein paar Sachen einstellt
man kann nämlich im bios die kurve für die lüfter anpassen und dann ist das vollkommen in ordnung
also man hört so gut wie gar nicht so weiter weiter im text 5 base ich persönlich finde fünf
festplatten einschübe eigentlich ganz nice er da hast du verschiedene kombinationsmöglichkeiten
du kannst beispielsweise sagen du machst raid 5 ja was bei drei platten nice ist ansonsten würde
keinen RAID 5 benutzen, aber drei Platten sind
RAID 5 schon echt ganz okay.
Kannst du RAID 5 machen hier mit drei Platten
und hast noch Platz für ein Mirror,
für Backups oder sowas.
Oder für anderen Kram oder für zwei
SATA-SSDs.
Du kannst allerdings auch einfach
fünf Festplatten reinmachen und einen RAID 6
machen.
Ich finde, fünf Slots
sind einfach handlicher
oder wie soll ich sagen, angenehmer
von den Möglichkeiten her als vier Slots.
Dazu kommt, man hat 3 gut zugängliche M2 SSD Anschlüsse, das ist sehr nice.
Ugreen hat auch 3, Ugreen macht aber nur 2 zugänglich, für das andere musst du aufwendig
aufschrauben, dass du da dran kommst.
Aktuell ist es bei mir so, ich habe eine 64 Gig SSD mit dem es ausgeliefert wurde und
2 Samsung 990 Pro drinne.
Ich hoffe, dass Freenas Forum hört das nicht.
Ich benutze Consumer-SSDs mit ZFS, Leute.
Triggert.
So.
96 GB Maximum Memory, juckt mich nett.
Ich habe noch 32 GB hier rumliegen gehabt, die kommen rein.
Was ich cool finde ist, 10 Gig on Board.
Und darauf soll lokale KI laufen.
Wir haben es im letzten Stream ausprobiert.
Das lief erstaunlich gut.
Wir haben das letzte Mal GPT-OSS ausprobiert.
Die 20B Variante.
Und die hatte irgendwie 16, 17 Tokens pro Sekunde.
Da kannst du dich nicht beschweren.
Für so ein kleines Scheißding.
das ist das ist echt okay
es wirklich ordnung so onboard 10 gig netzwerkkarte finde ich bock haben die ukraine
dinge auch die ukraine die ukrainis ist die haben ein etwas bessere netzwerkkarte was den chip
angeht die ukrainis haben quantik netzwerkkarte und die haben der
retec netzwerkkarte die nicht den besten linux treiber support aktuell hat
es ist besser man benutzt den offiziellen retec treiber was ein
bisschen viertel ist gefurrt ist das machen wir jetzt aber gleich was bisschen
eklig ist noch ich hoffe der treiber support verbessert sich noch unter
linux man merkt dass wenn man hohe datenraten mit vms übertragen will dass
es vielleicht die hälfte von zehn gig packt wenn man nur mit dem haus
überträgt das ist okay dann ist man so 89 hat man dann aber in der vm ist es
lahm und das liegt eindeutig am tag treiber so dass minis cloud os ist
schrott würde ich nicht benutzen ich würde aber auch nicht das system von
ukraine benutzen das wird runter geschmissen da kommt irgendwas anderes drauf ja es ist erst mal
egal was es ist es kam denn android sein es kann dem db jahren sein es kann proxmox sein wenn ihr
viel virtualisierung machen wollt oder den schulers oder war etwas vollkommen egal aber das original
us juckt mich nicht was das hier hat was ich sehr nice finde für android enjoy die haben natürlich
keine bilder wieder geil dann muss ich jetzt meinen eigenen muss jemand eigenen stream gucken
muss ich meine eigenen muss jemand eigenen stream gucken ich habe doch hier am anfang
mal das nass gezeigt hier guckte mal da liegt das und irgendwo hier sieht man die
zwei SSDs und irgendwo zeige ich es ja dann auch im Stream. Die habe ich ausgebaut.
Jetzt habe ich wieder rein gemacht. Was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte ist,
was man jetzt irgendwie nicht richtig sieht. Ja doch, hier sieht man es. Es gibt einen internen
usb 3 anschluss was für die ganzen android enjoyer ist ja weil android läuft ja immer
noch über usb stick also es ist gut durchdacht das ding finde ich gut so als nächstes man hat
die möglichkeit wenn man richtig hardcore ki sachen machen will oder irgendwas man kann also
dann wirklich wenn man will eine richtige grafikkarte dranhängen ansonsten ist man
angewiesen auf die gpu hierbei in dem reisen das ist eine radion 780 m so und
was für mich noch so ein killer feature ist von dem ding
man sieht es hier ich kann es einfach bei mir im stream zeigen
man sieht hier guckte mal seht ihr das da seht ihr das da
das da ich meine ich die netzwerkkarte ich meine das wo die netzwerkkarte drin
ist da ist ein pc express slot drin noch einmal in diesem kleinen ding und das
ist richtig nice das bietet enorm viel flexibilität also egal was jeder noch
dazu machen wollt ihr könnt damit machen weil es ein pc express slot hat ja das
ist ein low profile was soll die da sonst noch rein machen aber ihr könnt
da zusätzliche ssds beispielsweise reinhauen zusätzliche sata ports wenn ihr
was braucht ja zusätzliche netzwerkkarten wenn ihr was braucht oder
irgendwelche anderen dinge also ein pc express slot ist extrem lieb
und so insgesamt muss ich sagen ist das einfach eine richtig nice hardware so eine fertige als
fertiges bundle wie viel speicher hast du dann auf der hdd je nachdem was man rein macht und
du meinst ich jetzt was ich für festplatten rein machen will also ich mache da wahrscheinlich meine
alten 12 terabyte sind das glaube ich rein die jetzt gerade in dem hp
microserver stecken ich kaufe mir erst mal keine neuen da kam es so teuer
aktuell und 12 terabyte rate 5 gut ist den 24 terabyte nutzbar das reicht
ausreichend.
Ne, das stimmt gar nicht.
Das ist plötzlich, was ich erzähle.
Ich glaube, ich habe gar kein Raid 5 aktuell.
Ich glaube, ich habe...
Was habe ich denn aktuell?
Weißt du mal, weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich habe zumindest eine Platte davon extern,
um nächtlichen Airsoom zu machen.
Das brauche ich hier nicht.
Die stecke ich einfach in irgendeinen zusätzlichen Slot vorne rein.
kann am nächtlichen Backup machen.
Ja, aber ich finde in sich ist das wirklich
eine sehr, sehr nice Hardware.
Dieses ganze Gelaber von AI
und bla und irgendwie sonst was.
Ganz ehrlich, ich verwende
eh nicht den hier OS.
So, jetzt mache ich das
aber mal an.
Die Kiste. Jetzt soll ich erstmal Proxmox wieder installieren.
Die Hoffnung, das tut heute.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
und tokio nicht so kioto nicht nicht nicht so
hallo okay
ich will guten ich will was will ich guten options
ich will das da gut genau
Genau, Realtek.
10 Gigabit, den da will ich booten.
Das BIOS ist, das ist wirklich...
...Paintschamp, ja.
Vor allem BIOS, wo man mit der Maus klicken muss, dass man es ordentlich bedienen kann.
Also das ist wirklich eklig.
So, erstmal schön PXE booten
Ist es nicht schön, Leute, mein PXE-Boot-Screen?
Ich feier mein PXE-Boot-Screen immer noch
Es ist ein nicer PXE-Boot-Screen
Das ist übrigens KI-Katze, ne?
KI-Katze, ja
KI-Katze
So, was brauchen wir denn jetzt überhaupt?
Netboot, äh, nicht Netconfig.
NetbootXYZ brauchen wir jetzt, weil ich Proxmox nicht hier in meinem lokalen PXE-Boot drinne habe.
Dafür brauche ich das zu selten.
NetbootXYZ.
Hast du den auf GitHub gepusht?
Nee, nee, nee, kann ich nicht. Ich hab da keine Copyright-Sachen dran.
Ob da überhaupt jemand Copyright dran hat? Fraglich.
So, ähm...
Den gibt's aber im Internet, den, das Bild, ja?
Das hab ich ja nicht selbst KI generiert.
Also, Netboot XYZ.
Please download the latest version.
Ja, das mache ich dann am Wochenende.
Am Wochenende lädt er bei mir neueste Netboot XYZ Version runter.
Also, jetzt brauchen wir hier Live-CDs.
Linux Network Installs brauchen wir, glaube ich.
box box box text aber proxmox gui machen ich habe boxbox install habe ich und das
probieren wir jetzt mal gut der boxbox install funktioniert ihr wisst ich bin
text enjoyer aber gucken hast du mal aus ja hier ist doch gut
also die maus geht darüber kvm hoffen wir zumindest mal
also ich kann dir sagen große platten brauchen so 7 watt ungefähr wenn sie sind ja also hoch
hoch gespinnt und sonst was wenn du die dinger nur eitel spin down hast brauchen die unter einem watt
So, macht es jetzt was?
Wenn du die hauptsächlich spin down hast, brauchen die alle nicht so ein großes...
Ah, hier, okay.
So.
Wir akzeptieren selbstverständlich.
Wir machen hier a creak.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Options.
Wir wollen ZFS Raid 1.
Ne, Schwachsinn wollen wir nicht.
Do not use
Sekunde
Checkt der jetzt, dass es ein Single Disk Setup ist
Wenn ich Raid 1 mache
Ich hoffe, der checkt das
Weil ich will
Ich will hier nur
Nur da drauf installieren
Ah, ich denke, das checkt er schon
Oder Raid 0
Letztendlich kommt da eh keine zweite Platte dabei
0 mit einer disc
advanced options copies 1 ja das passe ich nachher selbst an
Okay.
Next.
Country.
Germany.
Jawohl.
Passwort.
Super, highly complex Passwort, Leute.
Da kommt ihr nie drauf.
Mail ad.
Example.invalid.
Das ist gut.
Was?
123456789
Das Beste hier.
Mail it invalid.
Ach komm.
Example.com
So.
Einfach nur PVE.
Äh.
Nein.
Doch. Richtig. Richtig.
Was für eine IP hatten wir dem das letzte Mal gegeben? 51.
2.51.
Gateway ist die 50.
DNS ist auch die 50.
Pin, okay.
Hosting, das...
Punkt example, Punkt kommt.
So.
Excellent.
Passt.
Automatic reboot after successful installation installed.
Übrigens Chat, was mich super irritiert ist.
ich habe hier eine elgato hd 60x und ich schaffe es einfach nicht ich schaffe es
einfach nicht 120 fps hierzu zu konfigurieren guckt wenn ich das jetzt
hier einschalten machen wir mal
Ah, schalten wir jetzt mal ein.
Der checkt es nicht mal.
Geil.
Jetzt.
Guck mal.
Custom.
Resolution.
Ich kann nur 60 auswählen.
Nicht stumm.
Angeblich kann die Karte 120 capturen.
Achso, hups.
Äh, Chat-Gear-Vergess.
Ich hab hier drinnen rumgeklickt und dann hab ich gezeigt, dass es nur 60 zur Auswahl gibt.
Jaja, ihr habt den Desktop ja nicht gesehen.
Logisch.
gibt es eine möglichkeit beim powershell was mein ps1 auf alle meine vm
lxc zu erzählen was ist ein ps1 bescheidigen spezieller prompt oder was das ps1 bash
abgas und prompt okay ist doch der prompt ja gut du kannst für jeden neuen user kannst du
das machen auf bestehende die lux system aber wenn du sowas hier konfigurieren willst da fällt
also wenn du quasi so eine so eine standard konflikt haben möchtest für alle linux vms
dann bleibt ja eigentlich nur sowas wie Ansible übrig.
Oder du machst dir
einen Bash-Skript. Das ist wahrscheinlich für den
Fall einfacher. Du machst dir
ein Git-Repo,
wo du so einen
Init-Bash-Skript drin hast,
klonst das Git-Repo, führst das aus
und dann richtet er die Kiste richtig ein. Oder du machst
Ansible. Also so
ein
Post-Setup-Step fällt mir da jetzt
nicht ein.
ok da sind wir jet 25 12.51 online fix ssh yes da sind wir als erstes machen wir wieder ein
Post-Install-Skript.
Normalerweise sage ich ja immer
Obacht, wenn man
hier irgendwelche Sachen, random Sachen von GitHub
nach Bash pipet, aber YOLO,
who cares?
Ich benutze das eigentlich nur für
dieses Post-Install-Skript.
Und für ein paar Kleinigkeiten, ansonsten benutze ich das gar nicht weiter.
Post Install Proxmox Automated Post Install Script.
Do you want to process the system update?
Dann machen wir jetzt gleich nochmal
einen IPerf-Test
Haben wir das hier nicht irgendwo gehabt?
IPerf, hier, CMD
CMD
Terminal können wir jetzt machen, ist das gleiche
CD, Desktop
IPerf
Hier, ne
Ja gut, das können wir dann mit Windows checken, wie schnell die Netzwerkverbindung ist.
Vielleicht hat sich jetzt ja beim Kernel-Update was getan, Leute.
Ich glaube es aber nicht, dass der Netzwerktreiber nennenswert besser geworden ist,
weil wir hatten da schon mal testweise einen 619er-Kernel drauf.
Das war immer noch so.
Yes, wir wollen das Banner
Removen.
No, wir wollen nicht neu starten.
Weil ich will jetzt
das erste Mal
Settings
ausschalten.
Okay, das war's.
also ab install h top t mux d start da die ist da brauchen wir nicht und ipad 3
alles klar so machen wir jetzt einmal einen test ipad 3 minus es
ipf das testet wie schnell die übertragung ist netzwerk technisch 2.51 9,7 also im prinzip das
gleich wie das letzte mal auch und minus dürfte ein bisschen weniger sein genau also im prinzip
haben wir genau das gleiche wie das letzte mal auch netzwerk performance gleich gut gleich schlecht
Geht also klar.
Ich mach doch keine 9000er
MTU bei mir lokal im Netzwerk.
So.
Gut.
Reboot.
Haben wir mal ordentlich rebooted.
Frage, Chat, was haben wir hier?
Herr Schwarz fragt
Hey Leute, ich habe eine Frage, wie kommt man
eigentlich weiter und mehr in so eine DevOps-Schiene?
Ich versauere gerade mal meine Arbeitsstelle.
Boah, das ist jetzt so sehr, sehr breit
gefragt, jetzt nicht, dass ich da der wahnsinnigste Experte
für bin oder so.
Versauern heißt, du bist eigentlich
innerlich da schon weg.
Gerade ist es in der Tat
nicht so einfach, neue Jobs zu finden.
Wenn man
Ahnung hat und gefragte Sachen kann, ist das aber immer eine Option.
Ansonsten, was mir hilft, ist, sich privat mit Sachen beschäftigen, die einen interessieren.
Zu 99% Sachen, die ich gelernt habe, wo ich dann später auch im Job von profitiert habe, ist was,
also jetzt mal von, wie benutze ich unser merkwürdiges Ticketsystem auf der Arbeit,
Das habe ich nicht privat gelernt, aber so von technischen Skills habe ich zu 99% zuerst privat gelernt, bevor ich die auf der Arbeit gebraucht habe.
Ich habe hier mit Kubernetes schon rumgebastelt, da hat bei uns auf der Arbeit noch keiner dran gedacht.
Ich habe mich damals mit Git und Versionsverwaltung beschäftigt, da war Git noch ganz neu, da hat auf der Arbeit auch keiner dran gedacht und solche Geschichten.
Ich hatte damals ein Jenkins installiert, da war das frischer Hudson Fork und sowas.
also mittlerweile ist das auch kein schenken es wenn du so als beispiel also viele sachen lernt
man privat und braucht die dann auf der arbeit irgendwann war natürlich nicht alles ganz im
ernst wenn ich daran denke was ich da mit micro controller gemacht habe und sowas das werde ich
wahrscheinlich nicht auf der arbeit brauchen wobei ganz ehrlich man weiß es nicht vielleicht muss ich
irgendwann mal was in c++ programmieren aus irgendwelchen gründen und dann habe ich wenigstens
bisschen ahnung davon also man weiß es schadet nie was was zu wissen so dass man prinzipiell
die frage interessierst du dich überhaupt dafür oder willst du das machen weil es kohle gibt
kohle gibt es auch woanders also das muss sich dann schon interessieren also ich muss dann so
was wie die icd interessieren generell musste dich mit kontinuierung beschäftigen irgendwelchen
workflow tools und sonst was das musste ich interessiert und am besten halt auch privat
Weil die besten Leute, ich weiß nicht, Chad, wie ist das bei euch,
aber ich habe den Eindruck, die richtig guten IT-Leute oder, sagen wir mal,
die, mit denen ich mich in der Regel auch am besten verstehe
und von denen ich selbst denke, die haben viel Ahnung,
sind Leute, wo ich weiß, das sind genauso, also zum größten Teil,
zum größten, nicht alle, aber zum größten Teil, das sind genauso Kellerkinder wie ich.
Ja, die basteln auch daheim gerade rum.
So, und damit musst du dich da ein bisschen auseinandersetzen.
Wenn du aber, sagen wir jetzt mal, in einem Windows-Only-Team bist, bei einem kleinen Betrieb, der zwei Windows-Server hat und keinen großen Plan von allem anderen,
dann wirst du wahrscheinlich in dieser Schiene dort nicht glücklich werden.
Einfach IT-Hausmeister.
Ja, ich glaube, da wirst du bei dem...
Ich meine, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Viele wissen es ja manchmal auch nicht besser.
Die Frage ist, ob man dich da vielleicht auch was machen lassen würde.
Aber der Wille zur Veränderung ist ja bei solchen Läden meistens nicht sonderlich hoch.
Also wenn die 90% in Excel machen und gerne alles von Hand durchklicken
und du sagst dann, ey, äh, lass uns das mal in Git verwalten
und ne, ne, ne GitLab CI Pipeline hinten dran machen auf jeden Push.
Dann haben die, oh, was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Das haben wir noch nie gemacht, das brauchen wir nicht.
Dann hat die Frage, was das für ein Laden ist.
Ne, niemand macht freiwillig SAP.
Und Oracle.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die machst du nicht freiwillig.
das ist das ist auf jeden fall sinnvoll ja automatisieren und du musst also gerade im
der voraus bereich ist es auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt wenn du programmieren kannst du musst
jetzt nicht der ultra hacker man sein in 20 verschiedenen sprachen aber was du können
sollte ist auf jeden fall bash also shell scripts ohne shell scripts läuft gar nichts wenn es
windows ist auch noch powershell aber ich hoffe nicht ich hoffe für dich nicht dass es windows
ist also shell scripts auf jeden fall ohne shell scripts kommt nicht weiter dann so sachen wie
ansible und terraform kontinuierisierung mit beschäftigen kubernetes kann man ein bisschen
später anstellen mit ci cd tools es kann auch meinetwegen ein oldschool jenkins sein aber
einfach dass ich ein bisschen mit beschäftigt in gitlab installieren mit gitlab ci oder git
installieren oder ford jo wie das neue jetzt heißt mit mit mit diesen actions
drin alles nicht verkehrt sich anzugucken und das daheim auszuprobieren
ist auch eine gute idee wie gesagt das meiste wenn sie erst mal
daheim kennen und uns und skill aufbau ist bei mir auch zu 95 prozent
privatsache irgendwie außer halt die sachen wie man nur auf der arbeit lernen
kann als irgendwelche business enterprise kämpfe ist
Eigentlich eine gute Antwort.
Je nachdem, ob das die HR-Leute da hören wollten oder nicht.
Wie kam das an bei dir?
Die Antwort.
Das will ich heute mal ausprobieren.
Es gibt halt die extrem talentierten, die alles können.
Ja, das sind aber auch genauso Kellerkinder.
Die können das ja nicht, weil sie morgens aufwachen und alles wissen.
Die sind halt einfach so, das sind einmal so Karriere-Kreisel-Grinder,
die kein Problem damit haben, 60 Wochenstunden zu arbeiten
und dann daheim die restlichen Zeit noch Privatprojekte und alles zu machen.
Das sind Leute, die das richtig drauf haben
Das sind alles solche Kellerkinder wie wir
Es wacht keiner auf mit und sagt
Ah
Ich weiß jetzt alles über Terraform
Das ist nicht so
Guckt euch die ganzen
Künstler an
Die machen halt das was sie Bock haben
Aber halt auch den ganzen Tag
Wenn jemand richtig gut werden will
Im Klavier spielen
Die spielen Stunden am Tag
Und üben und machen
Und die interessieren sich da auch privat für
Außer sie werden von den Eltern dazu
geprügelt so, das zu machen.
Ansonsten, es ist bei vielen Sachen so.
Aber es liegt halt auch daran,
weil wenn dich privat so was interessiert,
dann hast du natürlich auch eine größere Chance,
einen Job in der Richtung zu ergreifen
und vor allem auch ein größeres Interesse daran,
einen Job zu ergreifen in dieser Richtung.
Ja, wenn jetzt einer sagt,
Alter, ich will überhaupt nichts mit Computern zu tun haben,
dann wird er wahrscheinlich nicht in so einem Job landen.
Einer, der schon seit klein auf gerne mit Hardware gebastelt hat
oder einer, der schon seit klein auf Sachen programmiert oder gerne Microcontroller bastelt oder sonst was, der hat halt auch mehr Hang dazu.
Also ich sag mal, bei vielen ist das private Interesse an Technik zuerst da gewesen, vor dem Job.
Und dementsprechend ist das danach, wenn sie den Job haben, halt auch immer noch da.
Wobei es natürlich, muss man auch endlich mal sagen, ist bei mir ja teilweise auch so, ein bisschen nachlässt.
Ich habe beispielsweise auch nicht mehr Bock, an jedem Tag, wenn ich da auf der Arbeit, sagen wir jetzt irgendwie, mir fünf Stunden eine Linux-Konsole angeguckt habe, gerade daheim auch noch was in der Richtung zu machen.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass ich es nicht trotzdem manchmal mache.
Ja, Windows Server ist grausam.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit habe ich jetzt gehört, es geht mal wieder das Gespenst um, Leute.
Windows Defender für Linux einzuführen.
Chat, Hand hoch.
Hand hoch.
Wer wusste, dass es Windows Defender für Linux überhaupt gibt?
Oder umgedreht.
Wir machen mal so.
Daumen hoch.
Wer wusste, dass es Windows Defender für Linux gibt?
Daumen runter.
Wer nicht wusste, dass es Windows Defender auch für Linux gibt?
Machen wir mal so.
so dass wir es ungefähr so sehen.
Okay, viele wissen es nicht.
Ich sag mal, zwei Drittel wissen es nicht,
ein Drittel weiß es.
Ja, es gibt Windows Defender für Linux.
Guck.
Windows Defender Endpoint Linux.
Irgendwie so hieß der Kram noch.
Hier.
Microsoft Defender für Endpunkt unter Linux.
Geile Übersetzung.
ob man das nicht hier unten irgendwie umschalten deutsch
englisch united states microsoft defender for endpoint und linux und es
ist genauso scheiße wie sich anhört ja beim alten arbeitgeber hatten wir das
microsoft macht updates getarnt als signatur updates und es sind programm
updates und du wunderst dich auf einmal warum haben die datenbank so viel ram
Wärmeverbrauch und sowas. Das ist wirklich
der aller, aller
letzte Scheiß. Glaubt's mir, Leute.
Das ist so ein Schrott.
Sag ich aus Erfahrung.
Zumindest hatten wir solche Schrott-Erfahrungen
damit, ja. Das ist so
ein Schrott.
Ich sag nicht, dass es gar nicht
funktionieren kann oder so, ja.
Vielleicht ist es ja mittlerweile auch noch besser geworden.
Aber meine Erfahrung damit,
es ist Schrott.
Leute, falls ihr eine Frage übersehen habt, schreibt sie einfach nochmal mit
Edwublos in den Chat davor, dann wird es bei mir gehighlighted.
Ja, das ist abartig sowas.
Wenn du, um arbeiten zu dürfen, immer extra Runden drehen musst,
das ist nervig, das kenne ich, ja.
Das kenne ich, das kenne ich.
Das haben wir teilweise auch auf der Arbeit, wenn es um Berechtigungen geht,
da fliegen dann teilweise nach einem halben Jahr wieder irgendwelche Berechtigungen weg,
die man schon mal hatte und dann dauert es dann wieder
zwei Wochen, bis es genehmigt ist,
was meistens nicht an meinem Chef liegt, sondern an dem nächsten,
der es dann genehmigen muss, auf der Seite,
wo der Service dazugehört, ganz weird.
Aber in der Regel klappt es bei uns
eigentlich ganz gut.
Der kann auch was mit Holz machen.
Okay.
das das habe ich so noch noch in der form nicht erlebt bei leuten die
wirklich ahnung haben ja sicherlich gibt es da die ein oder andere die wirklich
nur job nach vorschrift machen sich dann doch gar nicht mehr dafür interessieren
dann frage ich mich wieder überhaupt in den beruf reingekommen ist wenn es schon
gar nicht interessiert na gut gibt auch viele leute die werden
schreiner und hat da keinen bock drauf
ich habe nichts gegen schreien ich bin froh dass schreiner gibt gibt es auch
microsoft edge für linux ja gibt's auch
genau atp das heißt advanced threat protection
Oder kann ich mir vorstellen.
Wir müssen den Defender jetzt auch auf unsere
Dienungslaptops installieren. Unsere Security hat
noch dreimal angerufen, weil ich Netzzeit ausgeführt habe.
Ja, ja, ja.
Solche Dinger fallen dann da auf. Genau.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die haben richtig Angst
vorm Terminal, wenn die unter Linux mal sind.
Weil die kennen halt nur
dieses ganz alte...
Der Chat hat mir letztens
erzählt, wie man das noch ausführen kann, aber ich weiß
es nicht mehr, wie es funktioniert hat.
Man kann
das ganz alte Windows Terminal
kann man immer noch ausführen.
Nicht das hier, das alte.
Und mit Batch drin. Also das ist wirklich...
Wer nur das kennt, verstehe ich, dass
der Angst vor schwarzen Fenstern
mit...
Wobei, unter Linux sind die ja nicht unbedingt schwarz-weiß.
Sag mal, vor Darkseem Fenstern
hat. Mit Text
drin.
habt ihr nicht einen cup tommy gibt es bei euch einen cup
ein change advisory board die coolen leute haben sowas
Bei euch ist Nmap verboten, weil das ein Hacker-Tool ist
Ich hab euch ja schon 50 mal die Story erzählt
Ein Kollege von mir auf der alten Arbeit
Hat
Kali-Lilux gehabt
Und hat dort dann ein Paket-Update gemacht
Da werden dann halt auch
Die bösen Hacker-Tools werden geladen
Und das ging über den HTTP-Proxy
Und auf einmal standen dann die Leute bei ihm
im Büro, was er denn da für Hacker-Software benutzt.
Du hast Angst vor Windows Terminal, ja, zu Recht.
Ja, die Leute sind einfach so dumm, Alter.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Ne, also richtig
Hacker-Man musste wenn schon
C-Matrix einmal ausführen im Terminal.
Das
geht dann durch so.
Kann das sein,
dass C-Matrix bei mir laggt irgendwie?
Seid ihr drin, Chat?
Ich muss mal gucken, ob es da irgendeine Option für gibt.
Dass man da irgendwas setzen kann.
Okay, was ist Minus M?
Ah.
Half-Life Enjoyer.
Aber was ich persönlich viel besser finde, ist das Askenquarium.
Das Gehör ist das Beste.
Für mich ist die Talent-versus-Fleiß-Thematik
ein etwas frustrierendes Thema.
Arbeit plus private Projekte
sammeln wir pro Jahr etwa
2.500 bis 3.000 Stunden.
Ich bleibe aber trotzdem Durchschnitt.
Du denkst, dass du Durchschnitt bist,
wenn du wüsstest, wie kacke der Durchschnitt ist.
90% der Leute können gar nichts.
Oder bist du sicherlich deutlich besser?
grundsätzlich hast du mit einer ausgabe
dass der das denke ich auch
weil windows wahrscheinlich weil es weib coded ist das bestimmt weib coded
Ganz ehrlich, ich mache mir eher Gedanken, wenn es Leute gibt, die sagen, alter, ich bin der Krasseste überhaupt in dem und dem.
Oder ich bin überall, bin ich einfach der Krasseste.
Über die mache ich mir Gedanken, über die Leute, die denken, oh, ich weiß so vieles, wovon ich keine Ahnung habe.
Die sind mir, da weiß ich in der Regel eher, dass das die sind mit Ahnung, als die, die erzählen, die es so krass drauf haben.
Also ich würde mir eher Gedanken machen, wenn du jetzt denkst, boah, ich habe voll den krassen Durchblick.
Weil du darfst ja nicht vergessen, umso mehr Ahnung du hast, umso mehr weißt du, von was du keine Ahnung hast.
Und dir wird auch bewusst, wie viele Themengebiete und Sachen es noch gibt, von denen du keine Ahnung hast.
Themen und Gebiete, von denen du wahrscheinlich vorher noch nicht mal wusstest, dass es die gibt.
Sehr gute ITler sind meist based. Ja, das finde ich auch.
Wir sind based.
Oder basiert,
wie man das so schön sagt auf Reddit Deutschland.
So, jetzt müssen wir...
Chat, chat, chat, chat, seriously.
Ich bin fast zwei Stunden
on. Wir haben noch nichts
mit Paperless und Proxmox gemacht.
Noch gar nichts. Das Einzige, was ich geschafft habe, ist
Proxmox zu installieren, Alter.
classic was die mz ist es gibt total viele leute die das nicht wissen die das
nur aus dem heimbereich kennen und denken sie wissen was es ist
ein bisschen daran weil routerhersteller so sah so sachen wie
exposed host oder wir leiten alles auf eine ip weiter die mz nennen was er
nichts aber auch gar nichts mit der dmz zu tun hat
Wie ist deine Meinung zu OpenClaw?
Habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Habe ich auch nicht das Verlangen dazu.
Ich habe nur mitgekriegt, dass der Typ jetzt bei OpenAI ist.
Und reich.
Okay, also.
So, wir haben hier unsere Proxmox-Kiste.
Äh, erstes Mal
SSH Copy ID
Minus
I, was machen wir da?
Punkt SSH
Äh, welchen Key nehmen wir dann?
Ach, den Oldschool RSA Key
Nehmen wir da
Beste
So
Der war vorher schon reich
Okay, okay, das wusste ich nicht
Was ist SSH Copy ID?
SSH Copy ID
Kopiert
Deinen Public Key
Auf den Server
Und ins Authorized Key File
Das ist quasi das gleiche
Wie wenn ich so machen würde
das hier nehmen würde und hier nach punkt ssh authorized key kopieren
spart man sich das permit admin dass das permit root das sparst du dir davon nicht wenn du dich
direkt als root einloggen willst du sparst dir dass du jedes mal ein passwort eingeben musst
auf den meisten die loks kisten lockt man sich auch gar nicht mehr per hut ein sondern als
normaler user und sudut dann was eigentlich ganz cool ist wenn man sich mal genau überlegt weil
dann hast du zwei sachen die du brauchst du brauchst es als hd zu meinung und das user
passwort musst du bist nur gut zu werden eigentlich ganz eigentlich ist es eine ziemlich coole sache
mit sudo.
Sudo
als root geht ja sogar, ne?
Macht aber halt nix, wenn man es installiert hat.
Okay, Leute, also, lass mal hier
kurz Proxmox, wo müssen wir hin?
1, 2, 1, 6, 8, 2, 5,
1.
Proxmox, ja gut, der hat kein gültiges
Zertifikat, das ist okay.
Äh, hallo? Muss mal kurz reloaden.
Root.
So.
Ich glaube, da sind wir.
Alles klar.
So, jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz gucken.
ZFS-Status.
Äh, nee, Zpool-Status.
Erstmal kurz gucken,
dass ich meine alten Disks nochmal wieder einbinde.
Weil ich hatte doch da schon
einen ZFS-Pool.
Zpool-Import
war das, ne?
Oder nicht?
Äh,
Work, genau.
Work-F.
das haben wir importiert und jetzt brauche ich noch zfs mount minus l work
oder nicht? ZFS mount minus l work slash save habe ich es genannt save save
und wie ging das noch
safe so genau weil ich habe mit native zfs encryption also z pool status
also wir haben hier unseren unseren zfs pool für root dann haben wir unseren zfs
Mirror für die 4Ms.
Wer sich jetzt wundert, warum es eine 2TB
SSD ist und eine 1TB SSD
und das in einem Mirror, da würde
ja 1TB verschenkt,
der hat recht.
Das liegt daran,
ich hatte die 2 SSDs noch da.
Man könnte da tricksen, man könnte hier eine
Partition machen und die 1TB noch
anderweitig verwenden, aber erst mal
drauf geschissen.
Paper burn money, okay?
So, jetzt machen wir erst nochmal einen Test, wie schnell die SSDs sind.
Ne, vorher, vorher.
Das habe ich ganz vergessen.
Wir müssen ja wieder ZFS, Arc, das da müssen wir erstmal wieder einstellen.
Wim etc mod also es ist so es gibt einen cache bei ZFS und der ist relativ klein gewählt hier
standardmäßig mache ich gerade mal ein bisschen größer und zwar wollen wir mindestens ungefähr
drei gig haben als cache und ZFS arg max wollen wir da muss man google sagen 16 GB
Ah, alles klar.
Gibt es das vielleicht auch...
Gibt es das vielleicht auch in normalen Dingern?
Okay.
Mal gucken, ob Chatgepäte sowas weiß.
Stimmt das denn?
Wollen wir mal checken, ob das stimmt.
Guck mal, Chat-GPT lügt wieder.
Ah, ne.
Äh, das ist 1.
Aber ich habe die falsche Zahl kopiert.
Ah.
Okay.
Das heißt aber, ich kann das hier einfach, guck mal, wenn ich das hier mal 16 rechne.
Oh.
To, to gibi.
16.
So.
Machen wir das so.
Jetzt muss ich, oh, update.
Init, InitRAM,
FS oder sowas machen, Minusu.
Und dann müssen wir nochmal
rebooten und dann so. Wobei, es müsste
eigentlich auch ohne Reboot funktionieren.
Gucken wir mal.
Wir rebooten trotzdem, um zu gucken, ob es dann
persistent ist.
Wisst ihr, was ich auch noch nice finden würde?
Wisst ihr, was mir gerade noch einfällt, was richtig
cool wäre?
Könnte man nicht sowas machen wie
while true
done
sleep 1
und dann
und dann sagen hier und und
break
der wartet jetzt quasi
bis die, sagen wir mal waiting
Ja, das ist eigentlich nice.
Das packe ich auch noch in meine Shell.
Irgendwie SSH-Wade oder so.
Sowas wie Auto-SSH, ja.
Ne, weil ich habe das total oft, ich reboote irgendwas
und will mich dann wieder einloggen
und dann tippe ich alle paar Sekunden SSH, SSH, SSH,
Ist er wieder da?
Können wir nicht sowas hier machen?
Wartet mal.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Warte mal.
Können wir nicht sowas hier machen?
Sowas hier?
Nennen wir es einfach mal hier.
Keine Ahnung.
Way Towards.
einfach ssh-o connect timeout 1 in eine schleife.
Du meinst, dann kann ich mir das Sleep sparen?
Weil ich könnte jetzt ja quasi sagen,
while true, do, echo,
done,
sleep,
waiting,
und jetzt
machen wir hier rein.
Dollar Add.
Und ist das so?
Jetzt kann ich quasi auf alles
warten.
Auf alles
warten, bis es mal okay war.
Eigentlich
ganz praktisch, oder? Macht es Sinn, was ich da gestrickt
habe?
Also machen wir jetzt mal sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Was, was auf jeden Fall
fehlschlägt.
Also keine Ahnung
Grab, 0 W
Echo 1
Das schlägt ja jedes Mal fehl
Jetzt kann ich davor sagen
Ach ne ja, das geht nicht
Das geht nicht mit dem Pipe
Ah ja
Okay
Okay, bin false
Können wir mal ausprobieren, ja hast recht hier
False
guck jetzt wer da bist das okay ist das ist okay das kann man noch verfeinern ja aber finde ich an
sich schon aber gar nicht so blöd weil jetzt jetzt ist es so wenn ich jetzt es ist es ist es
age da kann ich quasi jetzt einfach sagen walds welt hat so und jetzt
probiert es mal aus gut noch mal okay so richtig gut funktioniert das noch nicht
was ich mir gedacht habe so richtig gut ist es noch nicht aber die idee finde
schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Warum genau hängt der jetzt?
Weil ich keinen
Connect-Timeout hab, ne?
Ah, schon doof.
Schau mal, ob der sich jetzt automatisch connectet
oder ob das die sinnloseste Bash-Funktion ever ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist die sinnlos.
Ah, siehste, da sind wir.
Wie dank ist ZSH?
Ich glaube, ZSH ist gar nicht mehr so dank.
Die richtig coolen Leute, die benutzen, glaube ich, eher Fisch mittlerweile.
Sag mal, hatten wir nicht mal ein Way-to-Dank-Emote?
Ey, mein GIF funktioniert nicht.
Was ist hier los?
Aber das funktioniert.
In Nushel gibt es auch ein paar coole Leute.
Aber viele benutzen auch...
Also die Leute, die gerade auf Reddit Unix-Porn posten.
Also wer das nicht kennt, nicht, dass das jetzt wieder hier...
Leute denken, da mache ich Werbung für komische Subreddits.
Da werden Rices gepostet.
Unix-Porn. Unix-Customization.
Da ist Fischshell sehr beliebt.
Ne, das Subreddit kenne ich nicht.
Das gucke ich mir nicht an.
Fisch, so, Fisch
Fisch schreibt man das, Fisch
So, also jetzt haben wir den ganzen Krempel installiert
Jetzt können wir mal gucken, dass wir uns Paperless installieren
Erstmal gucke, NVTop
Ob der meine Grafikkarte
überhaupt erkennt
Und wie viel RAM und so, NVTop
ok er erkennt meine grafikkarte memory grafikkarte 512 mb genauso wie sein soll
nvidia smi beste es gibt auch rock im smi oder sowas weiß bloß nicht wie das hier rock im smi
gibt es auch noch Rock'em SMI.
Das ist das Gegenstück.
Ja, da kann man dann auch
sowas sagen hier wie
Rock'em SMI. Da sieht man dann auch
so Dinger wie 15% VRAM belegt,
Grafikkarte ausgelastet.
Allerdings muss man ehrlich sagen,
ähm,
ich persönlich finde der NV Top irgendwie
schöner.
Ja.
nv top sieht man gleich was abgeht
sensors install lms mal gucken was er für sensoren überhaupt erkennt hier
dass man gucken sensors sensors guck mal hier was erkennt er denn er erkennt
von der voller gpu erkennt irgendwas
dann erkennt da irgendwie vom was ist das vom ram was was ist das hier chat hat
irgendjemand eine ahnung was das hier für eine temperatur ist das dürfte ram sein
Ja, wegen SPD denke ich, dass es RAM ist, aber Wissen tue ich es nicht.
Das klingt sehr nach RAM.
Ist das eigentlich alles von Haus aus bei Linux dabei?
Was, du meinst die Möglichkeit was zu installieren,
ohne dir Sachen aus dem Internet laden zu müssen?
beziehungsweise ohne halt google und runterladen zu müssen oder ob alles schon direkt dabei ist
also bei linux ist es so in der regel ist es nicht einfach schon alles vor installiert aber
du kannst dir relativ easy sachen nach installieren ja zum beispiel hier mit abt was er hier abt hast
doch gesehen hier ab install lm sensors sagt da habe ich gerade nachher zählt es kommt aus dem
offiziellen repo von der distribution also ich muss jetzt nicht bei google gehen das paket suchen
gibt sich verschiedene Package Manager.
Abt ist das Ding von Debian
und Ubuntu. DNF
beziehungsweise Yam ist das Ding von Red Hat,
Rocky Linux, Alma Linux,
Fedora. Und dann gibt es noch
Pac-Man, was ja, sind wir uns einig,
Chat, oder? Der beste Package Manager ist
für Arch Linux, by the way.
Ja, ne?
Sehr hilfreicher Chat auch.
Und bevor jetzt wieder welche ankommen, das kann dir nämlich im Linux Umfeld öfters passieren,
dass du so ein paar Wichtigtuer hast, die dann ankommen und sagen, aber Max, das ist
doch nicht Linux.
Linux ist doch nur der Kernel.
Da musst du dann einfach drüber hinweg hören.
Wichtig ist, dass man weiß, was gemeint ist.
Und es gibt auch noch ganz wichtige, die sagen, es heißt gar nicht Linux.
Chat wie heißt es richtig ich glaube wir haben da sogar ich glaube wir haben da sogar einen chatbot kommando dafür das heißt nicht linux sondern
knus
Genau
Wenn schon denn schon
Knus löschen sagt aber auch kein mensch
Woher kommt dann Knu?
Oh je.
Das ufert jetzt aus.
Google mal nach
Richard Stallman.
Stallman.
Wie auch immer man den Typ ausspricht.
Wenn du ein Bild findest von einem,
der einen ganz großen, langen Bart hat,
dann ist das der.
Moment, wir haben einen Emote von dem?
Ah ne, der Gyrosgeier hat einen, okay.
Ich glaube, das muss ich mir auch hinzufügen, das Emote.
Warte mal.
Leave channels on Twitch.
Achso, das ist ein Emote von dem.
Dann geht das nicht.
Ja, dann braucht...
Also, wenn einer ein gutes Emote findet, dann...
Ah, hier, ich habe eins.
Moment, wir haben doch sogar eins.
Wir haben doch sogar eins.
Da ist er doch.
Wir haben sogar ein Hi-Res-E-Mode.
Man spricht das GANU aus.
Meinetwegen.
Das ist der EMAX-Typ, ja.
Aber nicht nur der EMAX-Typ.
So, was habe ich denn hier nochmal jetzt eigentlich alles für Sensoren?
Das ist die SSD.
Das ist auch eine SSD.
Das ist, äh, A-Fritz, ne, A-Pitz, A-Pitz oder A-A-A-A-C-P-itz, A-C-P-I-Null, 20 Grad, was auch immer das bedeutet.
Noch mal RAM.
Äh, K10 Temp PCI.
Das ist die CPU-Temperatur, oder?
Chat.
TCTL, das ist die CPU-Temperatur
Kryptische
hätte man es ja kaum nennen können, oder?
KC-Temp-PCI
00C3-PC-Adapter
TCTL
Ich glaube, das ist die
CPU-Temperatur, warum da nicht einfach
CPU-Temperatur dran steht?
Ich weiß es nicht
SSD und
Netzwerk-Hatten-Temperatur
Ist eigentlich alles ordentlich im grünen
Bereich oder? Da schauen wir doch mal
nach. Das interessiert mich jetzt gerade.
Wie warm meine SSDs wären, wenn
ich volle Pulle drauf schreibe.
Wäre das nicht sehr niedrig für eine
CPU-Temperatur? Naja,
nö, nicht unbedingt. Ich meine, das Ding, das macht ja nichts.
Das eidelt da vor sich hin.
Ne, das ist nicht
ACP. APC sind die
USVs. Die sind ganz
okay, ja. Ja, ja. Darf das denn
nichts Wahnsinniges erwarten von einer
60 Euro USV?
Aber die tun schon.
Ne.
Das benutze ich nicht. Ich bin Hardtop-Enjoyer.
Hatten wir das letzte Mal ja schon.
So. Mount.
Wartet mal, falls ich noch
mehrere Sachen habe. Wir machen uns hier gerade mal
ein Skript.
Bin.
Bash.
Was ich einfach ausführen kann,
was meine ganzen Laufwerke mountet.
Mit Passwort.
also der fsd aber so was soll ich mal genau ich wollte nämlich mal gucken wie
warm wird dann eigentlich meine ssd das haben wir glaube ich nicht ausprobiert
sensors hätten wir mal kurz crepe nvm
after zwei zeilen drei zeilen vier zeilen fünf zeilen fünf zeilen und
zahlen ist gut guck mal wie das passt passt genau hier auf diese seite drauf watch so jetzt kriegen
wir die temperatur von meinen informiert ist ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz sicher warum es zwei
temperatur sensoren auf einer ssd gibt wahrscheinlich ist das eine der flash und das andere der controller
rate ich jetzt einfach mal so.
Gucken wir mal.
Jetzt gehen wir mal hier hin und machen mal ordentlich
synchrones Schreiben.
I.O.
Bam.
Das machen wir mal ein bisschen länger als 3 Minuten.
Wir lassen es mal
10 Minuten laufen. Da muss ich ja nicht
bei zugucken. Und dann mal
gucken, wie warm die SSDs werden.
Also die
sollten eigentlich
eigentlich sollten die ssds im rahmen sich halten weil man sieht es ja hier im stream guckte mal
seht ihr das das sind die zwei ssds und die haben beide passiv kühler drauf das ist ein
Minis Forum Nass. Ein N5 Luft.
Sag Minis Forum, dass das so heißt.
Ein N5R heißt es aber.
N5R, das gibt es erst seit einer Woche oder zwei.
Und preis-leistungsmäßig finde ich,
ist das aktuell die beste Nass-Hardware, die es gibt.
Chat, was ist das?
Was ist dieser blaue Streifen, der da unter dem Kühler durchguckt?
Das Wärmeleitpad ist das.
Das ist das Wärmeleitpad.
Ich habe das vielleicht nicht ganz ordentlich aufgeklebt.
SSDs haben ordentliche Hitzeentwicklung.
Deswegen habe ich denen auch
einen Passivkühler spendiert.
Die Dinger sind super billig bei Amazon.
Hier.
PCI-E
Nicht PCI-E, NVMe
Passivkühler.
Ja, soll ich...
Ne, ne, ne, das sind die nicht.
Die sehen zwar ähnlich aus, aber das sind die nicht.
Das hier.
9,99 kostet die mit.
Davon habe ich ein paar hier.
Das ist jetzt bestimmt nicht der High-End-Kühlkörper schlechthin für eine SSD.
Aber die sind ziemlich dünn, passen noch rein.
Und die kühlen ein bisschen, ja.
Aber das bringt nur was, wenn da ein bisschen Luftstrom drüber ist.
Ansonsten kann man sich auch sparen, ja.
Passivkühler sind Heatsinks, ja.
Okay, guck mal mal, wie warm die SSD ist.
Och, guck mal.
Wurde nicht mal gesagt, dass Passivkühler die Temperatur noch weiter hochtreiben.
Ich könnte mir das durchaus vorstellen, dass wenn du keinerlei Airflow hast,
Das vielleicht, wobei ich wüsste dann auch nicht warum, aber wenn du ein ordentliches Kühlpad hast und ein bisschen Airflow über die Kühlrippen, ist das auf jeden Fall besser als einfach nur Plastik.
Wenn du natürlich die Passivkühler einfach nur auf dein
Deine SSD drauf machst
Ohne da ein Kühlpad drunter zu haben
Dann könnte ich mir vorstellen
Gibt es Probleme, weil sich das einfach staut
Da ist ja überhaupt keine richtige Übertragung
Und Unebenheiten
Auf manchen liegt es auf, auf manchen Stellen nicht
Aber man sieht ja allein schon, dass es was bringt
Also mein Lieblings
Raspberry Pi Case ist das hier
Pi-Fleer-Case. Nehmen wir mal das da.
Ja, das ist mein Lieblings-Raspberry Pi-Case.
Und das ist passiv gekühlt und das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Hier drinnen hast du so ein Ding, das drückt auf die CPU vom Raspberry Pi
und das Gehäuse ist quasi ein großer Kühlkörper.
Das ist quasi ein Alu-Gehäuse und das gesamte Häuschen ist ein Alu-Gehäuse.
fungiert quasi als Kühlkörper
damit.
Das ist mein Lieblings-Respair-Pie-Gehäuse.
Das bringt natürlich auch
nur was, wenn
also wenn
du gar keinen Airflow hast
und dein Raspberry Pi immer unter Volllast ist,
dann wird es auch irgendwann damit zu warm,
aber es dauert deutlich länger und meistens
hast du ja nicht immer Volllast
oder aber und oder
ein bisschen Airflow.
das war lieblings es für die pikes für
strich da ist so guck mal was macht die
ssd temperatur das ist vollkommen im
rahmen leute chat hat jemand eine ahnung
was wird wärmer bei ssd ist der
controller oder der flash speicher
selbst
Irgendjemand planen?
Okay, der erste im Chat sagt Flash, der nächste sagt Controller.
Chat weiß wieder Bescheid.
Wem klau ich denn jetzt?
Michael, 5 Spelianen, aber trotzdem schön, dass du am Start bist.
Bar KI, wollen wir mal wirklich...
Okay, okay.
Was wird heißer
bei einer NVMe?
Der Controller
oder der Speicher?
Bitte mit Begründung.
Fragen wir mal hier
die KI und fragen wir mal hier ChatGPT.
was sie sagen also google ki sagt in der regel der controller deutlich heißer als
der speicher begründung hohe rechenlast
energieverbrauch unterschiedliche temperatur toleranzen
ok da bin ich trotzdem nicht so ganz überzeugt ehrlich gesagt der controller
ist das Gehirn der SSD.
Ah. Dann glauben wir das mal der KI.
Also es hält sich in Grenzen. Guck mal.
Es bleibt auf jeden Fall hier alles unter
84 Grad.
Critical.
Du kannst auch informär
hier... Du hast recht. Das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich. Das kenne ich.
Dass man dann gucken kann. Ja, aber das können wir
tatsächlich mal machen.
Up, Install, NVMe, CLI.
NVMe, CLI.
Einfach nur NVMe, ne?
Ja.
Konnte man nicht sagen
All oder irgendwie sowas?
Smartlock
ist es. Smartlock. Genau.
Smartlock.
weiß dev nvm kann man ständchen machen dann müssen wir sagen dev disk bei id nvm samsung 1t
kritiker composite warning temperature okay das war anscheinend öfters mal zu heiß das
ding aber nicht heute kritiker war es noch nie und das hier war nur vier mal
insgesamt warning temperature lg grenzen aber das geht also das geht echt klar
hier das geht echt klar ich habe darf nicht vergessen das waren
jetzt acht minuten dauer alle pulle auf die auf die ssd units fahren halt ja ja
moment kann kann ein vmc la selsius
das heißt ich kann quasi so sagen jetzt ist es in celsius ich verstehe
smart lockt zeigt noch den status oder auch nicht die chatte stimmt
hat ich kenne mich terminierungsmöglichen heißt es anders ich dachte ihr kommt jetzt mal lockt
oder wie heißt es richtig
ne
gib nur Smart Lock
oder meinst du ich soll
Minus Ad machen
ne
ist vielleicht mein N4M
E-CLI zu alt auf Debian
das kann ja immer sein ja
Show Info
in Human Readable Format
was kommt denn dabei raus
ist das sonst nicht human readable oder wie?
ach so da macht er einfach nur tausender trendzeichen und sowas okay
es würde mich tatsächlich interessieren wie man sich das anzeigen lassen kann
hier dieses thermal throttle status
Ah ne, das steht hier einfach nur drin, oder?
To get additional, not all...
Ey, ist das einfach zu alt?
Ich glaube, das ist zu alt.
Guck mal, mein NVMe-CLI ist zu alt.
Der Poster von 2017.
Ey, das ist Debian.
NVMe, CLI, GitHub.
Kann man Build Date?
NVMe, Minus, Minus Version oder sowas.
Jetzt, 2013. Wir gucken mal, was das Aktuelle ist.
216, ne, ne, ne, ne
213, ne
Das ist, ey, ohne Scheiß, Leute
Finde ich auch, für Debian-Verhältnisse
Ist das eigentlich vollkommen okay
das ist das ist irgendwas eigenes
ich habe keinen schimmer der kette finde das kommando überhaupt nichts gibt es
nvm samsung oder sowas wenn du hast wenn du aus pacific hat samsung sowas was
was hat man hier der thomas thomas grenzen zugesagt das ist gar nicht
thomas kreml
okay geht geht das samsung ssds
minus ist die die zieht sich einfach wieder sinnlose sachen aus dem arsch
oder nicht ich habe nichts gesagt anscheinend okay sorry leute es ist falsch gesagt haben
wir haben update smart drive db was macht das
Smartmon-Tools-Driver-Database
Ne
Also anscheinend
Fundst das nicht
Dieses Command
Gibt es wohl nicht
Ja
Dann weiß ich auch nicht
Was er für Schmerzen hat
Ich finde es interessant
Dass man hier
Gibt es nichts von
Nix von Samsung
Ja, gut, damit müssen wir uns jetzt nicht aufhalten
Wir wollen Paypal jetzt installieren
Das interessiert mich jetzt schon
Command
DOS not work, wir machen das wie der letzte Kack-Noob
Ich mach mal was smartctl.
Hab ich so.
Dev nvme.
Äh, minus x.
Minus a.
Und jetzt?
Falsche Syntax Plugin fehlt.
Da es sich um eine Erweiterung handelt, musst du den Namen des Herstellers voranstellen.
Äh, sicher?
Intel
Okay, gibt es vielleicht
Search
Search NVMe
Samsung unterstützt
das nicht, okay
Ja gut.
Wurscht.
Okay, die AI sagt auch, dass es nicht unterstützt wird.
Dann habe ich Pech.
Gut.
Dann installieren wir doch mal Paperless.
Wie installieren wir das denn jetzt überhaupt am besten?
also die ssd ist in alle hier überhaupt nicht kritisch warm geworden das schon
okay durchschnittliche geschwindigkeit
1000 1880 megabytes pro sekunde komplett fein
das ist ja auch außerhalb vom cash der ssd ist komplett fein alles gut kann ich mit leben
713 gigabyte geschrieben ja das gut okay also jetzt muss erst mal den ganzen kram noch einrichten
also sekunde ich muss erst mal hier in die storage verwaltung bei box box rein immer
denn hier storage? Vergessen wir mal, wo ist da Kram? Storage hier. So, ZFS removen wir für Disk
Image und Container, das wollen wir nicht benutzen. Hier wollen wir nur ISO Images,
kein Backup, kein Import, Snippets. Wollen wir haben. Das ist nämlich meine unverschlüsselte
systemplatte und jetzt werden wir zfs den schon bestehenden zfs pool nämlich
hier work safe work safe oder was pool provisioning block sei es alles gut
zack soll das körper vor allem sein legen
ich überlege jetzt wie man das gerade am besten machen machen wir das mit lxc
container oder machen wir das am besten mit der vm und darin docker was gibt es
für wie okay ich habe nämlich paypal das noch nie beschäftigt how to install
was gibt es denn da für möglichkeiten dazu das zu installieren user
installation script wieder random sachen den docker reinhauen okay
Na komm, scheiß drauf.
Ich kann es ja
anderweitig ordentlich machen.
Dann installieren wir uns mal eine VM.
Bei der Gelegenheit fällt mir gerade ein,
Aha.
Ich kann ja jetzt
hier mein Debian installieren
innerhalb von 30 Sekunden oder so.
Create4M
Name
Paypalos
ID
Nein, nicht 67
oder for 2069
oder was auch immer.
Next
ISO Image
do not use any media system
ich bin proxmox helper skript weiß weiß der gar nicht was da alles ausgeführt
wird coemo agent temporäre fix ja wie hat schon jemand mal irgendeine
temporären fix gesehen dann nicht wieder in ordnung gebracht wurde also ich nicht
das ist genauso wie die pläne am freitag da ist auch noch nie was passiert bei
bios ist okay des 32 gig ist okay da werde ich eh noch anderweitig eine
platte dran hängen dann
musst du die grafikkarte grafikeinheit durchreichen ja muss ich da müssen wir
marktland dann gucken ok wenn es soweit ist backup davon machen jetzt eca backups 0 hier
wird auf jeden fall aktiviert falls das aus irgendwelche sachen cpu kerne kriegt es 31
socket gut memory abheben das braucht wahrscheinlich ein bisserl oder oder reichen viel gig was was was
ist eine gute sache für paperless ach das reicht wahrscheinlich dicke das ganze zeug
ich brauche dann ihren eigenen container
du musst bei cpu type auf haus stellen sonst verschenkt so leistung ja wirklich
ich mein einziges denken könnte ist bei aes encryption und sowas auf der andere
seite schadet auch nichts mit haus ist
Kann man im Nachhinein erweitern, das stimmt wirklich.
Network, wunderbar.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Finish.
Dann starten wir das ganze mal.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
PXE Boot.
Ach nee, es gab doch das Problem, dass PXE Boot nicht ging, oder?
Da war doch was
Das hatten wir doch das letzte Mal schon
Kann ich faken?
Warte mal, warte mal
IPXE Chain
wartet mal das problem ist dass wenn ich das nicht ich benutze in ipx in meinem
ipx etwas drin was nur mit meinem custom ipx funktioniert und das ding
booted anscheinend mit einem anderen ipx okay dass das müssen wir gucken das
kann man jetzt mal auf die schnelle fixen
äh, ne, nicht Root, äh, was war es, Max?
Wie, wie war...
Ja, PX, der PXE-Champ.
Äh, SRV...
TFDP...
Boot...
Netboot, wo ist Net...
Netboot XYZ.
Wo ist das Tier hier? Das muss man machen.
Chain, genau, das hier suche ich, Chain
Ähm
Chain, TFTP
Ja, okay, mal gucken
Ob ich das auf die Reihe kriege, ähm
Zu blöd für Ben, das ist zu
Also wir brauchen sowas hier
Chain, minus, minus
Auto
Free, TFTP
Doppelpunkt
Ich hoffe, das mache ich so richtig
12168.2.555
Slash
Und wie heißt dieses Ding dann?
SRV
SRV TFDP
Ähm
Undi
Only
Meine Güte, ey, sowas ich das alles merken kann
Undi
Only
Punkt
KPXE
Ey, das funktioniert schon nochmal nicht.
Geil.
Wie überrede ich den denn jetzt,
von meinem PXE ordentlich zu booten?
Connection timed out.
Warum?
Warum timed out das?
Da sollte doch ein PXE-Boot laufen eigentlich.
Oder nicht?
Weil die anderen Sachen booten ja auch bei PXE.
Ja.
Ist doch.
69?
69 ist auch TFTP, oder?
So viel zu 30 Sekunden ist bei dem.
Ah ja, manchmal hast du Probleme
von den Weißteilen und nix.
Ist das nicht 69?
Aber die IP ist schon richtig.
Du kannst aus dem Proxmox IPXE-Image auch per HTTP dein Custom IPXE-Image laden.
Ja, das Ding ist nur, ich habe das auch im TFTP liegen.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Ganz im Ernst.
Warum eigentlich?
Warum kopiere ich das nicht einfach dahin?
TFTP.
Hier.
Das kopieren wir einfach nach www.html.
Da ist es.
CA-Mod.
er kriegt einfach jetzt komplett 777 ok also dann machen wir nicht die fdp sondern
http http network und reachable dhcp
das ding war vorher einfach nicht okay das hätte mit der fdp auch funktioniert
das ding war vorher einfach nicht hatte keine ip toll
ok auf geht's das muss ich mal aufschreiben das müssen wir das
müssen wir irgendwann demnächst noch mal fixen
und zwar
if else ipx wenn schon ipx geladen ist da muss ich da muss ich in den freien bauen dass der
das eine chain loaded wenn er feststeller kommt schon ipx eben in der anderen version
so ok haben wir das so da haben wir gestartet also was wollte ich jetzt installieren debian
Guck mal wie gut mein Debian Installer funktioniert, mein selbst gebastelter Debian Installer
install
Also wir installieren Debian Stable auf diese Disk mit
genau diesem Ausnahme
leute ist die schnellste db an installation die ihr je gesehen habt das nämlich das db
an cloud image was einfach nur noch drauf gedreht wird fertig beste valeri dankeschön
für den sap habe ich gar nicht gesehen ich gucke mal falls ich noch mehr übersehen habt
sagte mal ohne leute schnellere db an installation habt ihr noch nie gesehen das ist genau so schnell
wie bei einem Cloud-Anbieter.
Splixter,
danke schön für den Sub, falls ich übersehen habe.
Pogu.
Pogers.
Hippofett.
Jetzt kann ich endlich wieder was zu essen leisten,
Chat, nach den Prime Subs.
So, da sind wir schon.
IP 2.1.2.1.
SSR 1.2.1.2.1.
naja fix ssh yes oh shit er wollen wollen das ist nicht max das ist debian
et da sind wir schon sind auf der kiste drauf also das war wirklich schnell
abt upgrade yes
Ah, Cup-Kernel-Update sogar.
Dann würde ich sagen, müssen wir gleich nochmal rebooten.
Immer noch N5 Luft, ja.
AI Luft.
Um genau zu sein.
Nicht einfach nur Luft.
AI Luft.
So.
So, da sind wir wieder.
Paperless-Stells.
Alles klar.
So, Chat.
Wir haben jetzt die Auswahl.
Wir probieren das mit
Docploi.
Ne, mit Docploi. Chat, Chat, Chat.
Mit Docploi probieren wir das nicht.
Weil dann leake ich wieder meine Public-IP.
Weil Docploi immer die Public...
Da muss ich quasi euch ausblenden
während... Muss ich schwarzen
Bildschirm machen während der Docploi-Installation.
wir machen das einfach mal so ok direkt kuba nichts kuba net ist wir machen das
einfach mal so also paperless install wie ging das hier setup wir machen es
mal einfach wie die ganzen kaknubs wir kopieren sinnlose bach sachen da rein
just installation script als doch also was muss ich installiert haben docker
und docker compose müssen installiert sein wartet mal kurz
Okay, Räder am Start.
Mach doch die Tür zu!
Oh, ich hab...
Das muss man echt alles dreimal sagen, das nervt.
So.
Schättke.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Da bin ich wieder.
Also, weiter geht's.
Ich hab gerade auf Twitter geguckt, ne?
Ähm.
Ich hab auf Twitter heute Morgen
mein Erlebnis vom Joggen gepostet.
Ich bin heute Morgen
hier bei uns
eine Runde gelaufen, so
plus minus, bisschen war es, sieben Kilometer
und auf dem Rückweg
laufe ich so vorbei
und da sehe ich einen Schwarzen, der
irgendwelches Plastikzeug
so gewaltsam
durch die Absperrung in den Brunnen
reindrückt.
Also bei uns stehen im Ort relativ
viele Brunnen rum
und da ist überall
so ein Metallgitter, aber
wenn du ordentlich Anlauf, ordentlich
Schmackes hast, ja, und dann
drückt da irgendwas in dieses
oder zieht es raus
oder keine Ahnung, irgendwie splittert
das Plastik dann in diese Absperrung
rein und da bin
ich an dem vorbeigelaufen, hab
mich komisch angeguckt und hat da so eine
ganz wilde, ganz wilde
Geste gemacht, so
wie soll man das beschreiben, so
kennt ihr noch früher aus der Schule
die
Bist du fresh, Leute?
So ungefähr hat er, so ungefähr eine Geste
hat er gemacht, so.
Und hat mich übelst aggressiv
mit angestarrt dabei.
Hab ich auch gedacht, Alter, was ist mit dir los?
Bin ja lieber schnell
weitergerannt.
Hab ich vorhin auf Twitter gepostet,
vielleicht sein Drogenverstecken oder so, keine Ahnung.
Diesen Vorfall hab ich
vorher auf Twitter gepostet.
Und das Beste, was den Leuten einfällt,
da drauf zu schreiben ist,
Max, willst du AfD?
Oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ansonsten fällt den Leuten alles nichts mehr ein.
Das ist anscheinend
das größte Problem, was wir haben.
Classic.
Ja, Classic.
So.
Also, Install.
Also, Moment mal.
Ich muss Docker noch installieren.
ab install docker.io und docker compose jetzt mal eine ganz doofe frage ist docker compose
nicht mittlerweile sogar in docker mit drin war das nicht so ich muss doch docker compose nicht
extra installieren relativ sicher ist doch mal docker compose ist not a docker command
Hä? War das nicht so?
Ganz im Ernst, Chat.
Also da muss ich jetzt was zu sagen.
Selbst wenn das keine Relevanz hat,
man kann sich doch nicht vor jedem Post,
vor jedem Wort, vor jedem Satz,
den man sagt, überlegen,
Ah, könnte sich da auf Twitter oder so irgendwie einer dran gestört fühlen oder nicht, dann hast du ja den ganzen Tag nichts anderes zu tun.
Hast du gelesen? Ja, das ist Wahnsinn.
Es sollte sich das nicht mal alles so zu Herzen nehmen.
Und anscheinend hat es ja für mich in irgendeiner Art und Weise Relevanz gehabt, zumindest in dem Moment.
Sonst hätte ich es ja nicht geschrieben.
Twitter ist Müll
Twitter war schon immer so eine Plattform
Wo es darum ging
Dem gegenüber
Ist eigentlich egal aus welcher Richtung
Ja
Twitter war schon immer eine Plattform, wo man versucht hat
Dem gegenüber seine moralische Überlegenheit zu demonstrieren
Warum bist du nicht auf Masterdon?
Weil keine Sau auf Masterdon ist
Ähm
Twitter geht immer darum
um dem anderen seine moralische Überlegenheit zu demonstrieren
und zu zeigen, dass man irgendwie eigentlich der bessere Mensch ist.
Oder dass man, wie man so schön sagt, dass man den High Ground hat.
Wisst ihr, dafür ist Twitter da.
Twitter ist dafür da, um anderen Leuten zu sagen, man hat den High Ground.
Richtig viel ist auf Masternode ernsthaft.
Ist da mittlerweile wirklich so viel?
Übrigens, warum ist eigentlich Docker Composed
not a Command?
Ist meine Docker-Version zu alt?
Von wann ist denn
meine Docker-Version?
Von wann ist die?
Docker, nicht Minecraft
Von 2024
24.
Okay.
Absearch.
Docker.
Compose.
Das ist separat?
Ich dachte, Docker.
Compose.
Separat.
Gibt es nicht mehr.
Compose.
naja jetzt geht's gibt es eigentlich docker kompost selbst dann immer noch als gibt es beides noch
ok dann gehen wir jetzt mal her docker ps soll ich das besser als user ach komm scheiße wir
lassen es einfach als gut laufen easy wir können noch user mod das chat ich
nach 20 jahren linux nach über 20 jahren linux ich kann immer noch diesen
kram nicht auswendig user mod minus a minus g docker debian so okay ich glaube
das war richtig ich glaube ich glaube das war richtig etc
ja tatsächlich es geht bestimmt auch schöner na gut dann docker ps darf ich
noch nicht aber jetzt locker dicker locker ps ok bär
Das Skript wird die Konferenz starten.
Paperless Nginx Applikation.
Die URL Paperless wird
an...
1.2.168.
Otherwise can be left blank.
Ich hoffe, das liegt
meine IP nicht gleich wieder.
Port 8080.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Chat. Kann ich das machen?
Als Nicht-Root, der macht
doch da bestimmt irgendwelche Dinge außerhalb von Docker noch.
Doch die Bahn ist, glaube ich, noch bei Twitter.
Die Bahn ist noch bei Twitter.
Viele anderen sind nicht mehr bei Twitter.
Ich glaube, der RMV ist nicht mehr bei Twitter.
Polizei Hanau gab es noch nie bei Twitter.
Ein paar sind nicht mehr bei.
Es ist mir schon ein paar Mal aufgefallen, als ich flamen wollte,
dass derjenige, den ich flamen, Heise auch nicht mehr, leider.
sicher dass er das mit docker installiert nicht blank ja weil er sagt wir sollen
schuhe melken dass docker und docker compose install sind
können time so ein jahr utc genau database back at sq lite wir brauchen keine extra datenbank
Was ist Apache Tikka?
Ich war schon an, was zu essen.
So was Indisches.
Indisches Hähnchen.
Paperless is able to use to support office documents such as Word, Excel, PowerPoint.
It requires more resources due to required services.
office documents warum nicht ocr language de user id ist mir eigentlich
egal
Home db an paperless engine x ok
Home db an paperless engine x konsum media folder
Er ist ja eh nur zum ausruhen data folder
paperless username db an passwort 123456
e-mail genau press
Okay, das macht jetzt mal 3000 Sachen.
Was passiert da gerade?
Wie findest du eigentlich ESP Home?
An sich ne coole Sache.
Ich hab auch ein bisschen schon damit rumgespielt.
Aber ich programmier lieber meinen eigenen Kram für den ESP32.
Wofür ich es vielleicht mal verwenden werde in Zukunft sind so Bluetooth-Proxys.
Fertig.
ok und jetzt läuft paperless unter port 8000 8000 ok probieren wir 12 16 82.1 21 8000 nicht
800 8000 da sind wir doch dbj 12 456 zack erst mal da krieger aus an die da kriege ich aus okay
Das Theme ist jetzt nicht irgendwie großartig hübsch, finde ich.
Gibt es da noch ein anderes Theme?
Boah, das ist ja mega überladen.
Django ist das. Aha.
Ich habe aktuell noch keine Platte drin.
kann man hier
irgendein Theme umstellen?
Seht ihr hier irgendwas?
Ach, Dark Mode.
Auge!
Kann man irgendwie nicht mehr rausnehmen.
Aber das ist tatsächlich weniger anstrengend.
Weil das ist, das Dark Theme
hat mir nicht gefallen.
Ach du kannst ja Theme Color einstellen?
Ja?
Echt?
Äh...
Wo?
Ach hier, Theme Color!
Enable Dark Mode und jetzt?
Ach hier, Theme Color.
Enable Dark Mode. Und jetzt?
Äh.
Na.
Ich war's nicht. Ich war's nicht.
Ist vielleicht was Blaues?
Was hellblaues? So.
was hier, hä?
Das sieht doch ganz brauchbar aus und wir können
Dark Mode anlassen.
Naja.
Nee.
Nee, Leute. Nee, Leute.
Das Dark Theme ist nix.
Das ist kein gutes Dark Theme.
Unten über Update Checking.
Ja, ich hab's ja schon gefunden gerade.
weil er nie sagt gerade auch schwer überlegen mainz server denn noch in einem richtigen pc
gehäuse wohnt auf 1 5 luft umzuziehen habe nur etwas bammel dass die fünf spinning raster auch
ordentlich funktionieren doch der hat eine extra lüfter nur für festplatten ich gehe mal davon aus
dass du bessere belüftung im ding sogar hast der hat der hat eine extra belüftung was von von hinten
vorne durch von vorn nach hinten durchzieht direkt an den disks ich glaube
da musst du dir keine gedanken machen du kannst du sogar im bios selbst
regeln die ganzen lüfter kannst du einstellen wenn es hier zu laut ist
kannst du ein bisschen runter drehen und so was und für den cpu lüfter kannst du
eine eigene temperatur kurve festlegen
Da würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen, dass das N5 nicht genug R hat.
So, also wir starten natürlich keine Tour.
Wie kommen wir da hin, wenn wir auf einmal Tutorials lesen würden?
Also, you can...
So, was macht man damit denn jetzt?
Zeige mal her.
Also, das erste, was ich in meinem...
Example...
Ne, Beispielrechnung.
Rechnung, Beispielrechnung.
Hier, hier, perfekt.
Das da brauchen wir.
Sehr geehrter Herr Mustermann.
Exzellent.
Das werden wir jetzt gleich nochmal paperless hochladen.
Wie, wie, wie, ah hier, Upload Document.
Also okay, einfach rein copy-pasten kann man.
Jobfiles anywhere
Das finde ich schon mal doof, dass man nicht Copy-Pasten kann, Leute
Wisst ihr, ob es da
Gibt es Plugins? Hat das Plugins?
Gibt es Plugins, wo man Dokumente Copy-Pasten kann?
Weil ich, weil ich weiß
Ich bin ein richtig
Braindead Copy-Paster
Jobfiles anywhere, ja
Anscheinend auch nicht so anywhere
ich bin ein richtig brand copy pester das ist keine pdf das ist die jpeg
safe rechnungsvorlage 5p beste was ist eigentlich ein use case für paperless
alle möglichen briefe von der versicherung vom finanzamt steuerkram
Rechnungsvorlage 5P
Open Document
Okay, und jetzt?
Ach guck mal, der hat OCRt jetzt schon, oder?
Vielen Dank für Ihren Auftrag
Ja, der hat schon OCRt
Oh ja, das ging ja gut
Das ist aber noch ganz ohne KI jetzt.
Links kannst du auf Content gehen.
Wo?
On Content.
Content.
Aha
Ach hier
Ihr Partner in Sachen
Name, was auch immer
Okay
Ich gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus
das OCR wird nicht so geil sein,
wenn man Dinger mit dem Handy zum Beispiel
fotografiert und sowas.
Na gut.
Metadata?
Tagging und sowas. Das geht gar nicht
hier, oder?
Hier, Actions?
Reprocess?
More like this?
Details
Hier, Text kann man hier angeben
Das hätte ich halt gerne
dass das automatisch gemacht wird
Das kann man mit
irgendeinem KI-Plugin mal ausprobieren
ob das automatisch
Date created, 8.7.2015
Wie kommt
er da drauf?
Ach, weil das hier steht
Naja
Die Tags musst du einmalig anlegen, also kann ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel sagen, Tag Name Rechnung.
Rechnung.
Ups.
Ah, okay.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Document Type.
An dem Moment, Document Type ist dann eher Rechnung, oder?
Oh, warte mal, was ist das?
Matching Algorithm.
Learn matching automatically.
Any documents contain any of these words?
Funst das, dass er das automatisch checkt?
Machen wir jetzt hier Tags.
Tags.
Wie lösche ich denn den wieder?
Rechnung.
Steuer.
Learn automatically.
Okay.
Das kann man bestimmt hier auswählen.
So, ähm...
Steuer.
Da muss ich mich erst noch mal dran gewöhnen.
jetzt hier documents text configures settings configuration
aha barcodes ich glaube die musik ist aus
Waren bei deinem N2-Kühlkörper die Pads dabei?
Ne, wie gesagt, ich habe das hier.
NVMe Passive...
Hallo?
NVMe Passive Cooler.
ich habe hier von so ein paar dinger da die übrigens auch teurer geworden sind
mittlerweile doch bei mir haben wir auch 57 oder sowas gekostet
da sind jetzt nicht die geilsten pets aber die sind schön klein
also je nachdem wie viel platz du hast bringt was ja ja die bringen auf jeden
fall was bringe ich viel als bringe aber natürlich nur richtig was wenn du
gewissen airflow darüber hast wenn das wenn das steht dann ist das natürlich
nichts bei meiner wahl mit pets ja na ohne pets ist natürlich kacke ohne pets sagt also die wir
haben gerade einen test gemacht mit ssds hier guck mal ich kann es ja noch mal zeigen ja also
wenn ich wenn ich jetzt immer voll wir machen wir was anderes wir machen wir schreiben jetzt
parallel drauf ja mehrere dateien parallel auf die ssd der hat es der
schreibt jetzt gerade angeblich wollte sagen angeblich 12 gig die sekunde das
ist etwas heck w der knallt gerade richtig auf die ssds drauf wie du hier
siehst aber heftig knallte auf die ssds drauf und du siehst hier unten zählt sich
Grenzen. Ich glaube, das höchste,
was wir heute hatten, war 78 Grad nach
10 Minuten Dauerbefeuerung.
Und auch nicht combined,
sondern nur ein der Sensoren. Also,
das ist wirklich iets.
Easy.
Also, bringt schon was.
Ja.
Die passiven. Ich habe jetzt keinen direkten
Vergleich,
wie es ohne Passivkühler wäre. Das heißt ich kann das jetzt natürlich nicht hundertprozentig
bestätigen. Vielleicht wäre das mit Passivkühler auch so kalt, aber ich würde ganz ehrlich davon
ausgehen, ohne Passivkühler würden die öfters mal gerade bei zehn Minuten Dauerbefeuerung mal
an der Temperaturgrenze kratzen. Ja und das NAS hat einen extra SSD-Kühler, also nur da drin,
nur für die ssds und da ist natürlich top mit so passiv kühler so ordentlichen
airflow darüber kann ich nichts passieren
ja guck mal das ist super hier das ding haut hier grad 5 5,5 gig im durchschnitt
weg auf die nvm ssds auf die zwei stück jetzt ist der cash langsam aufgebraucht
vermutlich und die ddr 50 58 61 vollkommen in ordnung die temperatur
da kann man echt nichts sagen
Okay.
Abbrechen.
Weiter im Text. So, wo kann ich jetzt meine
Tags löschen?
Custom Fields? Storage Path?
Document Types?
Document Types? Okay. Da kann man den
gerade mit Rechnung schon mal anpassen.
Aber wo kann ich
Tags löschen? Tags sind ja irgendwas...
Ach, hier oben. Alter, bin ich blind, man.
steht ganz fett oben text aller die lied
ist das hier pick random color
boomer ja aber richtig viels old
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
ok also da guckt man weiter also ich würde mal sagen so dieses automatische tag und so was das
ist wahrscheinlich wirklich was was man besser mit kai erledigt lässt was mich jetzt noch
interessieren würde ist man kann ja anscheinend nur hier dokumente hochladen wobei ihr habt gesagt
es gibt doch in fahrt wo man dokumente hin kopieren kann das ist mal ein bisschen rum
gucken drin was ich damit will zum beispiel sachen vom finanzamt für die steuern irgendwelche rechnungen
vom arzt irgendwas will ich meine dokumente hochladen und dann will ich die durchsuchen
können ich dann zum beispiel sagen kann zeigt mir alles alles an mit steuern oder steuer so
oder zeigt mir alles an was rechnung ist so irgendwie sowas in der richtung am besten halt
wenn ich noch ein KI-Chat hätte und fragen könnte, so nach dem Motto, wie viel habe ich im letzten Monat für Amazon ausgegeben, so.
Mal gucken, ob das mit irgendwelchen KI-Plugins funktioniert.
Storage Path, aha, Create.
Learn Matching Automatically
Ich checke nicht so genau, was er damit jetzt eigentlich will, ehrlich gesagt
Schau auf die Doku
Ja, ich glaube auch
Create New Storage Path
File Name Handling.
Ach, da kann man solche Dinge...
Okay.
Ich muss mir mal ein bisschen die Settings angucken.
Was gibt es denn hier alles?
Display Language.
Items per Page.
Ja, alles gut.
Passt.
Update Checking.
Enable Notes.
global search
ok
just pdf viewer provided by browser auf jeden fall
haben wir sonst noch die permissions bin eh nur ich document processing notifications user wie
gesagt nur ich application configuration logo title paper champ genau ocr settings
pdf pdf pdf 1 pdf 2 pdf 3 alles klar
pdf version
language pages die pd das juckt mich jetzt erst mal grad net marco settings
Ach, sieht man da auch die...
Könnte ich dann zum Beispiel irgendwie sagen, Rechnung von Amazon?
Amazon?
Automatic Matching.
Da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt.
Amazon Rechnung.
Ich brauche eine Amazon Rechnung.
Eine Test Amazon Rechnung brauche ich.
Das hier. Top.
da gibt es nicht irgendwie normale amazon rechnung beispiel oder sowas hier
perfekt wieder das ist doch gut aus sehr gut das nehmen wir jetzt
er braucht locker 50 beispiel okay da machen wir das jetzt gleich mal mit ki
ich finde ich finde es aber blöd dass es gibt es paperless plugins gibt es so was
k chloride system wurde davon BMW
was zum paar source
ok
ich habe gedacht kann man hat man das copy paste das mit der eines probleme
gleich aus das probleme gleich aus
ich habe ja man kann irgendwie copy pasten da na gut dann speichern wir das
hier nochmal?
By the way, warum habe ich hier random
Leute im Internet?
Haben ihre Amazon-Rechnungen eigentlich am Start?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Irgendwelche
random Documents aus dem Internet, man.
Na gut.
Dann benutzen wir das halt mal hierfür zum
Testen.
Documents
Ich hab schon wieder nicht
Upload Documents
Eins
Okay
Der hat nix getaggt und der hat auch nicht gecheckt
Dass es Amazon ist, oder?
Content
Metadata
Ne, der hat nichts gecheckt
Ne, der hat nichts, das hat er nicht gecheckt
Und der Empfänger ist jetzt auch nicht so geil
Ne, ne, ne, das kannst du vergessen hier
Guck mal, okay, aber das ist ein gutes
Das ist ein gutes Testdokument
wie löscht man die wie löscht man die dokumente wieder so hier da hat er die
lied ruft trash trash mt trash ich gehe übrigens noch mal in die settings und
dass wir nicht den eingebauten da probieren das jetzt mal mit den plugins
wir machen das jetzt per ki
Mal checken.
Also was gibt es? Es gibt Paperless AI
und Paperless GPT.
Da muss ich jetzt erstmal gucken,
was der Unterschied ist.
Look like AI can do chat with documents.
Hast du schon AI konfiguriert?
Ne, ne, ne, noch gar nicht.
Also was ist jetzt der Unterschied
zwischen Paypal als GPT
oder als AI?
Wir probieren einfach beides aus,
Leute. Fangen wir an mit Paypal als GPT.
Use LLMs and LLM Vision
to handle Paypal as NGX
documents. Digitalization
Powered by AI.
Ah, das ist written in go.
Das ist nicht
placing the fast rust.
Okay, wie installiert man das jetzt?
Chat übrigens.
Schön, dass ihr am Start seid.
Schön, dass so viele dabei sind.
Bei so einem Thema.
Ich denke, man interessiert wahrscheinlich auch viele.
Aber nice, dass ihr am Start seid.
Wenn es euch gefällt, könnt ihr mir bei der Gelegenheit ein Follow dalassen. Würde mich freuen.
Getting started. Installation.
Access to LLM Provider.
APK. Models like. Running. Ulama.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt erstmal Ulama installieren.
Aber wir können Ulama einfach hier auf die Debian-Kiste hauen.
Ich hab zu wenig Nasus, genau.
Ist eigentlich Ulama
bei Debian mit dabei?
Nee.
Oder doch? Nee, oder?
Dann ist es eine Library dabei,
aber Ulama selber nicht.
Und was zum Teufel ist
Debian GPT?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das was ist, was mich...
Wie bekommst du die GPU zu Olamar?
Stimmt!
Ha!
Das ist jetzt das eigentliche Problem.
Okay, okay.
Kobalt-CPP.
Ne, ne, wir machen jetzt nicht alles gleichzeitig.
Ich schreib mir das mal auf.
Das können wir dann vielleicht auch nochmal probieren.
Robalt, CPP, erinnere mich nachher mal dran.
Jetzt machen wir es erstmal mit Ulama.
Linux install.
Ja.
Bäm, wir kölnen das einfach wieder da rein.
Fertig.
Und dann brauchen wir...
Ja, was ist ein gutes Model dafür?
Also, GPT-OSS kann man doch eigentlich nicht viel falsch machen, oder?
Vielleicht steht da ja hier irgendwas, was ein gutes Model dafür ist.
Paypal ist AI, braucht ja ein Model.
Und da ist die Frage, welches da eigentlich ganz gut ist.
Was willst du machen?
Ja, ich weiß ja noch nicht, was die Dinger können.
So automatische Zusammenfassungen oder Tags oder was auch immer.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Ulama fleicht mit LXC, dann müllst du den Proxmox-Host nicht zu.
Ich habe es aktuell in der VM.
Hier, das ist eine eigene Debian VM.
Da muss ich jetzt meine Grafikkarte nochmal passtruhen, in der Hoffnung, dass das funktioniert.
No Nvidia, AMD, Olamo will run in CPU only.
Okay.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, wie das mit GPU-Paththrough funktioniert.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das überhaupt ordentlich funktioniert.
Ich habe gelesen, es muss äußerst, äußerst painstamp sein, eine Grafikkarte durchzureichen.
ähm, also eine
GPU
CPU Kombi durchzureichen
in der VM, schauen wir mal
äh
PC Device, RAW Device
so
was davon ist jetzt meine
GPU
ich hab, ich weiß noch nicht
was davon meine gpu ist das da keine ahnung was davon ist meine gpu die gpu
wird vom haus benutzt ja das muss ich irgendwie voran loben oder sowas gucken
wir mal also sieht man da irgendwas
äh, GLI 4.7, ja, das ist nicht, nicht, nicht so übel,
VGA, hier, das da, C, C00, das da, das ist die GPU, ja, C, ja,
Das ist die GPU.
All Functions.
Ich mach da mal ein Häkchen hin.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was das sein soll.
So, jetzt müssen wir erst mal Shutdown machen.
Oh, falscher Knopf.
Wohl.
Ich hab doch genug RAM.
So friert das System ein.
Wirklich? Mal gucken.
Schauen wir mal.
Bam.
Ne, der startet erstmal gar nicht.
Oder ist es jetzt...
Oh, es ist wirklich...
Es ist gefreest, Leute.
F.
Max, meinst du,
2026 kommt noch ein Video? Ja.
So einfach ist es anscheinend schon immer nett,
Leute. Aber zum Glück...
Aber zum Glück
haben wir unsere...
Nee, guck mal. Moment, da
kann ich noch.
Was?
Ach, der ist
rebooted. Der ist
rebooted.
Ich hab den komplett
zerschossen quasi. Okay, das funktioniert
nicht. Proxmox PCI
Pass Through.
PCI
Ne, PCI Pass Through.
IOMO ist enabled. Ist enabled.
Blacklisting Drivers.
Okay, also, die übliche Geschichte.
Und Bios muss ich auf UEFI umstellen?
Oder?
Okay, also.
modpro minus r amd gpu
hab ich jetzt
jetzt hab ich gar keine
grafikausgabe mehr hier oder
ne logisch weil die amd gpu unloaded ist
Geht GPU-Parsethrough nur wenn die VM UEFI ist?
Oder geht das auch mit BIOS?
ROM-Parser?
What?
also was will das von mir
Die VM muss so eh wie sein...
Okay, checken wir nochmal, was jetzt passiert.
Wir checken nochmal, was jetzt passiert, wenn ich jetzt starte.
Okay, es läuft noch
Chat, Chat, es läuft noch
Es läuft noch
Aber die startet nicht
Es crasht zumindest schon mal nicht
Das wird eine längere Aktion als die Netzwerkkarte
Letztens, ich merke schon
So einfach geht das anscheinend nicht
Ja, du hast recht, wir machen das lieber mit dem LXC-Container
Du hast recht.
Das ist...
Okay, Grafikkarte durchreichen ist
anscheinend größere Aktion.
Dann entfernen wir das mal wieder.
Liegt das vielleicht daran, dass ich hier
All Functions oder so ausgewählt habe?
Es hängt...
Guck mal, es hängt komplett.
Can't lock.
Okay.
Äh, VM? Ne, was war das? Q? QVM? Oder so? QM?
Stopp!
For 2069!
Okay!
Reboot!
Oh, der rebootet jetzt gar nicht mehr, oder was?
Oh, shit.
Chat, ist so kaputt, dass er nicht mal rebootet.
Ah, doch, jetzt.
Jetzt, okay.
Okay, wir sehen wieder was.
Wir sehen wieder was.
Wie stoppt man denn den Start-Task?
Irgendwie unten über das Menü?
Ach Leute, ich weiß, warum das Ding nicht starten konnte.
Wisst ihr, warum das Ding nicht starten konnte?
Das liegt daran, weil ich meine Festplatte nicht decrypted habe.
Die liegen doch auf einer encrypted Platte.
Modprobe.
Das geht jetzt, pass auf, das geht jetzt, easy.
start
ohne scheiße ist wieder gefriest obwohl ich obwohl ich die amd-gpu anrodet habe
okay ich glaube das funktioniert nicht so gut wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe
Ich kopiere mir das gerade mal.
Ist das?
Ryzen 7000 Series Proxmox.
Get the processors, integrate graphics, run a GPU path through.
Vor zwei Jahren. Nice.
konfiguriert jupiter pass zu jomo habe ich schon in ebeld ok ok ok ja das ist
die größere act es ist wirklich ich sehe es ein dass ein größerer act das
machen wir heute nicht das ist sonst zu viel zeit quest da muss ich erst mal
Damit muss ich mich erstmal in Ruhe beschäftigen.
Das machen wir nicht. Wir installieren sie im LXC-Container.
Ne, das ist sonst wirklich zu viel Sidequest.
Da kommen wir überhaupt nicht zu Paperless.
Okay.
Dann entfernen wir das mal wieder.
Remove.
Achso.
Ha.
Wir überprüfen mal kurz, ob wir immer noch die Probleme haben.
Ich starte das mal wieder.
Ob wir immer noch die Pro...
Ah, ich kack nu.
Ich will doch eigentlich...
Ich muss doch starten hier, dass ich meine Encrypted Discs einhängen kann.
Hoffentlich startet es jetzt auch.
Ich will mal kurz gucken, ob der jetzt...
Ob der immer noch die gleichen Probleme wie das letzte Mal hat.
Ja.
Upinstall
IPerf
3. Ob der immer noch die gleichen
Probleme in der VM hat, wie das letzte Mal?
Wahrscheinlich.
IPerf 3 minus S.
So, und jetzt gucken wir
mal IPerf 3 1 2 1.
Ja, guck, der ist immer noch lahmes
Fuck in der VM. Das ist
dieser Kack
Realtek Treiber.
Wenn ich
den originalen Realtek-Treiber benutze,
naja, dann
ist es schnell, aber so nicht.
Aber ich hab keinen Bock heute auf Netzwerkkarte,
die dritte. Für Paypal das reicht das
erste Mal. Okay, also heißt
im Endeffekt, so ohne weiteres
können wir hier Ulama nicht
drauf laufen lassen. Dann
legen wir jetzt einen Container an.
Create Container. Ne, aber dafür
müssen wir erst einmal
Container-Images runterladen.
templates debian
multi q das bringt nichts aber das letzte mal schon ausprobiert das bringt nichts das liegt
am real tech treiber wenn ich den anderen real tech treiber nehme geht es exakt mit den gleichen
settings schnell der real tech treiber ist ein witz im linux kernel der besteht wir haben uns
das letzte mal angeguckt der besteht zu 95 prozent auf aus magic bytes die
irgendwo hingeschrieben werden und keiner weiß was es macht es hat irgendein
real tech mitarbeiter committed und es ist nachher genauso magic wie vorher und
ihr eigener 3 war wurde halt noch ein bisschen weiterentwickelt aber sie haben
für linux 6 mal ab streamt ziemlich ziemlich verkackt also hier haben wir
unseren debian dann mama create container passwort 123456 massive passwort container
id aber 100 für die summe unter uns hostname prominent privilege nesting ich gehe mal davon
aus wir müssen ein privilege container machen wenn ich da was durchreichen will
tippe ich jetzt einfach mal drauf so templates debian standard disks
disk space da kommt der mauer mal ein bisschen mehr gegen 32 options ja ja schon
ähm, next
CPU-Cores, ja gut
der kriegt 5 CPU-Cores, weil
Olamas stellt's
Memory
Tja
Kann man auch sagen
Unlimited?
Ne
Geht nicht, ne
naja dann würde ich mal sagen kriegt es 24 24 gig
24 gig swap auch das braucht das kein mehr das macht aus network der cp keine ipv6 dns
ok start after created ja wobei will ich da noch etwas mountain ja ich will da noch was
mountain ja wunderbar ich will ja noch meine disk mountain brauche ich gar nicht
brauche ich doch moment moment moment ich bin wie man sich jetzt in meinem
docker container sind wir hier ist aus dass gut disk ich würde gerne
verzeichnis mountain geht das so hier ihr path also durch der quasi sagen
Wir machen mal hier einen Ordner.
Work, Save,
MKD, oh je, da liegt schon ganz viel.
Da liegt auch noch so mein Open Media World
drauf. MKD,
ja.
Olamer.
Ja.
Work, Save,
Olamer. Ist das der Path
im Container?
Ne, warte mal. Hä?
Moment, wie kriege ich ihn da jetzt?
Wie kriege ich ihn da?
Ein Verzeichnis durchgereicht?
Okay.
How to mount host directory LXC Proxmox.
Musst du ein Config machen.
Mount host directory into LXC container.
PCT-Set
MP
Okay
Das ist wahrscheinlich meine ID
MP0
HostDir
Also da kommt jetzt hin
Work
Save
Olamar
Und MP ist das innerhalb vom Container
Äh
Slash
Ja
Okay
Ach guck mal, da steht er ja
Nice
Ah ja gut, starten wir mal
Was haben wir für eine IP?
1, 3, 2
Fix, SSH
Jawohl, yes
Ne, Moment, es ist gut
Gut
Äh
Moment
W, w
Welcher User ist es denn überhaupt
standardmäßig?
Gut, ne?
Das geht nicht.
Das Passwort stimmt nicht.
Kann das sein, dass
er standardmäßig nur
SSH hieß?
erlaubt und ich deswegen mich ausgesperrt habe und ist es abelt das ist ja doof
die kommischen dann hier auf die konsole drauf
du kannst auf dem haus doch pct enter ach das geht
ja okay das muss man das muss man wissen ssh ssh d konflikt ab installen
install blitz
hallo container stellts
ich breche mal ab ich weiß nicht so genau wir gucken mal ob der
container da ist geht der der maunter ist alles ist da
ok weil es auch immer das rum gesponnen hat und jetzt sage ich einfach film etc ssh ssh
de auch wenn ich richtig tippen könnte es ist halt ich kann immer richtig ssh de config
allow
irgendwas mit allow heißt das doch
root
permit root login
da schreiben wir jetzt einfach rein
yes
reboot
hoffentlich hat das jetzt gecheckt
Ne.
Hat er das jetzt gecheckt oder nicht?
Sehen wir gleich.
Ne, hat er nicht gecheckt.
Okay.
Stopp.
Start.
Äh, was?
Stay on page?
Ja, dann meinetwegen.
Mach.
Und jetzt?
Also, das juckt dir nicht, ne?
Hä? Doch, doch, Moment.
Das hat funktioniert, aber...
Der Login funktioniert. Guck mal, der Login hängt jetzt.
Vielleicht, weil ich
X-Formuling anmachen will?
Hä? Was war denn das jetzt?
Das hängt.
Was ist denn da kaputt jetzt?
Was ist denn das wieder für komisches Zeug?
Oh, der Ordner ist da und
der Funst auch.
Was ist das für komisches kaputtes Zeug?
Also da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich von Proxmox erwartet, dass so was einfach brain dead sinnlos funktioniert.
Guck mal, man braucht ja nicht drei Stunden, um sich nach PSSH einzuloggen.
Was ist das? Was ist das? Seht ihr das?
Das war ja ewig.
Na gut, wir sind ja aber drauf eingeloggt.
Dann installieren wir jetzt Olamar.
Up, Install, Curl.
S.
Also irgendwas stimmt mit dem Container nicht.
Irgendwas stimmt mit dem Container nicht.
Der soll kein DNS-Reverse-Lookup gedünst bei SSH machen.
Hoffentlich macht er das nicht.
Moment, der hat eine IPv6-Adresse.
Uh, geh weg.
Wie kann man dem das abgewöhnen,
dass er keine IPv6-Adresse hat?
Stimmt, was hat der eigentlich für ein Warning?
System D257 detect,
you may need to enable nesting.
Kann man hier Added sagen?
Man kann es nicht ausschalten.
Was?
Features?
Options?
Das ist ein Container, ne?
kann ich denn nesting in ebeln ich sehe es erzählt ihr es ich sehe kein nesting
vielleicht weil es kein vielleicht weil es denn denn denn privilege container
ist da ist das quasi schon so klick features ach da
das ist immer das jetzt genau macht update upgrade
Yes
Okay, so
Ich warte das erste mal bis der hier
Also ganz ehrlich irgendwas stimmt mit dem container nicht das ist nicht normal dass das alles so lange hängt
Dass das schreit gebe ich hier jetzt schreit nach dns reverse lookup oder sowas in der richtung
boxbox lx boxbox lxd ist able ipv6
excellent das machen wir moment das ist das das ist jetzt den kölner parameter das hat
mit dem container nichts zu tun oder
und das naja wir haben es ist es ist es ist es ist es ist es ist es ist es ist
Wohin?
Das ist CTL-Conf.
Gibt's nicht.
Das ist CTLD.
Geil.
Es wird doch auch nicht
an IPv6 liegen.
Reboot.
Ich find's auch witzig,
dass er nicht checkt, dass der
rebooten soll.
In meinem Container kann ich wirklich rebooten,
aber ich bin dem ja eigentlich ein bei LXC Container.
Ging das? Der hat sich halt einfach ausgeschaltet
und wieder eingeschaltet.
Aber das juckt
den anscheinend nicht.
Uptime? 5 Minuten.
Ne.
Mit Nesting geht das dann, meinst du?
Gut, jetzt haben wir Nesting an.
Ah!
Jetzt flutscht das auch
deutlich schneller.
Okay, an Nesting liegt das.
Whatever.
Das muss man halt wissen, ansonsten hat man Pech.
Oh, Lama.
Bam.
ab install zstd habe ich jetzt so lange einst
ok
aber es wird anscheinend nicht aktiviert wenn man einen privilege container installiert ich
habe einfach mal auf gut glück mit privilege container gemacht weil ich denke das braucht
für den pass von der grafikkarte jetzt lasst uns doch mal gucken was empfehlen die hier denn
was das muss ich mir mal wie bookmarken habe ich schon was empfehlen die denn
paperless gpt recommends
ok hier ein example docker kompost jammertus peter las gpt
langsame verlassen die linie das jetzt schon mal nicht
wir wollen ja nur lama das thema
olama host okay
das braucht ja 3000 settings
advanced
Da starten wir einfach einen eigenen Docker-Container.
Paypal as Base URL, Paypal as API Token braucht man dann.
Ja, das können wir uns dann hiervon gleich mal klauen.
nur dass wir dann paperless engine x außerhalb laufen haben nicht nx unable to detect and wieder
amd gpu ja das ist klar kann man jetzt power off hier drinnen machen und geht auch wirklich aus ja
wunderbar wunderbar so und jetzt muss man gucken dass wir die gpu pass pass truhen können resources
So, wo liegt dieses Ding jetzt nochmal?
Dev, DRI.
Render.
Das da, oder?
Das muss man passtruhen.
Oder muss man...
Kann man auch einfach komplett Dev, DRI passtruhen?
Schauen wir mal.
Add device path through
FDRI
Okay.
Okay, das ist von Snet.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Was haben wir denn sonst hier?
By path.
Okay, beides, hä?
reichen wir da mal beides durch.
Kart 1
und
wie heißt das Ding?
Render.
Und das machen wir jetzt auch noch
da durch. Okay.
Start.
fdi ok da sind wir ab install nv top das müsste jetzt ja funktionieren nv top
ja das ist schon mal dumm wenn das nicht funzt
Wenn ich das nicht in den Container weitergeleitet krieg, dann muss ich da gar nicht großartig mit KI anfangen.
Stimmt vielleicht die Berechtigung nicht? Darf ich da nicht drauf zugreifen?
Ich darf drauf zugreifen
Ey, er ist nicht ein normaler Pfeil
Ich weiß nicht
Aber ich darf drauf zugreifen
Darf ich da auch was reinschreiben? Mal gucken, was passiert
Null
Okay
Aber ich darf drauf zugreifen, also das stimmt schon
Guck mal, ich meine, ich habe ja auch hier
für alle und so aber müsste ich darauf reiten können ich ganz ehrlich habe kein
blassen schimmer was passiert wenn ich in 1 in meine grafikkarte schreibe geht
hier auf dem horst auch nicht also das müsste eigentlich funktionieren
nv top in zeit lxc container gpu pass zu lxc container der ist noch die
zeitgeist band der ist zum geld von jenny film
erfahrer
ok ich sehe schon dass es alles deutlich komplizierter als wir das vorgestellt
Oh, da muss ja total viel.
Moment, gibt es noch sowas wie
Dev AMD oder so?
Ne, ne. Okay.
LXC Paththrough
AMD GPU.
Help with AMD Paththrough.
Da muss ich doch nichts blacklisten.
Das ist doch Blödsinn.
Das ist doch Schwachsinn.
Ich will ja die Sachen vom Host mit benutzen.
Und Container ist ja keine VM.
Container ist ein bisschen Sandbox.
Drumherum ein ganz normaler Prozess, wie alles andere auch.
LXC.
GPU Pass Through.
da gibt es doch bestimmt irgend jemalige
bücher in lxc container ok wie von
ssgp webinterface hinzufügen karte
dvi und dev nvidia ok haben wir ja
gemacht
die anpropagand haben wir nicht haben
wir nicht in privilege container access
666 haben wir im moment access mod 666 haben wir nicht oder
im moment das sieht jetzt noch mal ganz anders aus
Sekunde mal, das ist verkehrt.
Das ist 6 6 0.
Vielleicht liegt es daran.
Okay, wir probieren das nochmal auf Power Off.
Was ist denn die erste 0?
Das ist irgendwie Sticky Bit und so gedöhnt, ne?
Aber das brauchen wir nicht.
Ich reiche das ja auch mal durch
Start
Epo gerät identifiziert das ist nvidia braun man nicht container konfigurieren
das ist für nvidia gedürzt juckt mich nicht
geräte überprüfen die geräte anzeigen def kfd what the fuck was ist das das brauche ich noch oder wie
rock im support ist wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt wir reichen das auch noch mal durch
Wem gehört denn das hier gerade?
Dev, DRI
DRI
Gehört
Video und Render
Naja
Nachdem es ja meinem User gehört
Müsste es ja eigentlich passen
NV Top
Ups, falsche Kiste
Das fuckt mich jetzt schon ein bisschen ab, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Upt install rockemsmi.
Das sollte es ja dann zumindest erkennen, die Karte.
Der erkennt die Karte auch, oder?
Chat.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Vorraum 15%.
Der erkennt die, oder?
Machen wir hier off.
Und jetzt machen wir das andere noch durchreichen.
Was wir da noch durchreichen sollen.
Def K, Dings.
Äh, 666.
Was?
Wie?
Gibt's nicht.
Achso, weil da ein Leerzeichen hinten dran ist.
Okay.
Aber warum NV-Top nicht funktioniert, weiß ich nicht.
Naja, gut.
Okay, NV-Top mag nicht, aber das funktioniert hier.
Dann ist es okay.
Also, dann probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Äh, Ulama?
Ne, Moment mal, Moment mal.
Ähm.
olama wie konnte man das noch mal überprüfen ob der die gpu gefunden hat
olama ps oder irgendwie sowas ich habe eine amd karte ja aber das macht nichts
nv top kann auch amd karten
Na gut, schauen wir mal.
Wir gucken einfach mal.
Rock'em im Container installieren, habe ich gemacht.
Verifizierung der GPU.
Rock'em SMI.
Ja, haben wir ja gemacht.
Passt ja.
Bulama für lokale VMs.
Ja, gut.
Also dann, GPT, OSS.
oder was, Moment, was empfehlen die hier
eigentlich für ein Model? Das wollte ich jetzt die ganze Zeit
schon mal gucken.
LLM Provider,
LLM Model GPT-4,
ne, das ist nicht das wirklich, was wir haben
wollen.
OCR Provider,
LLM, Default OCR,
OCR Process Mode Image,
ne,
nee,
machen wir mal,
Paypaless, GPT,
Local Model Recommendation.
Ach, da ist Techno-Tim wieder.
Erstmal zwei neue Kubernetes-Cluster
aufgebaut, um das zu starten wahrscheinlich.
Na komm, wir nehmen einfach mal
GPT-OSS, ganz ehrlich.
Da wissen wir auf jeden Fall, dass das ganz gut funktioniert.
Ist halt fett, ne? 14 Gig.
ab install t mux das war ein thema session olama lounge gpt ging das nicht so
Ach, run.
Run.
Okay, da müssen wir jetzt kurz warten.
Was braucht
nvtop denn, dass er das
im Container
findet?
Insider
LXC.
Okay,
die labern, die labern halt.
dass
im sagen
sagen
Die AI fantasiert sich da wieder irgendwelche Dinger zusammen.
GLX-Info.
Kann man das machen?
Der kann auch...
Ne, ne.
Okay, Mesa-Utils.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Alter.
Ne.
Das zerlehe ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, Radiantop wird ja auch nicht funktionieren, oder?
Probieren wir das mal.
Moment.
Newer.
Exzellent.
Leute, exzellentes Tool.
Das ist so exzellent, dass es das gar nicht gibt.
Radion Top.
Ach, guck mal da.
Das checkt das.
NV Top checkt's nicht.
Hä?
Chat, ich hab nix gemacht.
Warum geht das jetzt auf einmal?
Wie gut gemacht.
Was ist NVI-Top?
Wow.
Äh, nein.
Das installiere ich nicht.
Aber eben ging es doch auch noch nicht.
Guck mal hier.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen geht es jetzt.
Das ist schon mal nett.
Na gut.
So, Chat-GPT fast runtergeladen.
Ganz ehrlich, 14 Gig.
Na gut, Moment mal, Moment mal.
Chat, wisst ihr, ob man Ulama irgendwie bei Bedarf das Model nur laden lassen kann?
Dass es nicht die ganze Zeit 14 Gig blockiert?
auf der anderen seite 14 gigs sind echt ordentlich ja
es anlaut automatisch nach fünf minuten okay aber vielleicht ist das doch ein bisschen fett
Aber es sollte zumindest ganz gute Leistung bringen
Nehmen wir mal was kleineres
Ach was
Ich gucke jetzt erstmal
Ob ich wieder auf meine 16, 17 Tokens komme
In dem Container
Aber kann das Model wischen?
Das weiß ich gar nicht
Kann GPT-OSS wischen?
Nee, oder?
Ich glaube nicht.
Nee.
Gämmer 3.
wenn 2.5 vl 75 b in strakt die die die model namen sind immer schon geil
Akuma hier hat es geladen sende message kecke
geht relativ schnell oder
es ist es ist es ist es ist es big brain time
Also eine wirkliche Auslastung von der GPU sehe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Hatten wir das nicht das letzte Mal auch, Chat?
Das ist das Erste.
Wir mussten doch in den System D Service noch was reinschreiben, damit das überhaupt ging.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Irgendwas mussten wir in System D reinschreiben.
Alter, wie lang denkst du bei Keckel nach, ChatGPT, Alter?
Guck mal, das hört gar nicht mehr auf
Override
Ach, guck mal, wir haben es sogar noch
Wir haben es sogar noch drinnen stehen hier
So, Moment
Und wie
Wie ging das andere nochmal?
Minus, minus.
Ulama Show Token Seconds.
Da gab es doch eine Option.
Minus, minus verbose.
War das ein...
Verbose.
Und dann konnte man hinten dran sagen,
How are you?
Fragezeichen oder so.
Oh, er thinkt.
Der User will wissen, wie es mir geht.
Das war das letzte Mal schon schneller.
Okay, Tokens pro Sekunde.
Okay, 10 Tokens pro Sekunde nur.
Das läuft wahrscheinlich,
Olamar PS,
100% CPU.
Also, dann gehen wir jetzt mal dahin.
Override.
Environment has
Override GFX Version.
Okay, whatever das da genau will.
Wie jetzt?
Oh.
Jetzt muss ich mal nachgucken, wie das funktioniert hat.
Kann mich schon immer dran erinnern.
Oh Lama.
S. Override.
Wie ging das denn jetzt nochmal?
Das haben wir das letzte Mal schon mal gemacht.
Ich meine, ich habe doch diese Sache hier im Hinterkopf.
War das richtig?
Ach hier, guck mal, da ist es doch.
ETC System...
Get over with file manually.
Aber so geht's auch.
Environment.
Kann man in einem Service...
Wait a minute.
Oh ne, es ist Nano.
Kill all Nano.
P-Kill-Nano
Ich hab, ich, ich komm aus Nano nicht raus
Weil Steuerung X ist bei mir
Tab schließen vom Terminal
Okay, minus 9
Nein
Nano lässt sich nicht killen
Was ist denn das?
Okay, gibt's nicht noch was anderes
Anstatt minus X
Moment, das heißt...
Edit.
Ah, hier.
Kill.
Ah, gut.
Gut.
Okay.
Wie geht das? Update Defaults?
Oder irgendwie sowas unter DB.
Update Alternatives?
editor ging es so dass macht man so selten update alternatives nano editor
was reconfigure up der config editor ja das meine ich wir wollen basic okay sehr schön
jetzt kann ich das editieren environment path gleich aber mehrere environments chat
wisst ihr dass man mehrere environments einträge hier haben kann unter service
also ich so was hier sagen kann so geht das
Und jetzt sage ich hier
Override.
Moment, das muss aus irgendwelchen Gründen auskommen.
Das ist ganz weird.
Moment, jetzt hat er das angelegt.
Hä?
Ah ne, Moment.
Was?
Ich, ich check's nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ist das System D Shit, der passiert?
Edits below this comment will be discarded?
Alter, sag mal, wie kompliziert kann man das eigentlich machen?
Edits below this comment will be discarded.
Was will das überhaupt von mir?
Also, im Prinzip muss ich jetzt quasi sowas hier machen.
Oder wie?
Und das checkt er jetzt, oder wie?
Okay.
System CTL Restart
Oh Lama
Okay, run
Nö, den juckt es überhaupt nicht
Dem geht es voll am Arsch vorbei, ob die Grafikkarte an ist oder nicht
100% CPU
Warum nicht, oh Lama?
Ist doch egal, was wir benutzen
Hat er denn jetzt restartet?
restart running since 43 sekunden ja okay da hat restarted
ja
Also
Das funktioniert im Container nicht richtig
Mit der GPU Acceleration
Das haben wir das letzte Mal
Auf dem Host laufen lassen, das war richtig schnell
Genau, einfach
Leute, Leute, warum nicht einfach
ChatGPT dann seine Daten füttern
Ich hätte noch was anderes warum nicht einfach seinen kompletten computer direkt in die cloud mountain
einfach slash slash auf one drive mountain
Hast du ein demon reload gemacht damit er das override tut das ist eine gute frage habe ich nicht muss man das dafür
Kann ich jetzt irgendwie gucken mit was für options olama läuft
Oh, das ist ja nicht.
Der benutzt keine Grafikkarte.
Und das liegt bestimmt daran,
ich, das, das,
das liegt bestimmt daran,
dass die,
dass die GPU aus
irgendwelchen Gründen im LXC-Container
nicht gefunden hat.
olama lxc gpu box box ok als elf aus olama box box lxc hier ist how you
see my arm dj without needing a full pass alles klar okay dann zeige mal her
ok olama fb 0 alter wieviel moment moment moment das habe ich doch gar nicht das
gibt es bei mir gar nicht
warum frame bach war das verstehe ich halt auch gar nicht
es war nicht immer
Für mich gilt dies den folgenden Resourcen.
Wenn du beide Karten hast, kannst du weitergehen.
Ja hab ich hab ich hab ich ja.
Nächster Schuss und dann könnt ihr nach den Ressourcen gehen.
Ich habe bereits durchgeführt.
Wenn sie da sind, klickt jeder und dann vorwärts und verändert die Mode zu 666 haben wir gemacht.
Das gibt 3 Geräte-Axis.
Dann in Rostel.
Kfb666-SQL.
Das ist die Computer-Interface.
Required for Rock'em.
Ah, muss ich Rock'em vielleicht noch installieren?
Upt install Rock'em.
Upt search Rock'em.
Rock'em Info.
nächstes mal amd extension entrocken mx 11 olama wird das mussten wir doch das letzte
mal nicht machen leute das mussten wir das letzte mal nicht machen das weiß
ich genau das haben wir das letzte mal nicht gemacht
Hates amd drivers
Das macht doch keinen Sinn
Ich meine wir können das einfach mal machen
das ist ein container das hat dir geholfen docker also dass das das haben
wir ausprobiert oder ist es das
amd gpu ja gut das ist im container naja amd gpu
linux video access
wenn running in a container inszeniert ist
aber ich bin ein privilege container ich darf das sehe wo schreibt er olama die
locks hin schreibt das irgendwie olama oder so
wer aolama loks htc docker moment das ist kein docker container
native sieg rupp treiber sieg rups
Journal CTL X.
Ist das XE?
Oh, Lama.
Minus U, genau.
Kempel da.
So, hat der hier jetzt irgendwas?
fail to pass
ok wir machen jetzt mal was anderes starten das und jetzt gucken wir noch mal rein
warning use of a road visibild devices if user not correctly discovered ansatz
discovering available cpu smix hat er hier drin
er des kraft keine gps juck dir nicht aber das kann ich das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen dass das wirklich notwendig ist was der typ hier schreibt
Ich meine, wir können das mal ausprobieren, aber das mussten wir, also auf dem Host mussten wir das definitiv nicht machen.
Wir können das mal machen, aber das mussten wir auf dem Host definitiv nicht machen, das wüsste ich noch.
Ich weiß noch gar nicht mal sicher, was ich da überhaupt mache.
ich untare irgendein
Ulama-Ding.
Geil, funktioniert das schon richtig gut.
Excellent.
Not found.
Yeah, nice.
Also das
gibt es gar nicht mehr hier.
Weil das haben wir auch nicht
gemacht auf dem Host. Das weiß ich
genau.
Aber, latest AMD Drivers in einem Container, warum?
Moment, ist der Dude noch auf dem Host oder wo ist denn der jetzt gerade?
Ist der jetzt auf dem Host oder ist der auf dem Container?
Ich meine, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal drauf geschissen, ja?
Aber es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn,
GPU-Treiber im Container zu installieren.
Okay, das ist irgendeine...
Guck mal, siehste?
Ach das ist ein Ubuntu was der Typ hat!
Ich hab nen Debian!
Das ist ein Ubuntu!
Ne ne ne ne
Remove
Habs remove
Search
Am DGPU install
Okay, der macht irgendwelche ganz
wirren Dinger. Das geht auch nur
mit dem Ubuntu-Container.
Das lassen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Okay.
Upt-Remove-AMD-GPU-Install.
Wo kommt denn das jetzt her?
Ihr habt es doch
removed.
Stimmt, ich habe das nicht geperged.
Wobei, dazu muss ich es erst wieder installieren.
Ja.
Ah ja, gut.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das für komisches Zeug ist.
Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das notwendig ist.
Okay, wisst ihr was? Wir versauen uns nochmal unseren Host.
Ich will einfach das nochmal checken, dass wir sehen, dass funzt.
So, hier, Ulama.
Dann installiere ich es halt nochmal neu, wen juckt's, ja.
Äh, Moment.
Das ist das Falsche.
Work, Save, gehen wir mal hier, MKD, Temp, ok, TM meinetwegen, Ollama installieren wir
jetzt hier auf dem Haus nochmal und dann machen wir diesen Krempel mal, wir nehmen mal ein
bisschen kleineres Model, ok?
Chat, was ist ein gutes Testmodel, um zu testen, ob...
...ob GPU Acceleration funktioniert?
Lama 3 oder sowas?
Da ist noch das alte Olamadir, ich weiß.
Aber das ist das vom Container, was ich eben angelegt habe.
Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das ist nicht unser
altes vom letzten
Stream.
Okay, das ist
besser. Okay.
Wir wollen use this model.
Ne, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Normalerweise gibt es doch
da einen Knopf. Use quantizations
oder sowas.
Ach, hier können wir
das machen.
ok und wie groß ist das jetzt das war auch genauso groß wie gpt oss
olama gpu test
Da gibt es doch irgendeinen...
Hier.
AMD GPU ready.
Oh, das ist deutlich kleiner.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ich hab keinen Bock
So viel Zeug runterzuladen
Ich mein ich könnt's rüberkopieren von der VM
Aber ganz ehrlich
Erstmal gucken ob's überhaupt funktioniert
So das müssen wir wahrscheinlich wieder override machen
Gleich
Die Musik eskaliert voll
Und kommt auch noch Amazon
Ich muss da gerade mal abwarten.
Kurz mal checken, was Amazon da so macht.
Amazon noch nichts zu sehen.
Zwischen 16.15 Uhr und 19.15 Uhr.
Alter, die armen Amazon-Lieferleute.
sport ich war heute nicht vergessen rennen davor tag pause aktuell läuft es wieder
es flutscht sozusagen
ok also ran olama minus verbot minus was ist das beste twitch im fragezeichen im
ort das labert wieder okay wenn wir es ist kurze antwort
ok gut zwölf tors pro sekunde olama ps alles gpu so edit
da muss man es hinzufügen environment und er ist schon wieder abgefuckt das nano nervt
doch nicht rum mit eurem Kack-Nano,
Mann.
Jetzt komme ich
da wieder nicht raus.
Moment, das ist mein Router.
Da will ich jetzt nicht drauf.
Ich bin auf
die 51.
Rebel-Edit.
Update Alternatives.
Editor.
Wim.
Jawoll.
So.
Service.
Das braucht man glaube ich an der Stelle nicht.
Aber ich mach's trotzdem mal.
SimCTL.
Restart.
Hola.
La-O-Lama-Service.
Äh.
Aber das läuft.
Moment, das läuft doppelt?
Chat, ist da irgendwas kaputt?
Ich kill das mal.
Bin mir nicht sicher, warum das doppelt läuft.
Was macht das Ding?
Warum läuft das jetzt doppelt?
Wenn
Ulama es meint, dann...
Chat, warum kriege ich hier keine Logs von Ulama?
Prozess, CPU und einer GPU.
Das ist sogar, das könnte sogar durchaus sein.
Jetzt geht es nicht mehr, doch.
Oh, jetzt ist es schneller, gell?
Habt ihr gesehen?
nach meinung viele drei hat leute ist das beste twitch im ort gibt es zwei hacks eigentlich noch
das letzte mal wo ich was von tracks gesehen habt da hat er ein komisches dance spiel gespielt
treu hat das war ein alter watch erinnert euch noch drei hat seven oder so was dann über seinen
riesen aufschrei wieder gab racism weil tryhard 7
zwei
ok aber es ist auf jeden fall schneller also das reicht koper das hat jetzt das
hat genügt.
Ich musste, guck mal, was habe ich im Endeffekt
gemacht? Ich habe Onama
installiert und
dann
habe ich hier nur diese Sache
hinzugefügt. Das war's.
Mehr habe ich nicht gemacht.
So, rebooten wir den
Container nochmal. Vielleicht geht es ja dann aus irgendwelchen
magischen Gründen.
Mehr habe ich nicht gemacht.
Wir machen jetzt nochmal kurz hier den Vergleich.
Okay.
Ich kann auch mal Ollama PS.
100% GPU. Seht ihr?
Gucken, was der jetzt hier macht.
Aber irgendwas muss man da im Container noch durch...
Durch...
Ja, ja. 100% GPU, sagt er jetzt.
Irgendwas muss man da noch durchreichen, dass das funktioniert.
Wir suchen nochmal.
Olamar LXC GPU.
Hosting Olamar on Proxmox LXC Container with GPU Path Through.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Ja, Web UI juckt mich nicht.
And I got it working with 2 RTX.
Ja, RTX brauche ich nicht.
I had to modify the system.
D-Service used to start the web UI service.
Das ist mit Nvidia.
Wir wollen es ja mit AMD-GPU haben.
Ja, aber Docker-Daemon bringt mir doch gar nichts.
Ich habe doch gar nichts in Docker.
Der macht erstmal eine Proxmox-Install, Alter.
Übertreib es halt mal.
Ja, okay, das ist für Nvidia-Stells.
Ich glaube, das bringt uns jetzt nicht so viel.
Eine nämliche Frage, kann es sein, dass es einfach nicht das
Rock'em Package geladen hat, weil wir die GPU
Zum Installen nicht gepathed haben
Vielleicht
Vielleicht, okay, das ist auf jeden Fall
100% CPU
Okay, also meint sie, wir sollen nochmal
Ein Install machen
Vielleicht bringt das ja was
Ein V-Top von
Auch wieder
Ist das die gleiche GPU
dieses letzte mal benutzt hat ja der gleiche server und eben hat sie auf dem
host funktioniert ja witzigerweise aber im container von es ist nicht was
ziemlich ziemlich doof ist das ist immer richtig krasse side quest die wir heute
wieder erledigen müssen dass es funktioniert
Ah, Chad, ihr habt recht.
Community-Ge.
Ihr habt recht, guckt mal.
Weil er die GPU nicht erkannt hat,
hat er diesen ganzen Rock'em-Campel nicht installiert.
Ihr habt recht.
AMD-GPU, ready.
Hogu.
Ja, mal gucken, ob es jetzt auch funktioniert.
Ah, es ist schon deutlich schneller.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, funktioniert.
Easy.
Ja, das hätten wir mal wissen müssen.
Okay, also, das heißt, wir haben jetzt einen Olamal laufen.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ähm, Chat, Chat, was war es nochmal?
Was für ein Model für Vision?
Netznet.
Uptinstall.
Ich bin... Leute, ich weiß, dass man...
dass Netznet outdated ist, ja?
Aber ich bin...
Ich bin...
Äh, IP-Utils?
Ach, wie hieß der Kram?
Install Netznet Debian.
Na, Net... Net Tools!
Net Tools war's.
Ich war...
Ich mein, ich hab fast alles durchprobiert in der Richtung, ja?
netz der netz der enjoy ja also hier ss ist das neue ich finde es in deutschland schwierig das
zu benutzen wenn man das im stream zu oft sagt müsste gleich nazistream gefleckt deswegen
bleibe ich mal bei netz der olama läuft auf port 330 39 olama und gemma 312 b hat auch
wischen.
Taugt das?
Hey, Palos.
Pass auf.
Jetzt kommen die Leute und Rage-baiten
andere auf Twitter gleich noch.
Ah, das ist gut.
Das ist gut, Andreas, dass du das schreibst.
ist gut dass du das schreibst edit
das ist das wird das ist gut sonst hätte ich wirklich gar nicht dran gedacht
restart system ctl restart olama status
4 Seconds.
Run.
Lass mal nochmal checken, ob das jetzt auch alles funktioniert.
Ja, aber gut.
Das ist gut zu wissen.
Laut den Twitch-Mode-Macher...
Das ist ein Kackmodel, Alter.
PogChamp.
Das ist das am meisten beliebteste Emote auf dem Kanal.
Okay, dieses Model hat absolut keinen blassen Schimmer von dem, was es überhaupt von sich gibt.
Haben die anderen auch nicht.
für bilderkennung und ocr ja ich brauche ja nur bilder bilderkennung und ocr wir probieren einfach
mal ein paar models durch jetzt also irgendjemand hat gemeint glm 4.7 ist rock hat es auch vision
dabei woran wo sieht man das ob das vision dabei hat die text generation hat das nur
ne hat das wissen wo sieht man dass ich nur wenn ich ab und zu kein bisschen okay dann nicht
search vision
G-L-M
O-C-R
Popular
Ministral 3
Okay, das hat 2...
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Probieren wir mal, wie viel
Tokens das
generiert hat.
Ich meine...
15 Gig hat es auch.
Boah, ey.
Jetzt sehe ich was kleineres
Das ist kleiner hier, ne?
Wie viel GPU-RAM hast du?
Ich habe eigentlich genug
Also, man, GPU-RAM kannst du vergessen
Das ist eine iGPU
Mit RAM
Sag mal so, 16 GB RAM könnte ich
Denen schon einräumen
Ab und zu mal, ja?
Fürs Indexieren von den Dokumenten und sowas
Aber mir persönlich wäre es lieber, wenn das irgendwas um die 8 Gig oder so wäre.
Chat, Chat, ich habe ein Problem.
Ich bin doof.
Falsches Verzeichnis.
Wohin?
Äh, Route ist fast voll.
Wohin downloadet denn überhaupt
Ulama die Models?
Opt Ulama oder so?
Ja, da war es doch.
Ja.
User Share, User Local Bin, Lib,
Olamer, da vielleicht.
Wohin downloade das?
Aha.
Oder auch nicht.
Homefolder?
Auch wenn es als System D
ist.
Ach, Momente mal.
Olamer Run
lädt die Dinger dann runter.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Siehst du?
Ich habe hier dann Service laufen.
das ist das ist eine gute idee ja das ist eine gute idee einfach wo am meisten
verbraucht ist ncd ist pock
Ups, oh, wenn ich mich vertippt habe.
User.
User, share, olama.
Äh, Leute, das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd.
Ah.
Ähm, das ist in der Tat etwas doof.
Deswegen linken wir das jetzt einfach mal um, würde ich sagen.
Ich hoffe, das stört sich nicht, wenn ich ihn einfach jetzt unter dem Arsch mal weglösche.
Und das stört ihn bestimmt, wenn ich sie unter dem Arsch weglösche, oder?
wobei das stört den glaube ich nicht models ls ls work wird gelingt auf models so und jetzt
sollte das eigentlich...
Oh Lama, run.
Durchaus.
Ups.
Jetzt ist es kaputt.
Warum machen die mir das Leben immer so schwer?
Was soll das?
Was will er jetzt von mir?
Hat er jetzt
keine Rechte da reinzuschreiben oder was?
Journalctl
minus u olama
Hä?
Was?
MKDier, permission denied.
Fuck.
Läuft der als User olama, oder was?
Och nee.
Hä?
Geht net.
Zudo minus u
olama
bin
Bash.
Wird ja immer schlimmer.
Tatsache.
MKDeer
Models
0w. Jetzt hat er keine Berechtigung
drauf.
Das macht mir echt das Leben schwer hier.
Ja, das bringt mir
jetzt nicht so wirklich was.
Kann ich das hier?
Warte mal.
CHO und Hut.
Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Oder doch?
Der Link ist eigentlich immer 777.
Das kann es nicht sein.
User, Share,
Olamar.
Das ist normal.
Die Dinger sind immer
777.
Okay, das darf ich nicht.
Das liegt bestimmt am drunterliegenden
Liegenden
Drunterliegenden hier work
save olama
Hier daran liegt das bestimmt
Es gehört aus irgendwelchen gründen konnte ab jetzt okay, was sie am ort 777
Oh, bam
Restart
Touch, 1
Aha, jetzt geht's
Einfach immer mal 777 überall drauf und gut ist
Bam, Pfunst
Die beste Variante ist das sicherlich nicht
Okay
Also, dann wollen wir mal
okay welches model hat er wie zuletzt jemand empfohlen hier quen b
most powerful vision vision language modeling fan model family to date
3.5 haben wir auch schon.
Guck mal da.
Wasser.
was sagen die
Das hatten wir hier gerade.
Das hier.
Gibt es irgendeins...
Gibt es irgendeins,
dass ich für den Inhalt verwenden kann
und für OCR gleichzeitig?
An der Technikkeller.
Seine Physi... Ja, hat er.
Hat er bestanden.
Soweit ich weiß.
Good model for OCR.
And
and general keine ahnung
ein kleines schade dass das gpt oss keins hat kommen wir können das hier
durchaus mal probieren.
Also geht es...
Wenn...
Quen 3.
Ja, das haben wir ja. Moment mal.
Warum gibt es Quen 3 und
Quen 3 VL? Ist Quen 3
VL nur quasi
der Teil von Quen 3,
was für Vision ist? Oder
wie ist das?
Ja, ja, aber ich will ja ein Model haben, falls es es gibt, was Wischen und normalen Kram zusammen machen kann.
Vielleicht geht das ja, da ich nicht zwei Sachen laufen lassen muss.
Dann nehmen wir 3 VL. Okay, das mache ich gerade.
Ja, mal gucken.
Ich muss da eh mal ein bisschen rumprobieren.
Ich muss da mal eh ein bisschen rumprobieren, ja.
Guck mal, die Temperatur von dem Zeug ist aber echt okay.
30 Grad.
Juckt ja keinen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Du willst wahrscheinlich neben OCR auch direkt Werte extrahieren oder nicht?
Na, ich würde da schon gerne, dass der meine Dokumente auch richtig taggen kann.
So Amazon und Rechnung und sowas.
Da müssen wir mal gucken.
Ja, ich will halt nicht gar so viel RAM raushauen.
Ich meine, ich habe 32 GB RAM da drin.
Aber da soll halt schon ein bisschen was frei bleiben für 4Ms und sowas.
Ich meine, ja, die unloaden die Models auch wieder, aber das ist trotzdem, das wird dann auf einen Schlag benutzt.
So ein...
Oh, ein Claw benutze ich nicht.
please kurze antwort auf warte mal habe ich nicht gesehen auch was denn 97
was für eine antwort auf was der zweifel gab keine ahnung ich kenne ihn nicht
persönlich also der hört ja gar nicht mehr auf zu denken hier guck mal hier
Der thingt sich ja kaputt.
Ach so.
Ja, please, kurze Antwort.
Der hat ja noch nicht geantwortet.
Der thingt ja gerade noch.
Du hast recht, wenn die OCR-Modelle nur 2 GB groß sind, dann macht es Sinn, eins für OCR und eins für andere zu benutzen.
Was hast du für ein gutes Model für OCR-only?
Okay, das werden wir jetzt einfach mal kurz benutzen, dafür, dass wir mal mit Paperless weiterkommen.
Also Paperless.
Wo haben wir es denn hier?
Ja, Paperless.
Also, Paperless,
Paperless, GPT.
Dann brauchen wir dieses
Compose-File von dem Dude
hier.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Okay.
Compose-File von dem Dude
haben wir hier.
beste name kompost jammel weiß sofort nach zwei wochen nicht mehr was es ist also das
da brauchen wir nicht paperless haben wir schon mal laufen paperless gpt image paperless latest
environment paperless url ist 12 168 121 your paperless api token my profile
das ist glaube ich dass ihr braun oder
paperless public url league leute
pp das bgpt auto tag pampers gpt auf ups gpt auto lm provider open ai olama local
Ach guck mal, der hat sogar das
Moment, ich hab nicht Quen 3 8 B
Sondern ich hab
Quen 3
Quen 3 V L
8 B
Olamahouse
Ist bei mir
Die Kiste hier
Also im Endeffekt das da.
Und der Port.
Okay.
Ulama Context Length.
Ich lasse mal das Standard Ding.
Token Limit.
Brauchen wir das?
Kann man das weglassen?
Okay, das brauchen wir nicht
LLM Language
Ja man
Gucken, ob es das checkt
Würde es drin lassen
Du meinst das hier
Aber Token Limit heißt doch nur, dass es
Das kann doch gar keine lange
Geht das nur fürs Denken?
Oder für insgesamt?
OCR, Configure LLM
Vision LLM, Ulama
Ulama Vision Model, ja im Prinzip das gleiche
Nochmal
ulama host
OCR processing mode image
pdf skip exist
Weg damit
Enhanced OCR features
Nee, das ist ein Limit für die Token.
Ein Token ist quasi so ein...
Können wir vereinfacht sagen,
ein Wort der Antwort von einem LLM ist ein Token.
Auch wenn das nicht direkt stimmt.
Aber das kann man sich so vorstellen.
Also quasi Token sind Wörter in der Antwortgröße.
Anscheinend limitiert er das.
Save Hogger-Files, was auch immer.
Create local PDFs, false.
Local PDF upload.
Was sind denn Enhanced PDFs?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das lassen wir jetzt mal einfach weg.
auto cr tech ocr limit pages blog level info volumes prompt for document was
alles falls hier kann man weg machen 80 80 die pens on kann man weg machen
ok prompt muss ich mir jetzt dann kommt ausdenken so du bist ein dokumentenmanagement oder oc oder
doch immer was ist haben die da haben wir hier in sinnvollen beispiel prompt
vielleicht schon mal und default prompt
date prompt ocr prompt
er wird
dann wird er die wahrscheinlich auch so benutzen ohne dass ich da
ok dann wollen wir mal locker kompost kompost wie war das jetzt einfach ab oder was already
die feind aber tatsächlich schon mal die feind
und jetzt gehe ich jetzt einfach hier auf 80 80 und bin dann da ja no
No documents found with filter tag.
Ad-Hoc-Analyse?
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Analyse.
History. OCR.
Vielleicht sollte ich mir mal kurz die Hilfe durchlesen.
Du musst den Dokument in Paperless in Tech geben.
Wir gucken erstmal. Wir lesen es mal kurz durch, so im Großen und Ganzen.
Ah.
Okay, so richtig schlau bin ich jetzt daraus nicht geworden.
Settings.
Ja, aber was ist denn, wenn ich neue Dokumente scannen lassen will hiervon?
Muss ich dann einfach immer sicherstellen, dass beim Upload Paperless GPT drankommt?
Kann ich, okay, kann ich das auch nachträglich machen?
Also kann man da jetzt irgendwie auch sagen, hier, äh, boah, wo ist der, wo...
Moment, wo sind meine Dokumente jetzt?
Wo sind da meine Dokumente?
Ach, da oben.
Man sollte vielleicht auch mal hochscrollen.
Kann man jetzt auch einfach nachträglich sagen?
Tag.
Checkt der das jetzt?
Ah, guck mal da!
Ah!
Document to process.
Generate title. Generate text.
Generate correspondence.
Generate document type. Generate...
Und jetzt?
Macht der Knopf jetzt was?
Ne.
processing als kann man mal gucken ob
guck mal da macht jetzt was der macht
was die gpu wird benutzt
der ist jetzt am prozessen
dann schauen wir dann warten wir mal bis der fertig prozessen hat
wo wir gerade dabei sind lasst uns doch mal gucken
wenn so ein bisschen bisschen laster drauf ist
was also cpu temperaturmäßig okay 50
Das ist ja nix im Endeffekt.
Ja, man hört's jetzt ein bisschen.
Man hört's jetzt ein bisschen rauschen, so.
Aber es hält sich doch wirklich in Grenzen.
Also Hardware-mäßig muss man echt sagen, ist das Ding gut ausgestattet.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was das macht.
Also, das
gener... Okay. Titel,
Tags,
Kontakte da draus,
Document Times, Generate Create Date.
Ist der so
schlau und checkt, dass ich
schon ein Tag Rechnung hab.
Oder generiert der
selbst was.
Vielleicht kann man ihm auch sagen, nur schon bestehende
Tags.
Das sind die
Default Prompt.
Der ist immer noch am
LLM'en.
Ja, das UI-Design ist ja
wirklich grausam.
Der LLMt immer noch mit 99% GPU.
Gab es da nicht einen Log zu?
Also hier ist das Paperless-Log.
Das macht jetzt nicht so viel.
Wie viele Seiten weiß ich nicht.
Wir können mal...
Achso, eine. Eine Seite.
Ich dachte, du meinst, wie viele Toggs pro Sekunde.
Wir können mal...
Das hier ist das Log von Paperless-GPU.
zählt sich in grenzen was da drin steht
ich glaube wir müssen sagen wir müssen damit fertig ist
wir müssen nicht zugucken bei bei der gelegenheit können wir uns einfach mal
das andere angucken. Paperless
AI. Was da?
Was ist das jetzt?
Paperless AI?
GPT Difference.
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied dazwischen?
Okay, das von AI zu summarisen
lassen ist vielleicht nicht so schlau.
Rats?
Keck.
Ah, okay.
Mini-PCM, das
empfehlen die.
Moment, warte mal.
Okay, die sind nicht so groß.
okay das benutzen die für ocr das heißt ich brauche normales model und das hier für ocr
mit welcher kartengruppe von nvidia ist eine amd vergleichbar ehrlich gesagt wahrscheinlich
mit ziemlich ziemlich schlechten ich weiß es gar nicht genau ich weiß dass es eine radion
780 m versus 30 50 gucken wir mal keine ahnung was das vergleichbar ist
sogar so eine publik 30 50 ist einfach 100 bis 180 prozent noch mehr das ist
nicht das ist jetzt nicht sonderlich geil
haben wir mal einen vergleich speed ranking guck mal was sonst noch so alles
ungefähr auf dem show gpu ranks ok also was jetzt weil ich mich verarschen
Ich will wissen, was da sonst noch so drum...
Was ist das für eine abartige Seide, Mann?
Ich will einfach nur sehen, was noch so drumherum ist.
Seht ihr da irgendwas, wo man sich das angucken kann?
Okay, gucken wir mal, was da so in der Nähe ist von der Grafikkarte.
Da gibt es einfach nichts zu.
Da müssen wir mal kurz hier gucken, Mensch.
Ist da in der Nähe von einer 2050 vielleicht?
Okay.
Also, ungefähr auf der Höhe von der Mobile 2050, okay?
Machen wir doch mal.
Was schafften die hier im 3D-Mark?
So.
Okay, 3837.
Das ist die Hälfte.
Guck mal, das ist weniger als die Hälfte von einem Budget Gaming PC.
Die ist jetzt nicht so geil von der Performance, ja
Also, versus, guck mal hier
Das ist eine 40-90
Die hat knapp 10.000, oder die hat 9.200 Punkte
Und die andere hat 510
Also, die hält sich arg in Grenzen, was die Performance angeht, ja
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, für lokale LLM...
Ey, das ist ja immer noch nicht fertig, Mann.
Für lokale LLM reicht's.
Braucht man nicht eine AKI-Badge?
Ja, theoretisch schon.
Aber sag mal, was macht denn das Ding da eigentlich gerade?
Sollte ich vielleicht nicht besser ein Non-Thinking-Model oder sowas verwenden?
weil das thingt sich ja glaube ich echt voll kaputt.
Wie viele Dokumente?
Eins.
Mit einer Seite.
Ein Dokument mit einer Seite.
Nutzt doch mal die Default Models.
es gibt kein default model für es gibt kein default model für für tech generation und sowas
guck nur wischen ach nee doch ihr queren 85 ok
ja machen wir
ich breche mal ab leute kompost jammel machen wir das mal also wir wissen also
wir haben das hier aber hier mit 1000 hat er standardmäßig hier drin stehen
hier hat er drin stehen quen 8 b und hier hat er drin stehen
mini cpm vdx machen wir das doch mal
kann jetzt das selbst automatisch selbst runterladen diese models
wenn es noch nicht da ist
By the way, Journal,
CTF, hat das sowas wie F?
Ah, yes, excellent.
80, 80.
Also hier.
Generate suggestions.
Äh, 404?
Warum?
Was hat der für Schmerzen? Warum 404 auf einmal?
Wie jetzt? Was ist denn mit Olamas schon wieder los?
Ich hätte das eigentlich erwartet.
Der sagt mir was, wenn er ein neues Model runterlädt.
Run.
Was hat er mir jetzt hier für Models?
Das da?
5,2 Gig.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Da stand noch sowas wie Status LRM is loading.
Downloading.
Ne, man kriegt schon Statusmeldung.
Aber erst seitdem ich das jetzt angeschmissen habe.
Leute, ich muss mal ein Toastbrot nehmen bei Essen.
Ich bin hier schon 5 Stunden 20 Minuten am streamen, Alter.
WTF?
lange mache ich nicht mehr so jetzt hat das model runtergeladen
das model der best mod ist ja ganz genau ganz genau
ziemlich ziemlich dummes model oder weißt du nicht dass kek w das beste im modus
der denkt in englisch oder antworten auf deutsch das graue hier ist der denkprozess
Moment, was habe ich hier eingetragen?
Äh.
Wartet mal kurz, was habe ich hier eingetragen?
Mini-CPMV.
Hm.
Okay, das ist das.
mini cpm v
4,4 gig
mit einem handgeschriebenen zettel ich kann dir sagen mit
meiner handschrift erkennt das ocr wahrscheinlich gar nichts
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Download hopp hopp.
Wobei es eigentlich gut ist, wenn er downloadet, kein Schwein-Toast-Brot-Potat.
Was? Nochmal was?
Moment, warum lädt der zwei Sachen runter?
Gibt's da zwei?
Zwei Versionen von dem Model?
Ne.
Hä? Was ist das?
er nämlich ein bisschen docker images
sind das update vielleicht erste version zweite version dritte version
reflex dankeschön für den sab acht monate poktanschen messer subscriptions
Also, das beste Twitch-Emote
hängt von den jeweiligen Bedürfnissen
und vor allem ein beliebter Emoji ist
Pogchance.
Ein kleines Emoji mit dem Text
Pogchamp. Okay, das Model hat absolut keine Ahnung,
wovon es redet, aber
es ist ja auch für Wischen.
Das muss auch gar nicht wissen, worüber es redet.
Docker Compose Up.
Compuse.
So, jetzt aber.
Jetzt können wir das ausprobieren.
Hier.
Sag.
Generate.
Suggestions.
Okay, das sieht jetzt tatsächlich so aus.
Jetzt macht das was.
Ah, guck mal.
Es schafft.
So, das dauert jetzt wahrscheinlich 5 Stunden,
bis das fertig ist.
ich fände es gut wenn ich nachgucken könnte was er gerade so macht aber das
lassen wir einfach mal laufen wir installieren uns jetzt wie viel vram
null die lebt von meinem arbeitsspeicher
Was?
Äh.
Hallo?
How to?
How to starten?
Please?
Installation.
Docker pull.
Peppeless AI.
Okay.
Oh, Amazon ist da, Leute. Ich muss runterflitzen.
Wartet mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, da bin ich wieder.
Mal eine Frage, wenn die GPU so langsam ist, könnte dann die CPU eventuell noch schneller sein.
Naja, also mit der CPU alleine haben wir so ungefähr 10 Tokens pro Sekunde.
Und mit der GPU haben wir so 18, 19 Tokens pro Sekunde.
So, jetzt machen wir hier Live-ASMR-Unboxing, Leute.
Amazon ist am Start.
Wo ist denn hier das Ding zum Aufmachen?
Hier.
Oder auch nicht.
Amazon.
So
Kiste aufmachen
Und was ist drinnen in der Kiste
Es ist eine
Elgato 4K Pro
Pro Capture and Beyond
Capture Pro
Ohje das ist
Französisch
Das habe ich mir gekauft
Dass ich mein Mini PC
und andere Sachen
möglichst latencyfrei
capturen kann.
Das ist Nummer 4.
Genau.
Reicht ja noch nicht.
Guck mal.
Der ist fertig, Leute.
Der ist fertig.
Äh.
Ähm
Und jetzt?
Und woher weiß ich jetzt, dass der fertig ist und was er gemacht hat?
Ich sehe da jetzt nichts
Ich sehe absolut keinen Unterschied zu vorher
Hä?
Hat das jetzt überhaupt was gemacht?
Hat das jetzt
Okay, man hat keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt was gemacht hat oder nicht.
Suggested Titel for Document 1.
Rechnung Max Mustermann.
Doch, doch.
Der hat das gecheckt, ja.
Der hat das kapiert.
Aber.
Aber wo steht das denn jetzt?
Hier ist überhaupt nichts passiert.
Was hat das denn jetzt gemacht?
Metadata?
Also das UI gefällt mir nicht.
Ich habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer, was es jetzt überhaupt gemacht hat.
Das war doch vorher auch schon OCR'd.
das ist nicht neu
ok ich habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer was das jetzt gemacht hat
also das könnte man ein bisschen klarer
ein bisschen klarer hätte man das schon machen können hier
Was hat es denn hier?
Tag Suggestions?
Nichts.
Tags for Document.
Steuer.
Moment, das Suggested Tags for Document.
Correspondent.
Okay, hat es das angepasst?
Nö.
ich weiß ja nicht was dazu kommen sollte aber irgendwas halt einen neuen tag oder
correspondence oder so ach dann kommt ein fenster vielleicht habe ich aber das ist ja
wirklich auch ui design aus der hölle warum gibt es da nicht irgendwie job history wurde
draufklicken kannst also das ist das ist das ist ja wirklich nichts das ja nix
probieren wir das mal aus was das kann
docker oder wo stand das jetzt wie man das installiert hier irgendwo ja genau
install locker pull nettes braume doch nicht das macht er doch automatisch
locker kompost ist noch da ja gut
aber bringt ja nix
dann starten wir mal das da
welches welcher port 3000
pepo fat docker image
Ich weiß nicht genau, was der machen sollte.
Habt ihr es ja noch nie benutzt.
Kann man das nicht automatisch machen?
Ich will doch nicht jedes Mal bei jedem Dokument
landest durchklicken.
Geht automatisch? Okay.
Den Link habe ich nicht mehr.
Aber du kannst einfach bei Google
irgendwie so eine Beispielrechnung oder so.
Da steht es oben.
auf docker mama hin
Ne, der hat auch keine Korrespondenten eingetragen und sowas
So, ich muss noch kurz meine Pillen nehmen.
Mist.
Mir ist eine runtergefallen.
Das ist schlecht.
Wartet mal.
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha
Weg!
Ach ne!
Hier ist es!
Der ist doch in dem Pillkontainer drin!
drin doch okay gar nichts runtergefallen so jetzt haben wir hier paperless ei laufen auf
3000 also als nächstes paperless port 3000 gucken was das ding jetzt so macht okay das
interface gefällt mir schon mal deutlich besser als das andere
bis kalt und morgens überhält sie konfiguriert intelligenten start user
account for paperless user will be used to access and management process next
Apple ist
okay das lassen wir es einfach mal gut sein
user setup max 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
next connection string
ja das ist der connection string paperless api token
dass er das ende nicht so sehr an oder ex provider lama local wir haben diese url für
olama model model für was model für was für text oder also also quasi dass da dann
trocken limit okay response talk must
use existing correspondence and text moment now scan intervall process only
pre tag documents now at a i process text to documents yes new specific text in prompt
disable automatic enable disable a tag assignment
tag assignment correspondent detection titel generation document type classification
example personal ist documentarier task ist ein restokument
ok
wir lassen einfach mal jetzt hier so machen safe es continue
Pass auf, das kackt jetzt gleich ab, direkt beim
Saven, ich sag's euch.
Guck mal, ich seh's schon, ich seh's schon, dass du's nicht richtig
saved.
Ich seh's schon, Alter.
Es ist auch wieder...
Hä?
Oh, oh!
Ich hab nix gesagt.
aber was ist heraus spuckt hier
macht das schon was auch immer der er hat schon
draußen doch immer eine rechnungsvorlage
Oh, das werde ich processed.
Hä?
Ich check's wieder nicht.
Processed? Unprocessed one.
Hä?
Today processed 0
Ja aber warum
Er hat doch eben angeblich processed
Waren wir das hier mal weg
Alter
anerfen.
Scannen auch.
Okay, jetzt macht
er irgendwas.
Oder auch nicht.
Was sagt denn der Output?
Okay.
Das ist ja alles
nicht sonderlich stable, ja?
Und du weißt überhaupt nicht, was Sache ist.
Das Model ist nicht zu groß.
Ne, ne.
Die sind beide irgendwie 5 Gig oder so.
Und hier sieht man auch nichts.
GPU-Hang.
Was?
Max, isolierst du das Ding dann vom Internet?
Hä? Ich hänge das erst gar nicht ans Internet. Warum sollte ich das ans Internet hängen?
Okay, restarten wir mal.
MCTL restart.
Oh, Lama.
Gehen wir nochmal, scan.
Llama Runner started.
Generate, okay, jetzt macht er was.
Listening, Leute.
Listening.
Alter, ja, was hast du denn jetzt für Schmerzen?
hatte hat er das jetzt gescannt texte iphone finanzengeschäft jetzt hat das kapiert oder
er zwar das kapiert es könnte ja deine daten wie soll er mal model meine daten
abladen die haben überhaupt kein tool access oder sonstwas
okay ich glaube jetzt hat es funktioniert rechnung prozess finanzen
geschäfte kundenrechnung correspondent muster firma
Aha, hier kann man es aufmachen.
Aber das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Oh, jetzt kommt mal, man kann auch chatten damit.
Ähm, wie hoch ist die, die, ist die Rechnung?
Macht es jetzt was? Denkt es?
Es denkt, Leute, es denkt.
Es macht Pfeifert, Pfeifert-Time.
Naja, also den Chat werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht benutzen.
Der ist ganz schön lahm.
Okay, jetzt ist er fertig.
Die Rechnung beträgt 1,190.
0 diese umfasst den netto betrag von 1000 bezüglich 19 und höhe von ok ok
erstmal überprüfen ob das stimmt okay das ist richtig
von ihr pfeiffer model
ok 21 fragen hat trägt trägt bei wem kann ich mich für rückfragen melden zu
der rechnung also rückfragen müssen ja eigentlich eindeutig an den max mustermann gehen
meine max mustermann schickt an sich selbst post eigentlich müsste damit freundlichen grüßen
fragen wir ob es heute regnet ach guck mal jetzt ist er schneller jetzt ist auch schneller gewesen
hier für rückfahren zu rechnen können sie sich an herr max mustermann melden
die kontakt dann finden sie im dokument info
Ja gut, das ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Rechnet es heute.
Oh, jetzt haben wir es geprickt, glaube ich.
Das war zu viel, Leute.
Oh, doch.
Das Dokument Rechnungen hat keine Information zum Wetter.
eigentlich kann keiner echt sein wetterbericht erstellen hat diese gut
ok gut funktioniert schon mal ganz gut oder leider kann das ding kein
verbessertes ocr das heißt man braucht beides man braucht gpt chat paper das
gpt für besseres ocr
Und...
Ja.
Das andere brauchen wir...
Guck mal, jetzt hat das hier...
Was? Private?
Hä?
Private?
Was will er?
Der hat Finanzen, Geschäfte, Kunden, Rechnungen hinzugefügt angeblich.
Und jetzt ist es private.
Hä?
Was soll mir das Set sagen?
Aber hier sind die Dinger.
Guck mal.
Hier sind ja die Tags.
Keine Berechtigung auf den Tag?
Es gibt doch nur einen User.
Das bin ja ich.
Jetzt hat er es gecheckt.
Okay, was auch immer, Leute.
Was auch immer.
Dokument gehört der AI, ist nicht mehr meins.
Genau.
So, also.
Das ist ja eigentlich schon mal von den Tags her gar nicht so verkehrt.
Finanzen, Geschäft, Kunde, Rechnung.
So, jetzt probieren wir das Ganze nochmal.
Mit der Amazon Rechnung.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ähm, warte mal.
Settings, wo war denn der Prompt hier nochmal?
heitel konzerns text thematik text
correspondent müsste eigentlich an amazon dabei kommen
Ok, lassen wir hier einfach mal das Standardding.
Ok, Documents.
Ich finde immer noch die Komponente.
Upload Documents.
Amazon Rechnung.
Das Problem ist, dass das OCR halt versagt bei dem Dokument.
Guck.
Das OCR versagt, sobald es nicht ganz gut eingescannt ist oder ein bisschen schräg ist oder sowas.
Das könnte ein GPT, könnte das GPT-OCR wahrscheinlich deutlich besser.
Oh, es ist schon, es ist unprocessed.
Und es idelt.
Ja, dann scan. Let's go.
Gib ihm.
Processing.
Was für ein OCR-Model nutzt du?
Noch gar keins.
Ich wollte
Pepperless GPT benutzen und dann
das Standardmodel, was die da vorschlagen
bei Ulama. Was war das?
Mini-PCR
oder irgendwie sowas.
Okay, der ist fertig.
Das hat wieder nicht geklappt.
Oh Gott.
Nee, okay, okay.
Ich wollte mich gerade schon aufregen.
Er hat es gecheckt.
Okay, History.
Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, was er gemacht hat.
Also, Finanzen, Geschäft.
Ah, nee, hier Rechnung.
Bestellung.
Kopfhörer, Musik, Rechnung.
Alter, ich fände es...
Correspondent, Amazon.
Das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Ey, da brauche ich aber Paperless-GPT wieder dazu, was irgendwie nicht funktioniert hat.
Ah, guck mal, das hat sogar einen halbwegs schönen Dark-Mode.
Schon wieder Private.
Was?
Ja.
Jetzt, guck mal, jetzt hat es das gecheckt.
Bestellung, Kopfhörer, Musik, Rechnung.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht mal so verkehrt.
Warum ist da eigentlich Steuer dran?
Naja doch, Rechnung, ja doch, Steuer.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Und der Titel ist auch gar nicht so verkehrt.
ihr rechnung denn es war rechnung das sage ich gar nicht mal so übel und das
dokument ist rechnung finde ich finde ich eigentlich ganz gut so und jetzt
gehen wir noch mal hier zurück zu
also das läuft ja gar nicht mehr
äh, Compose.
Also, dann machen wir das mal so.
Ich will ja nur, dass der OCRt.
Den restlichen Krempel können wir jetzt einfach mal sein lassen.
Der soll nur OCR machen.
Also, starten wir mal.
Joker,
Compose,
Up.
Paperless.
So und jetzt muss man sagen, Paperless GPT musste man da dran taggen.
Tag, Paperless GPT, save.
Okay, so und jetzt kann ich sagen, wie mach ich hier OCR?
Das ist ein Experimental-Feature. Result may vary.
Okay.
Das kann man bestimmt auch automatisch beibringen.
Document ID. Was ist meine Document ID?
Welcome to Paper Champ.
Document ID ist... Wo sieht man die?
Drei. Würde ich mal sagen. Daran sieht man das.
Drei. Drei.
Submit OCR-Job.
Er macht Dinger.
Er macht Dinger. Er OCRt, Leute.
Komm mal hier.
Da geht die Grafikkartenauslastung hoch.
Was?
Was ist jetzt schon
GPU-Hang
Es hängt keine GPU
Laber nicht, oh Lama, Alter
Nochmal
Was hat er gerade gesagt? No file?
Das heißt ich muss alle fünf Minuten meinen Ulama neu starten lassen, dass es weiter funktioniert.
Okay, aber jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
und er hängt auch keine GPU mehr.
Hat es jetzt funktioniert?
Ah.
Ja, das ist schon mal
deutlich besser, Leute.
Das ist schon mal deutlich besser
als das,
was das andere OCR da OCRt hat.
Ja.
guck mal das ist sogar markt dauernd
das ist sogar markt dauernd wenn ich das jetzt mal rein haue wo ist studio code
wie war der wöchentliche cloud ausfall für dich brauchst nichts ausgefallen
Das ist gar nicht mal schlecht, dass er das als Markdown da raushaut.
Okay, also, ohne Scheiß, die OCR hier ist richtig nice.
Die eingebaute OCR ist nicht so geil.
ok also ich sehe wir müssen beides in kombination verwenden wir müssen das gpt
verwenden für ocr ganz im ernst wir können dem auch auch noch mal sagen er
soll hier nochmal generate suggestions
aber der andere ist deutlich schneller für text und sowas
andere war ja in 15 sekunden oder so durch mit der ganzen tag sache
Wie ist das eigentlich? Wie kann ich denn jetzt einstellen? Es gibt doch hier irgendwie so was
wie Workflows habe ich gesehen. Man kann irgendwie so Workflows einstellen hier und
sagen, er soll automatisch was hochladen.
Hier, Trigger.
Consumption started.
Document
added, Document updated.
Dann kann er sagen, Document added.
Actions.
Ah, dann muss ich den Webhook callen wahrscheinlich.
Webhook von
Peppaless GPT. Was ist denn der Unterschied
zwischen den beiden? Also so wie ich das jetzt
auf den ersten Blick sehe, ist
Paperless GPT kann
OCR und
kann Tech und sonstige
Generations.
Paperless AI kann
nur Tech Generation und sowas,
hat aber auch einen Chat,
wo man zum Thema,
zu seinen Dokumenten eine AI
fragen kann.
Hier kann ich nicht den Dark Mode anmachen.
Das sieht kacke aus.
Also, wahrscheinlich ist es gar nicht so verkehrt, das in Kombination zu benutzen.
Jetzt müssen wir mal checken, was besser ist.
Ja, also, welche der KIs besser ist für was.
Man muss schon mal sagen, die Paperless AI ist deutlich schneller bei Texts und Suggestions.
Ich weiß, dass man Dark Mode anmachen kann.
Das sieht aber kacke aus.
Guck.
Das ist ganz grausam hier, der Dark Mode.
Guck dir das mal an.
Üh.
Das ist nix.
Vielleicht ist es so ein Ding, wo man sich dran gewöhnen muss.
Keine Ahnung.
Also das hier ist ein schönes Dark Mode Theme.
Das geht auch.
Aber das gefällt mir gar nicht.
Viele haben die Workflows auch über N8N gemacht.
Ich will es jetzt nicht unnötig verkomplizieren.
Okay, er war fast fertig gewesen.
Taugt Paperless was?
Also ich würde sagen, das kann, wenn man
sich da ein bisschen Mühe gibt und das alles schön
tunet, so wie es sein soll, sehr praktisch
sein.
Bin mal gespannt, ob die
Suggestions für Tags und Sachen da so
viel besser ist, als bei dem anderen.
Weil der eine braucht, also Paperless
AI braucht für diese Tags und
und Zusammenfassungen und sowas.
Da braucht es
15 Sekunden und das hier
rödelt hier mehrere Minuten rum.
Das mag
wahrscheinlich daran liegen, dass der Prompt einfach
größer ist.
Vermute ich jetzt
einfach mal.
übrigens ich kann es noch mal sagen es schön dass so viele von euch heute mit am start sind
sehr nice ich hoffe euch gefällt das stream
wenn es euch gefällt wisst ihr ja könnt ihr jetzt follow klicken wenn ihr das noch nicht gemacht habt
wenn ich sehr nice um nicht zu sagen wenn ich das
michael furcht spiele jahren bis da ich auch noch da weil ich weiß der markt dieses im ort
immer da will wenn es nach ihm geht will ich muss ich das den ganzen stream über spam
Wie, dann braucht das Ding eigentlich...
Also, ich glaube...
Also, ich tendiere.
Ich tendiere aktuell...
Ich tendiere aktuell dazu
Peppaless AI für alles andere
und Chat und Peppaless GPT
für OCR.
Ah, hier schlägt er jetzt Sachen vor.
Okay. Review and edit suggested titles. Rechnung. Okay, da ist auch viel.
Stellung, Kopfhörer, Musik, Rechnung, AI-Prozess, Steuer.
Äh.
Ist da jetzt irgendein Unterschied?
Ah, Moment. Der benutzt nur Tags, die angelegt sind.
Okay, nachdem das nicht so viel besser ist, dann werde ich das wahrscheinlich so machen.
Dann werde ich das wahrscheinlich wirklich so machen.
Paperless GPT.
Paperless GPT für OCR.
und paperless für text generation sonst was jetzt probieren wir mal was jetzt probieren
wir mal was moment moment rock paperless ich muss jetzt irgendwie dafür sorgen dass der
das erst prozess wenn der andere fertig ist okay moment ist das muss ich mir jetzt erst
mal überlegen dazu schalten wir mal stopp das hier aus workflow gpt workflow wie macht man das jetzt
workflow
Okay, gibt es ein Video dazu, schauen wir mal. Aber das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht komplett an,
ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor. Papyrus GPT Overview.
Jeter, was zu Workflows?
Guck mal, man kann hier auch einen Status für
hab ich schon bezahlt und so machen. Das ist auch nice.
Ja, sieht man da jetzt aber leider nicht so richtig.
Schritt für Schritt erklärt.
ok youtube spackt wiederum
workflow hier workflow also ok dokument erstellen gibt hier ereignis neues dokument
Aktion Tag Paperless GPT Auto.
Ach, so machen die das.
Moment, ich...
Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Okay, das ist eigentlich
Pfeifett. Das ist eigentlich Pfeifett.
GPT soll
nur verarbeiten, wenn Paperless
GPT Auto dran steht.
Das Ding ist nur,
Da muss ich nochmal in die Settings rein.
Weil
ich will ja wirklich nur OCR machen.
Auto.
Auto OCR Tag.
Option. Default. Paperless.
GPT OCR Auto.
Auto. Ach, hier kann man nur
Auto OCR machen.
Sehr gut. Sehr gut.
Also heißt es im Endeffekt, wir müssen hier hin.
Workflow.
Okay.
Trigger.
Neues Dokument.
document added action es sein tag
okay ach so aber mein arzt ist ja geil ich abbrechen tags create wir brauchen
jetzt ein tag gabe paypal es wollte ich habe gerade irgendwie gesagt gay gay
gay palace paypal es perron bla bla bla net
du kannst es auch einfach als inbox tag machen das check ich noch nicht so genau
was es ist in box texte automatisch ist sein tool konsumt documents oder egal was
No Disable Matching machen wir.
Zack.
Alles, was du an Paypal schickst, bekommt das Tag.
Okay.
Ja, Moment, aber der soll den ja entfernen, nachdem er fertig ist damit.
Deswegen, ich glaube, das ist mit dem Workflow besser.
document added
assignment tags okay
assign owner debian assign title nix user
debian okay mach mal so dann passt das
Okay, save.
Chat.
Ach hier, Name.
OCR.
Sort Order.
Null.
Ach, das sind welche Reihenfolge,
die Sachen ausgeführt werden.
Okay, verstehe.
So, von der Idee her.
Jetzt machen wir hier Beispiel Rechnung
Online Shop.
Bilder.
So, hier. Genau. Shopify Rechnungsvorlage.
Ganz toll.
Frau. Mathilda Musterfrau.
So.
Safe Image
as Shopify Rechnungsvorlage.
So.
Da machen wir das mal aus.
Back. Wollen wir nicht.
Zack. So. Und jetzt
adden wir das.
Und von der Idee her sollte der jetzt ja automatisch diesen Workflow ausführen.
Äh, was genau macht das Ding da gerade?
Also, dann wollen wir mal das Upload Document.
Okay, so
Und jetzt
Ah, guck mal
Der hat schon gecheckt
Guck
Er fängt an zu OCR'en
Hat nicht funktioniert
Ist wieder kaputt gegangen
GPU hängt
Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß, Alter
Die GPU hängt überhaupt nicht
labern hätte alle los aber ich immer olama neu starten dass es funktioniert
das muss ich auch noch fixen
probiert das jetzt wenigstens noch mal neu aus wenn es einmal fehlgeschlagen
ist
EPU-Hang.
Ist das einfach random, wie das auftritt?
Probiert er das dann irgendwann nochmal?
Äh.
Moment, ist das das Falsche?
Hm.
Macht er das nochmal, nachdem es abgekackt ist, oder?
Es wird gerade wieder abgekackt, oder?
GPU hängen.
Könnte das sein, dass der Probleme hat?
System CTL.
Stopp.
Weil Ulama hier auch läuft.
Wenn Ulama zweimal läuft, dass der dann irgendwelche Probleme hat?
Gucken wir nochmal.
Der sollte den Kram jetzt ja eigentlich nochmal submitten.
Okay, jetzt läuft er wieder.
Und?
Macht der jetzt was?
GPU hängen.
Geil.
Das ist nicht sonderlich zuverlässig.
Kann man da was gegen machen?
IMD Rock'em Driver
Suckt, so wie es aussieht
Wenn du aus VRAM rausfährst.
So, jetzt kann er es hoffentlich gleich nochmal probieren.
Und bei der Request Auto-Feedback, vielleicht sollte ich das mal...
Vielleicht sollte ich das mal...
Okay.
Okay, Chat, wisst ihr was?
Wir rebooten jetzt nochmal.
Reboot.
Aber das ging doch vorher auch.
Oh Mist.
Warte mal, 144.
Wir gehen jetzt ins Bios.
Ich geb dir mal ein bisschen mehr V-Gramm.
Ja, mir geht's gut.
Pog.
Nelly Pog.
So, gucken wir mal.
Setup.
Ah, Sekunde Leute.
Ich muss mal mein anderes Handy noch holen.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, ich kann euch auch sagen, warum ich mein anderes Handy holen musste.
Ich habe heute 19 Uhr einen Reboot von 8 Servern gescannt auf der Arbeit.
Ich habe gesagt, sollte es wieder mal nicht funktionieren, rufe halt einfach an.
Deswegen muss ich wenigstens so tun, als bin ich am Start.
Ja, ich bin immer noch live.
6 Stunden 22.
Das ist ganz ungewohnt.
Gibt es da wenigstens Kohle dafür?
Nee, nachdem das offiziell nicht beantragt ist,
gibt es da keine
Kohle für.
Wo muss ich jetzt nochmal hin hier?
AMD CBS.
Da hin.
GRMX.
Kannst du übernehmen. Easy. Nice.
Du wirst übrigens
ordentlich auch bezahlt dafür. So nice.
Okay, sagen wir
ihm jetzt mal specify. 16
10 Gig, ja klar.
Okay, Leute, machen wir mal 2 Gig, okay?
2 Gig
VRAM, das muss reichen.
Weil, weil eigentlich
ist es ja so,
der kann auch mehr RAM anfordern.
Aber
dieses 2 Gig ist, glaube ich, was mindestens
reserviert ist.
800 Euro brutto für die ganze Woche.
Für die ganze Woche nachts, oder wie ist das bei dir?
Das ist okay, aber da geht schon mehr.
Wäre schon nice.
Der letzte 6 Jahre...
Hey man, das ist eigentlich ganz nice, ist so meine Zusammenfassung.
Wobei ich noch bei weitem nicht alles gecheckt habe.
Also starten wir Paperless-Container.
Achso, Moment.
Erstmal
ZFS entsperren.
Paperless starten wir auch.
Ja.
Ups.
Äh.
Achso, war das.
Okay.
nv top
jetzt haben wir 2 gig
docker compose
Moment, ich bin gerade verwirrt
wir sind in der anderen Kiste
äh
Zack Leute, wartet mal
jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt, wo sind wir jetzt hier
wir sind auf der Olamakiste
Journal CTL.
Das wollen wir uns angucken.
Und hier müssen wir jetzt auf die Debian-Kiste.
Und da gibt's
jetzt...
Da gibt's jetzt...
Cloud-Speicher, das müsste funktionieren.
Das müsste mit jedem Cloud-Speicher funktionieren,
der sich unter Linux mounten lässt als Ordner.
Dann kriegt der Paperless davon überhaupt nichts mit.
So, Docker Compose up.
Ach so.
Ah, Paperless läuft, okay.
Docker Compose up.
Dann bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
NV Top.
Okay, der macht Dinge.
Der macht Dinge.
Und anscheinend ist der jetzt auch nicht mehr out of memory.
Guckt mal.
Das scheint jetzt zu funktionieren.
Paperless.
Paperless GPT, wo immer es ist.
Das scheint jetzt zu funktionieren.
Ob das wirklich am VRAM liegt, weiß ich nicht.
Zwischendurch ging es ja vorher auch mal.
So.
Der ist fertig.
Okay, der hat jetzt OCR.
Document.
Rechnung.
Paperless GPT.
Content.
Ah, guck dir mal, wie schön er OCR hat.
Der braucht den...
Also, VRAM und RAM ist bei mir genau das Gleiche.
Der kann auch mehr anfordern.
Deswegen will ich eigentlich so wenig wie möglich haben,
dass ich auch RAM, weil das ist vom System RAM abgezwackt.
Das kann ich da nicht für anderes benutzen.
Wohin ging umgedreht, der auch immer mehr anfordern kann, wenn frei ist.
Was ist mit E-GPU? Das brauchen wir zu viel Strom.
Du meinst über Oculink oder sowas.
Deine Firma Name GmbH.
Titel.
Aber das ist...
Also man muss sagen, der OCR hier ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
So, wir brauchen jetzt nochmal eine andere Sache.
Rechnung.
Beispiel.
Irgendwas, was da mit dem Handy...
Irgendwas, was mit dem Handy fotografiert wurde.
Irgendwas, was halt richtige...
Was ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen reutische Qualität hat, so.
Foto.
Moment, sieht aus wie ein Dokument von der IHK.
Kann ich nach schlechter Qualität suchen?
Das geht nicht.
Ich brauche mal irgendeine Rechnung mit einer Kackqualität, Alter.
Oder schräg eingescannt oder sowas.
Abfotografiert.
Ja. Ah, hier.
Excellent.
Problem ist nur, das ist so klein.
Telekom-Rechnung.
Ja, toll.
Massenbong.
Okay, okay, top.
Amazon rettet
das wieder.
Amazon rettet's
wieder. Okay, und dann fragen
wir jetzt als nächstes, Chat, pass mal auf.
Als nächstes
fragen wir
Paperless AI, was der
Gesamtrechnungsbetrag ist.
Wobei das hier halt ein bisschen abgeschnitten ist.
Ja, vom EDK.
Das hier können wir nehmen.
Das ist auch ganz gut.
Das ist auch keine gute Quali.
Wir nehmen mal das.
Ich glaube, das hier ist sogar
nochmal eine ganze Ecke anspruchsvoller.
Ich glaube, das ist
nochmal ein bisschen anspruchsvoller.
Save Image S.
Es gibt nur
Paperless NGX, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, was anderes gibt es gar nicht.
Upload Documents.
Kassenbomb.
So, und der sollte es jetzt eigentlich sofort checken.
Und gleich loslegen.
Mit Scannen.
Guck hier.
Paperless GPT-OC.
Warum sind denn die Dinger schwarz-weiß?
Äh.
Okay, whatever.
Kunst?
Das OCRt, Leute.
Das ist der Dark Mode.
Okay.
Warum macht der mit Thumbnails sowas?
Da sollte er eigentlich überhaupt keinen Einfluss drauf haben.
Oh, das macht ihm ein bisschen zu schaffen hier.
Er OCRt immer noch.
Das ist auch ein gemeines Bild.
Wäre doch nice, wenn er das OCR auch in die PDF-File packt.
Meinst du?
warum welches model verwendest du mit olama
wenn 38 b und mini cmp oder so was ist das wurde da empfohlen zu benutzen ich mache mal einfach mal
Also der OCR macht dem ganz schön zu schaffen, hä?
Der OCR-Scan macht dem ganz schön zu schaffen von den Kassenbons.
Übrigens, ich könnte jetzt sagen, ich scanne einfach nur noch auf Paperless GPT-Tags und das dann mit Paperless AI.
Wäre jetzt noch intelligent, wenn er daraus mehrere Dokumente machen würde.
Das stimmt, aber wir wollen es ja mal nicht übertreiben.
Kann es sein, dass einfach die Anzeige hier oben überhaupt nicht stimmt?
Hartoppo?
Ich habe letztens eine News gelesen.
Okay, Leute, ich schäme mich dafür.
Es war die Bild-Zeitung.
Das war in so einem News-Feed.
Ist das aufgetaucht?
Da hieß einer, da habe ich erst gedacht, das kann doch nicht sein, der hieß mit Vornamen Huso.
Was? Das ist doch Fake von der Bild.
Aber nein, der hatte wirklich Huso als Vornamen.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Aber doch, scheint so zu sein.
Kennst du B-Top? Ja, kenne ich, aber H-Top-Beste.
Österreich, Fisch des Jahres.
Der Huso-Fisch.
Aha.
Haha.
Der sieht aber abgedreht aus, der Huso-Fisch.
Nee, B-Top.
B-Top und B-Top plus plus, ist das nicht das Gleiche?
Ja, das ist das Gleiche.
Nee, nee, das ist nix.
Ganz ehrlich, ich kann damit nix anfangen.
H-Top-Beste, nach wie vor.
Es geht darum, dass es der österreichische Fisch des Jahres ist.
Boah, der OCR hat ja immer noch...
Chat, ich glaube, wir haben was gefunden, was das OCR-Model ziemlich fertig macht.
österreich des jahres 2025 der hausen auch genannt huso huso europäische hausen genannt
Das ist er hier, guck
Das ist der österreichische Fisch des Jahres 2025
Der sieht aber echt abgedreht aus, ne?
Der hat es bestimmt nicht leicht, ne?
Glaube ich auch nicht
Also gerade der hier hat es definitiv nicht leicht
Der ist ja immer noch am OCR
WTF?
Und es ist alles GPU, weil guck mal hier, CPU-mäßig macht der nix.
Habt ihr schon mal offline CPU-Kerne gesehen?
Ich hab die Kiste aufgemacht und hab einfach die zweite CPU aus dem Sockel rausgerissen.
Jetzt sind die offline.
Was braucht das Teil im Eidl?
Ich kann jetzt hier gerade nicht drauf gucken.
Also jetzt gerade, also ich kann dir sagen,
jetzt gerade braucht er
71 Watt.
Aber der ist auch ziemlich unter Last gerade.
Nicht deswegen, sondern weil die
gpu ich hier gerade gedöns macht ein 70 watt im eidel braucht der elf watt ungefähr jetzt mal
ehrlich was ist da los mit den offline kurs das ist ein lxc container ich habe dem einfach nur
fünf zugriff auf fünf kerne erlaubt und nicht auf alle das ist alles elf watt ist richtig gut
dafür die ganzen ukrain nassus die bisschen mehr power haben die haben 20
und auch nur wenn er schon ordentlich bios getweakt hast also immer immer mit
zehn gig interface ab ohne zehn gig interface noch mal immer so 33 4 watt
weniger
Und immer drei SSDs drin.
Und halt 10 Gig Interface ab.
Wie lange braucht der denn für das OCR von den Kassenbongs, Alter?
Chat, ich glaube, da haben wir was gefunden, mit dem der überhaupt nicht gut klarkommt.
Wie funktioniert das OCR von Paperless NGX im Vergleich zu dem hier?
deutlich schlechter das gute an dem gestürzten ocr ist dass der am ende das
ocr als markdown einfügt was du dann im nachhinein auch super weiterverarbeiten
kannst also und die erkennung ist auch viel besser
kann man mit paperless auch die pdf von der börse einlesen oder wird das in ich
weiß nicht wie viele pdf und wie groß ist also mit paperless selbst bestimmt
wie performant es dann wird nach einer ganzen weile keine ahnung aber nachdem
paperless selbst ja erst einmal nur relativ statisch ist nachdem er einmal
ocr durchgelaufen ist wobei der pdf muss ja nicht mal ocr durchlaufen ist ja
relativ ist ja relativ statisch so pdf das geht damit bestimmt sage ich jetzt
einfach mal aber was wo du wirklich ordentlich hardware bräuchte es ist wenn
du da per ki tags generieren willst und zusammenfassung und sowas da brauchst du
brauchst du ordentliche hardware dafür bei tausenden seiten pro pdf oder du
wartest halt ein monat pro pdf wenn du aber diese ganzen ki features nicht
verwenden willst ist es wahrscheinlich relativ simpel pdf abzulauen
Du brauchst kein OCR bei PDFs.
Da ist ja schon Text drin.
Oder meinst du PDFs, wo einfach nur Bilder drin sind,
die OCRt werden müssen?
Für mich ist ein PDF ein Dokument,
wo tatsächlich schon Text drin ist.
Oder willst du das nochmal OCRn?
Oder musst du das OCRn,
was in dem PDF drin ist?
Erst mal kurz hier was checken.
Sensor.
Sensors.
64 Grad die CPU jetzt.
Ist schon ein bisschen wärmer geworden.
Äh, was bin ich
in diesem Dokument sehend?
Was ist?
Leute, ich muss mal kurz runter.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist schon Text.
Das musst du ja nicht OCR'en.
So, ich muss mal kurz runter.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Hier gibt es eine Runde Askequarium für euch.
Und ein...
Renn-Pepo.
So, gleich wieder da.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
So, geschafft
Ist das eigentlich fertig mittlerweile?
OCR? Der OCR, der kennt
immer noch. Leute, ich glaube, wir haben ihn kaputt
gemacht. Ich glaube, wir haben es
zerstört
Diese Kassenbongs machen den fertig.
Das funzt nicht sonderlich gut.
Die letzten Dokumente hat er in 15 Sekunden OCRt.
Für den Kassenbong braucht er jetzt irgendwie eine halbe Stunde oder so.
Zeig mal das Log.
Ne, warte mal.
Da.
Wie hat er angefangen?
Der hängt, oder?
18.06 hat er angefangen.
Und seitdem macht er nichts mehr.
Das Dumme ist, ganz ehrlich, ich will nicht, dass sowas in der Endlosschleife hängen bleibt.
Mir wäre es lieber, es gäbe ein Limit, wo man sagen kann, ich breche das ab.
Nach 5 Minuten OCR.
Aber das hat ihn fertig gemacht hier, dieses Bild.
Hat er da oben die Positionen?
Kein Schimmer.
Nee, eher nicht, weil die immer gleich groß sind.
Ich glaube, der hat die Bilder, der hat das Bild einfach aufgeteilt in acht Slices.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht so geil.
Okay, ich brech mal ab.
Ich brech mal ab.
und gibt es gibt es ein limit wo wir sagen können ocr limit pages
limit
was ist denn das hier eigentlich ocr processing mode was was macht es da irgendwie sinn
converts pdf pages to images bevor processing juckte nicht
also das hat ihn ziemlich kaputt gemacht probieren was man damit
dass es das ist deutlich kleiner und sollte easy sein lassen bogen
Moment, der fängt jetzt bestimmt gleich wieder an, das zu verarbeiten, weil ich es gerade wieder gestartet habe, oder?
Ich habe es noch nicht wieder gestartet.
Ich lösche mal dieses Ding hier.
Delete.
Move to Trash.
So, dann starten wir es wieder.
Ich habe zu viele Fenster auf, Leute.
So.
Dashboard, Upload, Custom Bong.
liegt eventuell auch daran dass das bild 19 18 millionen pixler wie sowas für eine auflösung
hatte hatte das denn überhaupt kummer 8.200 mal 875 überhaupt kein ding doch gar kein ding
Das hat sogar mehr.
Ja, ich probiere gerade einen kleinen Kassenbon.
Successfully processed document.
Guck, hat funktioniert.
Gar kein Problem.
Hat funktioniert innerhalb von 15 Sekunden.
Ja.
Oder auch nicht.
Doch, hat funktioniert.
Aber sollte jetzt nicht eigentlich Paypal das GPT dran stehen?
Nee, hat funktioniert. Guck.
Hat funktioniert.
Ne, guck halt vor.
Hatsch, hatsch.
Ne, ne, das hat funktioniert.
Guck, der hat hier
dran stehen.
also der hat das, warum er das nicht richtig getaggt hat, keine Ahnung,
aber der hat das OCR entfernt
und hat hier den ganzen anderen Kram dran geschrieben, hier, bla, Steuer, sonst was,
so, und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was
ähm,
Paperless AI dazu sagt,
oh, ich kack noob, ich muss das nochmal,
T-Mux, Docker Compose Up,
Docker Start.
Paperless AI.
Logs.
So, jetzt mal Paperless AI.
Ich habe zu viele Fenster auf.
Das ist mir gerade zu undurchsichtig.
Paperless AI macht einfach gar nichts.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es am Prozessen ist.
Es prozest, Leute.
Paperless AI ist hart am Prozessen.
Das ist so hart am Prozessen, dass das Webinterface nicht mehr lädt.
Ich prozesse gerade noch hier Tee.
Ich prozesse deutlich lieber Tee als Bier.
Guck, da ist es wieder.
Prozessed.
Shopify-Vorlage.
Kassenbogen wird prozessed.
Bin ich mal gespannt, was er da prozest.
Karstenbogen ist prozest worden.
Gucken wir mal.
E-Center? Bonus?
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Close all.
Edeka Handelsgesellschaft.
Bla bla bla.
Aber einfach nur Edeka würde reichen.
Aber guck mal hier.
Bonus E-Center Einkauf.
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel, ehrlich gesagt.
So, dann fragen wir jetzt mal.
Okay, wir fragen ihn jetzt mal.
Wie oft habe ich Bauchspeck gekauft?
Ne, die Summe...
Wie, wie, wie...
Wie teuer war der Bauchspeck allein
in der letzten...
Was ist das hier jetzt?
Ne, ne, ne.
Das wollen wir nicht. Wir wollen...
Chat, ich hab vergessen,
wie es funktioniert hier. Chat, so muss ich.
Please choose document.
E-Center Hedeka.
Da hat das,
würde ich sagen, das OCR nicht so gut
funktioniert. Hedeka.
oder Hit Car.
Also.
Wie viel
hat der
oder Getränke?
Das checkt es nicht.
Wie hoch
ist die
Wie viel hat der Bauchspeck zusammen auf dieser Rechnung insgesamt gekostet?
Das geht auf alle im Paperless gleichzeitig, der Chat.
Doch, doch.
Kann ich dir gleich zeigen.
So, es denkt jetzt erstmal.
Das kann ich dir gleich zeigen.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht übel.
Es denkt wieder.
Du hast doch das Dokument erst auswählen müssen.
Jaja, warte mal ab.
Zeige ich dir gleich.
Wenn er das noch schafft,
mit einer sinnvollen Antwort hier zu
generaten.
Ist das N5R echt so gut
als bis jetzt? Finde ich sehr nice.
Es hat ein paar kleine...
Wie nennt man Sachen, die noch
ein bisschen doof sind, weil es noch so neu ist.
Kinderkrankheiten, sowas, ja.
Zum Beispiel ist der Linux Support für das Netzwerkinterface,
für das 10-Gig-Netzwerkinterface so semi-gut, ja.
Okay, die KI ist zu dumm, Leute.
Die checkt es nicht.
Der Preis des Bauspecks wird in der Rechnung nicht einzeln angegeben.
Doch.
Wird er.
Kostet 1,19.
Dentke.
Chat Dentke.
Richtige Hardcore Dentke KI.
So ist sie hier.
Guck.
Eindeutig.
Dentke.
Doch wird er.
Guck nochmal genau nach.
Pass auf, jetzt ist es komplett überfordert.
Wie kommt ihr auf 13,11 Euro?
Sehr gute Frage.
14,84 Euro.
Ach, hier unten.
Die hat recht.
Guck mal, die KI hat recht.
Ach, Moment, nee.
Das ist die Summe Mehrwertsteuer.
Das ist, wie viel Mehrwertsteuer man da drauf bezahlt hat.
Also mit Kassenzetteln ist er noch ein bisschen überfordert, würde ich sagen.
Aber das ist ja, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, ne.
Das ist ja eh nur Spielerei.
Letztendlich ist mir wichtig, dass es einen gescheiten Titel generiert und gescheite Tags.
So dieses Durchsuchen, naja.
Die Rechnung enthält keine exklusiven Preisergaben für Bauchspeck.
Doch!
Ey, das stimmt nicht.
Der Bauchspeck kostet einzeln 19.
Der Bauchspeck kostet 1,01.
Das ist doch richtig, was ich geschrieben habe.
Keine Angabe für den...
Doch!
Also ist hartnäckig ist hartnäckig
Ok useless useless komplett useless
Du kannst hier guck mal es gibt hier einen chat der geht über alle dokumente
Das habe ich aber selbst noch nicht noch nicht ausprobiert
start indexing ich weiß nicht was jetzt passiert
Indexing startet
hat das jetzt funktioniert
kannst du dir die chunks anschauen du meinst
hier
Wie hoch war meine letzte Edeka Rechnung? Der denkt ja nicht, dass es Edeka heißt,
er denkt das heißt Hüdeka oder Hüdeka oder irgendwie komisch.
Ah jetzt ist es kaputt gegangen. Chat ich glaube es ist kaputt oder auch nicht.
Searching is search in progress
Mal gucken, ob der so schlau ist
Und feststellt, dass EDK
Und RTK oder so, wie der das genannt hat
Das gleiche ist
Dann sagt er bestimmt wieder 13,11 Euro
Diese Information ist nicht enthalten in den Dokumenten
Doch
Hittika
Useless
Okay
Wie hoch ist die letzte
Rechnung
Von Hittika
Von E-Center
Sehr gute Frage
Also Hittika
Irgendjemand wollte wissen was der hier macht
Was Ulama hier macht
Dinger.
Stimmt, Edeka Handelsgesellschaft
hat er erkannt.
Warum erkennt er nicht, dass
vom Edeka... Das ist nicht
so richtig gut, das Zeug.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
dafür will ich es auch nicht verwenden.
Ich will einfach nur gutes OCR haben
und sinnvolles Tagging.
Am besten auf Basis von meinen Tags.
Ich will gar nicht, dass er sich selbst Tags ausdenkt.
Michael50BD, ah, da bist du ja wieder am Start.
Ich hab gerade schon gefragt, wo du bist.
Guck mal, ich hab gerade dein Lieblings-Emo ein bisschen gespammt.
Weil ich mir gedacht hab, du bist noch da.
Okay.
Die Bankverbindung.
Wie hoch ist die letzte Rechnung von Helika?
Die Bankverbindung der Firma muss...
Okay, das ist komplett useless.
Komplett useless.
Bringt überhaupt nichts.
Vielleicht ist ein anderes Model gut.
Vielleicht taugt das Model einfach nur nichts.
Das ist eigentlich richtig gut, diese Frage.
Weil dazu musst du tatsächlich den Zusammenhang, also musst du den Satz verstehen.
Und nicht einfach nur sinnlos Text generieren.
Ich finde das eigentlich eine richtig gute Frage.
Weil da muss die AI was mitmachen, was du nicht anhand des Textes erkennen kannst.
Nämlich, dass du fahren musst, wenn du das Auto waschen willst.
Das ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Kaiji-Bait-Frage.
Also diese Chatfunktion
Und so, das ist echt Spielerei
Ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie was
Sinnvolles ausspuckt
Vielleicht, vielleicht
Wenn du es bei den großen Models online machst
vielleicht das könnte natürlich sein wenn du es bei einem großen model rein
haus dass es deutlich besser noch mal ist weil die sind alle besser als die
lokalen models also nicht alle die sind umgekehrt die sind also die die großen
model sind der regel besser als alle lokal models aber für automatisches tag
generieren und so was da muss ich sagen finde ich das eigentlich ganz nice
Korrespondent.
Hier.
Edeka Handelsgesellschaft Nordbayern Sachsen-Thüringen MbH.
Ah ja, mit denen wollte ich schon immer.
Last Used.
2007.
Gar nicht schlecht.
Doch, ich glaube, Paperless ist was, was einem richtig viel Arbeit und Gesuche ersparen kann.
Das wollte ich sagen.
Man muss aber ein bisschen Arbeit investieren.
Und so wie ich mich kenne, fange ich damit motiviert an, aber nach spätestens 3-4 Monaten ist das Ding komplett versaut und man kann es nicht mehr benutzen.
Und dann benutze ich es nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, dass das mit AI-Tagging tatsächlich besser ist, als mit dem Paypal-Kram.
Hattest du vorhin meine Nachricht gesehen mit der Polizei?
Ne, was denn?
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ist auch nicht mehr drin, was denn?
Sag mal, was war?
Warst du in irgendeiner Kontrolle oder?
Von ein paar Stunden her.
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Sag nochmal.
Ah ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ah, du hast recht.
Ich kann ja deine Messages angucken.
Das ist immer Twitch-Experte hier am Start.
Hatte mal, ah hier hab ich's, hier hab ich's.
Ritzkohl hat geschrieben, hatte mal einen Dokumentenscanner mit einem Rack, also mit so einem Chat, für die Polizei gebaut.
Der hat leider immer den Sachbearbeiter als Täter identifiziert.
tja
KI
erinnert mich
ein bisschen
an die hier
ich kann es nur noch mal sagen
Chat, wisst ihr eigentlich
oder eine andere
Frage mal, für alle die es nicht wissen
bin ich mal gespannt
Auf welche Technologie basiert das Startmenü?
Ist das neu?
Dass das Startmenü so komisch aussieht hier unten
Auf was basiert das Startmenü?
Ihr wisst, ihr habt aufgepasst
Das ist eine React Native Anwendung glaube ich
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es in React Native
Aber wäre sinnvoll
Ist auf jeden Fall eine React Anwendung
also unter der haube ist das ein javascript ist es ja ja das ist ja was
kripp anwendungen webview ist das also wenn es webview ist es keine react native
anwendung oder dann ist es im endeffekt einen browser mit javascript
wahrscheinlich noch ein fucking node.js oder so im hintergrund ja das startmenü
ist eine javascript anwendung klasse und ich bin mir sogar also so in
meiner gedankenwelt bin ich mir sogar relativ sicher warum microsoft das gemacht hat wisst ihr warum ich denke dass microsoft das gemacht hat
weil ki
viel besser ist in javascript generierung als in native
windows api kram
wenn du da kaisers generell generiere mir
ein c programm das die windows api benutzt um das und das zu machen
kommt da viel schlechter ergebnisse raus wie generell in der webseite mit javascript
Also meine Vermutung ist, dass sie besser Vibe-Coden können.
Ist das.
Wieso? Das Startmenü wurde doch auch schon dreimal ausgetauscht.
Ich bin immer noch am streamen, ja.
Aber jetzt ist es vorbei, Leute.
Alter, sieben Stunden, zehn Minuten.
Ich glaube, so lange habe ich noch nie gestreamt.
Kann das sein?
Noch nie.
Doch, ich bin mit meinen Kräften am Ende.
Ich kann nicht mal weiter streamen.
Außerdem muss ich mal schnell auf der Arbeit gucken, ob der Remote funktioniert hat.
Wen soll ich raiden?
Twitch?
Kenn ich nicht.
Testing a new Microscope.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was man da sieht.
Irgendwelche CPU?
Nee, kein Schimmer.
Chat? Oh, fuck.
Mein Browser ist dead.
Was ist jetzt los?
Okay, geht wieder.
Den raiden wir jetzt.
Der RF-Programmer sagt, es taugt.
Ich vertraue meinem Chat.
Wir sehen uns dann wahrscheinlich morgen früh zum Aufwach-Stream.
Wer noch nicht gefollowt hat, kann mir jetzt ein Follow dalassen.
Würde mich freuen.
Und wir sehen uns dann im nächsten Stream, Leute.
Macht's gut. Bis denn.
See you!